this is all my best presentations and
videos on sales you could call it my
Ultimate Guide enjoy selling with logic
to make lots of money and so this will
either be the best presentation on sales
you've ever heard the worst presentation
on sales you've ever heard or somewhere
in between that is a promise all
right and so I thought it would make
sense to start with this we have a high
this is Charlie Monger who's probably
like my number one hero in this season
of My Life
um we have a high moral responsibility
to be rational and I think that getting
someone to rationally decide is
important because emotional buyers often
times get excited they'll buy and then
who's had somebody who calls him two
days later it's like I don't know why
anybody raise your hand just so you know
you're not alone okay and what happens
is it's just like dating I think Lea
talked about it yesterday if you have a
rational foundation for a relationship
or a decision when the emotions fade the
logic will continue and so it's good to
to answer both sides of the
decision-making process the short-term
side is the emotion that gets you to
decrease your astion threshold and take
a step right but the logic is what makes
it stick and actually makes a great
customer all right and so for me and I
think that the further along you get in
business and the higher up you get in
business the more you'll see people who
tend to make more logical decisions more
logic first decisions and fewer and
fewer emotional decisions all right so
what does being a rational sorry what
does rational logical have to do with
selling well you have logical buyers and
you have emotional buyers in general
right most people sit on this Continuum
one way or the other and emotionally
people want to believe you people want
to buy you must help their logical
brains justify to decision that they
already want to make think about it that
way they want to buy from you you have
to help them all right so who here
identifies actually I'll skip through
this emotional logical you're probably
in between anybody in between these two
anyone all right then you'll love this
so before we get started I thought I
would give you a few beliefs about
selling that have served me very well
throughout the years number one people
want to believe you they want to buy you
must help their logical Brains Brains
justify the decision two selling happens
before you ask for the sale closing
happens after so you're selling for a
lot longer period of time but the moment
you kind of like take your pants
yourself and you're like this is what it
is that's when you're closing
right you have now
solicited now you
close three it's easier to handle
obstacles than objections I'll get to
what the difference between those are in
a
second that being said expect and plan
for no it is not failure it is expected
so stop being surprised it's one of the
first things we talk new sales guys into
is expect no that's not like that's a
part of this if they already were going
to say yes then you are not necessary no
is the job right if they could make the
decision on their own they would just
send you the money right the reason
they're struggling is because they can't
and they need your help which is why
sales is actually the first step in
coaching and I see sales as power if you
can have the ability to direct or
influence others that is power and I
feel like it should be made much cooler
than I feel like it is five if you
didn't get a gasp from a price tag you
didn't go high enough this is another
belief so for those of you who are
afraid to raise your price if you're not
getting gasps you're not going high
enough straight up and when you do it
that way you can always walk down and
have a beautiful price anchor right when
you say $100,000 first a grand feels
like a rounding error it's true but when
I say $10 first like I'm saying right
now $10 and I say a thousand sounds way
[__] bigger doesn't it so you got to
get the gasp and you got to train your
guys if you have a team they have to be
comfortable with the no and they have to
be comfortable with the gasp they got to
go for the gasp be like dude you should
have heard the gasp on this one right
there we go seven selling properly is
the first step becoming a coach right
your first impressions the expectations
you set dictate the relationship how you
sell the fact that you use logic in the
sale will set you up for success and
your client for success in the long run
eight selling is helping prospects make
decisions to help themselves like you
are helping them help themselves that's
where the power comes from you are not
helping them you're helping them help
them see the difference it's nuanced but
it's real nine keep the prospect not the
sale as the priority it's not about us
the more you can vanish in the sale and
and magnify them the better your selling
conversations will go because it's not
about us they don't care about you they
only care about them and they will talk
about themselves as long as they'll let
them this is a really important one
especially when you starts getting into
closing seek to understand not to argue
and the way that I train our sales teams
around this is childlike
curiosity so when someone says when
someone objects to something it's like
ha that's so weird I wouldn't have
thought that tell me more about that
right and you get to be able to maintain
that childlike curiosity the same way
they train fighters to not breathe too
much during a fight through exposure the
more more times you get into these
uncomfortable high stakes closing
scenarios the less weird and high stakes
they become because they become what you
do every day and the good thing is you
get to have this conversation hundreds
and thousands of times and they only get
to have it once so you [__] better be
better at it than them closing is a
dance not a fight it's seduction not
rape
I mean I'm being super serious about
this the goal is not to beat them into
submission the goal is to sell from your
back foot it's like I'm good I want to
help you help you and if that means not
doing this then I [__] love it I'm
with you I'm on your team and I'll give
you a bullet around that in a second
selling is a transference of belief over
a bridge of trust therefore there are
two things that are required You Must
Believe so that you can transfer it and
you must have trust to make the transfer
because if you truly believe and a lot
of times you anyone been on a hot streak
when they're selling anyone anyone who
just had their hand up ever been on a
cold
streak most times you go from hot to
cold not because you forgot how to sell
because you stop believing in why you're
selling you have the same skills as you
did the day before but sometimes you get
a text you get an email get a pain in
the ass customer you ask for a refund
whatever the hell it is right and then
you question yourself and so that bridge
might have been created but there was
nothing to walk across it because your
cup wasn't full and so that's why
especially it's you in the beginning but
your teams over time the process of
filling conviction is one of the easiest
and best ways to increase someone's
closing percentage better than any of
the training in the world if you get
someone to believe they will sell the
right way because they're doing it not
to make the deal because they want to
help the other person 16 you can only
build trust if you genuinely want to
help and humans are exceptionally good
at sniffing out intention is a survival
mechanism you have to know if someone's
trying to double cross you we're very
good at smelling it out and the reason a
lot of you guys can't close is because
you only care about closing belief and
Trust are a Continuum not binaries so
it's not you believe or don't believe
it's not they trust you or don't trust
you but how much do they trust you how
much do you believe how deeply do you
believe because anyone ever been around
somebody who just believes balls to
Bones something that you think's batshit
crazy like I mean all the way so much so
that you start to question what you
believe that's what real conviction does
18 closers ask hard questions and it's
because you genuinely care that's why
you do it it's why we're here who here
wants to impact thousands of lives and
help people then you got to [__] ask
hard questions because it's the only
thing that's going actually Pierce
someone's hard and actually get the
transformation to happen if you can't
make if you cannot have transformational
conversations you cannot coach and this
is the first step
the person who cares the most about the
prospect wins the sale that includes
them so if you care more about their
well-being than they do you will win and
if you are more convicted they will
question their own excuses because you
are so
certain little TI Little Nugget for you
record all your sales by the way because
when you do get on that hot streak right
when you get on that hot streak and then
you get cold
again watch your hot streak see where
you pause what jokes you made when you
asked for the sale when you didn't how
you overcame it and it'll get you back
in the flow much faster than trying to
question yourself what do I do what do I
do always record all your sales it's
also the easiest way to train new people
and then lastly
21 power is the ability to direct or
influence people if you want to be
powerful you must understand this skill
and that's what we're going to talk
about cool awesome when does selling
happen does it happen when they're a
lead does it happen when we're
qualifying them does it happen when we
solicit the sale does it happen when we
close the sale when does the selling
happen all the time the entire time
selling is happening but what are we
going to talk about today just this just
closing everything you have to do after
asking someone to buy why are we doing
that rather than the entire process
beyond the fact that we'd be here all
day the other reason and I love this is
that closing has one of the highest
predictors of success in business and
here's an analogy for it everyone
familiar with the NFL yeah great so
here's an insane statistic the top five
Red Zone offenses in the league now last
five years made the playoffs 90% of the
time here's why this is interesting and
crazy there's a million other stats they
could have horrible defenses they could
have terrible coaching they could have a
terrible whatever it is right they could
have all these things that are wrong
with their they could have Terrible
Special Teams
whatever but just this one set if
they're in the Red Zone they [__]
close and I can tell you if you have
this ability if you have this skill it
will make up for a tremendous amount of
deficiencies in other areas of your life
and business and it will buy you time to
learn those but if you can't close it's
very difficult to grow in business
especially in the beginning because it's
probably you that's why we're talking
about closing why is this important from
Money Getting
perspective well first off if you have
100 people walking the door 10% are
never going to buy just accept that
right problem is you don't know which
10% it
is but 10% are ever going to buy 10% are
always going to buy you just got to not
[__] it up and most of you guys these
are the only sales you're getting
they're like well I already I'm already
here my friend told me about you I have
my credit card out and some of you like
well you know let's make sure you're
like just shut the [__] just take the
card you know what I mean like shut up
right that's like hey my friend's so
awesome you got to meet him and she's
like oh my God he's great and then the
guy starts talking and she's like oh
just kidding you know
like terrible right but this is what we
fight for this is what we train and if
you want to make a big impact that's
what we're fighting for it's the middle
80 why this presentation will make you
money if after this presentation you
just have one more bullet one more play
In Your Arsenal to close where I get you
one more deal a month I'll feel like my
job was done all right and hopefully if
you just do that it'll pay for your
entire weekend all right that's my goal
for the presentation that everything
that you guys have done for this whole
weekend is paid for is that cool Fair
outcome all right so this is one of my
favorite sayings you're only one
decision away from changing your life
forever and whenever I feel overwhelmed
or I feel like I'm decreasing like I
feel powerless or I feel like I have
less power than I want to have I always
say this to myself because it's like I
can take one decision and change [__]
everything you know what I mean like I
can I can drink a bottle of Jack get the
car I can change everything with one
decision right I can make a step to to
invest in something I can buy something
I can invest in myself I can I can have
a terrible conversation with Laya or I
can have amazing conversation with Lea
but just one decision and that's always
given me power but the thing is is that
instead of changing our lives we blame
when I say blame I want you to think
give power to sources outside of our
control and this is what you and this is
what your prospects and your customers
are doing and this is why so many people
are Weak and Powerless and so we're
going to do a fun activity today because
I want you to be involved so you can
learn it and we're going to do this so
that one you can help decisions to help
yourself with whatever decisions you're
facing two you can use these Frameworks
to help prospects help themselves and
then three become more powerful so but
rather than keep this hypothetical I
need you to visualize the decision that
you need to make all right can you do
that for me fantastic and this is why I
want you to actually think through a
decision together because this is a
statement from confusious I hear and I
forget I see and I remember I do and I
understand so my goal here isn't for you
to take screenshots of every picture of
every slide that's not my point here
because the thing is is when you do that
and you kind of I mean this is why I do
it I take pictures so that I don't have
to remember it but I don't want you to
remember it I want you to understand it
if you understand it you won't have to
go back to your notes because let's be
real half the time you're not even going
to open these notes up again you're here
now with me try and understand if you do
that it can change your life because
what we're going to do is not going to
be some scripts that you have to
understand but the logic behind the
arguments that people will give you as
to why they are not choosing to become
more powerful and if you can unlock that
you people will feel more powerful
talking to you and they will want to buy
from you because of the feeling they
have does that make sense and so that's
when you're using logic to create an
emotion so you here here's an easy one
for it anyone here presented with the
decision last 24 hours yes great
fantastic so who thinks the a decision
could change your life for the better
great for the worse knows all right
let's go so here's my goal I want to
show you as though you were Prospect how
to think through a decision and help
others using these Frameworks right what
you want what you don't want maximize
the left minimize the right so here's
what this is translated to if you decide
to buy the offer you feel more certain
about your decision if you decided not
to buy the offer you feel [__]
certain about the decision and if you're
undecided you make a [__] decision
all right and you feel good that it's
the one that has the highest likelihood
of you getting you close to where you
want to go and this is what we have to
walk through with with our prospects
when you're looking at them you have to
be like I don't want you to buy I want
you to decide for you not for me I'll be
the same either way right you're like
I'm going to be ripped and in shape it's
not going to change me right like that's
not going to change but like it will
change for you right so quick note on
sales ethics and then we'll dive in
helping someone make a decision to help
themselves does not mean buy from you
that's a reiteration you have to keep
their goals at the center of the
decision and you should be happy I mean
this because if you can shift this truly
if you can be happy when someone decides
to own the power and not work with you
then the pressure around sales
disappears it evaporates there's no
stake the stake is did I help them does
that make sense and that means that you
can win every sale because you change
the metric you're measuring Yourself by
that's the superpower like and that's
where you do make the most sales because
you don't care about the sale because
you care about the person and the people
pay the people who pay the most
attention so what I call it paying
attention they pay for it they pay for
you to pay attention rather than talking
about yourself right CU they don't care
about you cuz they're thinking about 100
other things and this is why most
importantly make high stakes decisions
to help your prospects in order to best
serve them okay so I told you earlier I
was going to talk about the difference
between obstacles and objections couple
of you guys raised your hands about the
differences I'm not going to ask I'll
tell you what it is obstacle is a thing
that blocks one's way or prevents or
hinders progress when you disagree with
them that is an obstacle this happens
before you solicit the sale someone says
some [__] before you even get to the
sale that's an obstacle a simple example
I hear all the time hey why'd you hop on
the call today hey why'd you walk in the
gym today whatever it is right them I
just wanted to find out a little bit
more about the program first 10 seconds
obstacle you're not here to find out
more about the program I'm here cuz
you're fat but they got to say it so
you're like oh so you finding out like
do you do this all the time do you go to
lots of different programs it's find out
information or is there a problem you're
trying to solve they're like oh well you
know I'm trying to lose weight like oh
got it so you're not just hopping on 100
calls a day cuz I was like that would be
a very weird existence right you just
hop on for information all day ha great
fantastic I've had this conversation
before right so that's an obstacle right
and the thing is it's easy to confront
and Destroy obstacles before you ask for
the sale once you've asked for the sale
you switch to objections objections is
when they disagree with you do so it's
much easier to be on the other side
disagreeing and helping them break their
beliefs before the stake has been
presented after after the after you're
in the Red Zone it's all closing it's
all objection overcomes right example
that's like I don't want to buy right
now and you're like totally understand
what are the main criteria you're
thinking through which is always funny
because people are like I need to think
about I've never had someone like leave
because they need to think about it I'm
like cool what are you thinking
about and they're like oh I'm still
here right like so learning how to talk
through these high stakes decisions with
yourself or others is the purpose of
presentation and as a result you'll
become more powerful okay so before I
dive into these AR each of these
arguments I have to make this one
statement is that the person must really
want the
goal and believe three things one which
you'll get to it there we go the product
will get them the goal comma the way
they want to get there and I learned
that second half the hard way because we
found out in gym launch that people
would say no sometimes to buying
memberships right or buying challenges
or whatever but when we offered them the
ability to come back the next day help
them for free we'd sell them $400 of
supplements and they just said no to a
$100 down service thing I'm like what
the [__] it's because they want to lose
weight but they want to lose weight
their
way and so that's when I started
learning like oh not only do we have to
make sure that they want the goal and
they believe that the product's going to
get them there it has to get them there
the way they want to get there this
gives you ammo for the questions that
you're going to ask does this make sense
okay the second thing is that you and
others will support them like are you
telling me the truth is this really
what's going to happen will other people
around me support this decision and the
third is that it will work for them and
not just everyone else sure I've seen
the people who step on the stage but
they're different than me I'm a
snowflake I have metabolic thyroid keto
osis right whatever I have zero
influence oler whatever you know what I
mean like I have no following is itis
right whatever it is right whatever
[__] you tell yourself and what you
have to do in this situation you have to
Pride proof so that it'd be more
unreasonable not to believe than to
believe and this is a logical close this
is not a this is not an emotional close
this is when you look at someone and say
how many people would you need to see
for it to be more unreasonable for you
not to believe than to believe at what
point is it 10 is it 50 here's a
thousand tell me when to stop
okay okay okay great so that's not the
real reason and then you can confront
the real [__] all right so otherwise if
they're not sure of those things if they
don't actually want to lose weight if
you don't actually want to make money
doing online fitness then it doesn't
matter what Jason says you don't want to
make money doing online fitness then
you're not going to buy right if you do
want to make money doing online fitness
then you go down you go down the Train
the train tracks that make sense okay
again this is why you expect no at first
because if people could make the
decision they would have already made it
all right out of the main course Richard
feeman besides Charlie one of my
favorite thinkers of all time he was
like the second guy on uh the atom bomb
sounds negative brilliant teacher he's
known for this understand don't memorize
learn principles not formulas and that's
what the rest of this presentation is
about is the principles behind
overcoming these distortions that people
have and so this is me asking you for
your own sake don't take pictures of the
slides it's because all the stuff's
going to be in the recordings but you
are here now so be here now so you can
understand it okay so there are three
sources this is a huge breakthrough for
me so I'm going to share it with you
this first time try share to life there
are three sources that we cast our power
to okay and it took me a very long time
to get through this because I looked at
Grant and he had his you know you got
stall decision maker money then you talk
to Barry who owns Sage she's like you
got time fit uh money fear shame right
those are hers and then Jordan Belford's
got his and so everybody's got like
these are the only overcomes right I was
like there has to be
an actual truth here like there has to
be something that's true that's
uned and so trying to figure this out I
actually went back to Dr Albert Ellis
anybody who know who he is no one great
um who here knows what cognitive
behavioral therapy is CBT he invented it
smart
dude and so what he noticed is that he
originally had 11 distortions of reality
then he dropped it to nine then to seven
and then he came to three and the three
stuck and the three are what I'm about
to share with you and you're like why is
he talking about this about sales
because the objections that people offer
you where they cast their power to are
distortions of
reality they are the things we use to
upset
ourselves these are the three
circumstances and this is the irrational
statement that people make I must get
what I want when I want it I must not
get what I don't want if I don't get
what I want I can't stand it that's when
people blame their emotional
disturbances on emotional disturbances
on circumstances two others other people
must treat me fairly and kindly and if I
if they don't they are no good and
deserve to be condemned and punished
it's like your animal brain right three
self I must do well or else I am no good
these are the three core distortions
that upset people this is like mental
illness right and so I'm not saying
anyone has mental illness if they don't
agree with you it's more so that these
are distortions that are not real and if
you can understand not memorize if you
can understand this then you can have
these high stakes conversations
understanding exactly which Distortion
they're suffering from and I'll show you
how to overcome them okay and so I like
to consider like the onion of blame
people this is like one of the bigger
breakthroughs I had they start with the
outside they blame
circumstances time money other [__] and
then the step next to that they start to
blame other people my spouse my kids my
employees and then finally they say like
it's me it's my fault and so you might
have to overcome multiple layers as you
peel back and based on the objection
they give you you can know where you're
at you can know how close you are if
someone just says I have to think about
you're like great I'm talking to the
person who's in power and the decision
maker and I just need to get them to say
yes if they're like I don't have they're
casting the power away and some of you
guys are probably casting your power
away on decisions you need to make which
is why I'm making this presentation even
though that these are the things that
distort people's realities CU you're
like no one's ever said circumstances
are getting in my way right like no says
that right they manifest in five ways
that I want to equip you to deal with
all right for yourself and others so
these are the five most common excuses
scapegoats that people use for circum
and if you find other ones these are the
biggest buckets because I didn't want to
have a hundred things here but the big
three buckets are circumstances others
and self right but they manifest with
time in multiple ways and I'll show you
how value price money Etc fit I'm a
special snowflake others which is I
don't have the authority to make the
decision
and then finally self which is what if I
just don't make the decision let some
let life make it for me right avoidance
stall you go from surface level to core
and as a side note you should never get
stuck on the stuff near the top and
ideally you really never get stuck
anywhere on this equation if the person
wants what you have and you truly
believe in what you have to help them
and I mean that like if you understand
this thoroughly you can walk someone
towards helping themselves okay okay
this is what they look like or this is
what they sound like in
reality not a good not a good time right
now I'm really busy right that's time
can't afford it too expensive fit not
sure if it's for me I hate broccoli I
can't do a plan with broccoli right
can't do a plan where I have to DM
people every day it's against my brand
I'm poor but it's against my brand right
Authority have to talk to my partner
spouse I have to talk to somebody who
has more power than me it's funny
because when you start thinking this way
it sounds silly
and then avoidance I need to think about
it clearly let's think about it now all
right and so I told you I want you to
think about the principles Behind these
things not memorize you've got
circumstances you got other people and
you have yourself and we drill down so
quick test who here is physically in the
room raise your wonderful arms are
working we're rocking so here's my ask
raise your hand if you or your prospects
present with this
Distortion so who here is a Time person
I'm busy it's not a good time maybe in
the future anyone deal with these
sometimes it's yourself totally so I'm
also going to tell you a secret about
this I think the reason I got pretty
decent at logical arguments is because I
am inherently skeptical and I will
paralyze myself from not doing anything
unless I have really sound reasons to do
it and I realized that I couldn't move
forward to make any progress in my life
until I had these Frameworks to think
through these hard decisions through so
I could start taking steps to where I
where I wanted to go it took me years to
get there and so so hopefully I can give
you some keys that help me unlock my own
head to get out of my own [__] way so
that you can too and help your clients
all right so the way I think about time
and there's a lot of overcomes for all
of these things what I tried to do is
Bunch the three biggest ones that I like
to use most frequently and if I uh Veer
from like the the bullets on the screen
it's because I'm riffing with you and
I'd rather just kind of stay in the flow
is that cool okay fantastic so when
you're overcoming this one each of these
is kind of a specific angle that you're
attacking it from so macro is like I'm
this is a busy season for me got lots of
stuff going on right micro is like I
don't have any time in my day so you're
one person is saying I've got lots of
[__] going on one person's like I can't
find the time it's different sounds
subtle but it's both about time but in
different ways all right and then the
the last one is well when when I have
time I'll start right everyone know this
[__] horeshit but whatever okay so as
always we never disagree with prospects
because you're not in a fight
totally get it totally understand do you
think like do you want this to be
something that lasts for the long term
right it's a question you're like yeah
do you think that you're going to be
busy again in the future well yeah so
you want this to last in the long run
and you do think you're going to be busy
again in the future well then don't you
think it'd be best to start now when you
are busy because if you learn how to do
it when you're busy you'll be able to do
it forever if you can only learn it
during a perfect circumstance then
you're going to fall off when it gets
busy again and isn't that the time you'd
want to have the most support goes for
you guys too that's just number one we
got so many lore right and so when you
knock that out the goal is that the
person says well [__] that's not a good
reason and you take one step towards the
truth so when you're thinking about it's
not like oh I've got to overcome this
one thing and then they'll buy you got
to keep peeling and if you have this
framework you understand the direction
you're going in and you can start
listening for the oh they're talking
about themselves now I've gotten two
layers deeper right so that's seasonal
micro you can't tell someone in a sale
hey take out your phone take out your
hours by week pull it up oh look 22
hours on social media this week you've
got time so you say it differently you
say you know what I had the same issue
and I used to complain all the time
about like how I didn't have time to to
be successful and do things I needed to
do and my wife got so sick and tired of
me saying this she pulled my phone out
and she was like look I guess I just
found your time didn't I I was like ah
[__] and you can say it that way and
then a prospect feels better does
anybody here feel like they don't have
time right
and the first thing that any program is
going to do if it's a good program is
going to cut out the 90% of the [__]
that you are doing which is causing you
to feel overwhelmed which is probably
the real reason you feel like you don't
have time Jeff basil got the same time
you do right it's just what are the
things that you're doing that he's not
it's not about adding [__] to your plate
it's about removing the stuff that's not
working because clearly everything
you're doing that's filling your time is
not making you more money so you're
doing the wrong [__] so there's going to
be plenty of time because all the stuff
you're doing now is not working right
not simple but that's the reason right
so we went
mael when then hey in the future when
I've got time I'll totally sign up for
your program right anyone heard this one
anyone say this
one right and again you want to you want
to empathize you don't say like Ah
that's [__] you say totally
understand that's I was stuck like this
for years if you can step in their shoes
you're not attacking them you actually
go from the inside out you step into
their self and then you walk them
through the Epiphany that you
experienced and it doesn't feel
judgmental it feels helpful that make
sense I used to feel the same way right
and I found this out actually from Jason
Flatley and he was the one who told me
this it's a it's a logical fallacy it's
called the when then fallacy which is
why that's how I remember it and the
onein fallacy simply States when I have
X then I will do y but it flips sequence
so it's like when I get better I will go
to the
hospital sorry there's just so many like
hilarious ones about like money and
stuff like I start saving money once I'm
rich like all right but the thing is is
that we do this right we do this I'll
pay for the program that'll make me more
money when I have more
money that's the point of the program
I'll pay for the program that'll help me
get a sixpack once I have a
six-pack once I have more time which the
program is going to help me have you
know what I'm saying like it's just it
doesn't make it's a fallacy and so what
that means is it's a distortion it's not
real and so the goal of having these
high stakes conversations is simply
showing people we're not attacking we're
just walking them through it and be like
do you realize that this is holding you
back and I know this better than anyone
because I'm a skeptical [__] the
reason I can do all these logical things
is because I'm the first person I'd
overcome right and you might be
too so once we attack time from these
three angles it depends which one they
present with if they present with one
and then move to the next you can knock
all three out you'll probably find some
that that make the most sense to you but
the thing here is it's not about
memorization you just got to get it
macro you're always going to be busy
once you want the most help when you are
busy so that it can stick forever yes
time my wife showed me my phone turns
out I got [__] time but the reality
is it's not about what I am doing it's
about the stuff I got to stop doing and
that's what I'm going help you with
right this isn't scripting this is just
understanding it right and then when
then it's a fallacy it's a distortion
it's not real and then just use two
crazy examples like once I have money
then or I'll save money when I'm rich
right it's just like ridiculous okay so
what do we do
one reason down and we're getting closer
to the core right right so who here is
somebody who's like I can't afford it
it's too expensive or has heard this
from a prospect I like I better see
everybody's
hand especially if you're selling High
ticket which hopefully you get a gasp so
these are the four Frameworks that I
think through there's a million like
money closes but these are the ones that
I like the most and that that to me
resonate the best right and so why a lot
is good is kind of like my my my first
one here and so the reason that if
someone gasps or think that this is a
lot of money you just ask them is this a
lot of money to you and they're going to
say yeah if they say no then you're like
awesome buy it and if they say yes right
and if they say yes then you're like
that's the exact reason how you're going
to be successful because there's other
people who buy this thing and you know
what they're not all in on it but the
question is do you want to draw the line
in the sand and go all in do you want to
step over the line and be the person you
want to be because I can tell you that
this is not about what whether this
works or not I've already proven that
the question is whether you work or not
and so if you put more on the line then
you have a higher likelihood of being
successful so you should be the last
person to be worried about this I'm more
excited because the best stories are
always coming from people like you in
your exact situation so don't let that
be a reason not to do it that should be
the reason to do it so the next one is
like why is this not a lot so first is
the fact that it's a lot for you is good
it means you're going to try hard the
second one is like well it's a lot in
terms of absolute amount but relative
amount very little right because if all
this does is ADD $10,000 a month to your
income is it worth it if all this does
is get you into a bikini is it worth it
yeah and so then what happens and the
reason that this is a stepping process
right is that we're we're just taking
these objections out of the way so we
can get the person to confront reality
not a distortion they've created because
the reality is the thing they're afraid
of and so what happens is when they say
yeah if it did that it would be worth it
right the problem is they don't believe
you right and so it's like great then
it's not about the price it's about
whether you believe me so you can
sidestep it does that make sense we're
taking a step closer and then obviously
you can use a comparison you know
depending on what you're selling if you
can price anchor with like well here
they don't have a four-year degree for
doing online fitness that's why the
alternative education industry exists
and it's because the formal education
has failed most of us right anybody
graduate with here with a 4-year degree
anyone immediately be able to use that
for degree to get leads make
sales no me
neither right and what's crazy is that
some of these degrees are 501
$200,000 and take four years when you've
got something that can help you make
make that entire amount of money in half
the time right for a tenth of the price
when you think about it like that frame
it's actually a great deal does that
make sense so you just frame it you have
to give context all right so number one
is the fact that it's a lot for you is
good means you're actually going to try
number two is if it does what we say
it's it's going to do the value is there
so that's not actually what you're
opposed to which then we can take the
next step all right number three is
what's money good for anyways this is
actually one of my favorite lines of
reasoning for a variety of reasons and
I'll get to it when you're looking at a
prospect or looking at yourself you're
going to spend this money either way
over the next 12 months you're going to
spend it right and in fact not only
you're going to spend it you're going to
buy the program the question is whether
you're going to pay for it in money or
pay for it in time and so like you can
learn every single lesson that's in this
program whether it's losing weight you
know uh getting leads selling online
whatever it is right you're going to
learn these lessons but do you want it
to take 12 weeks or 12 years and the
question is are you going to be able to
live a thousand lifetimes because of the
thousand people that we've helped just
like you and gathered all those lessons
and put them together so you don't have
to do the trial and error for that
entire period of time so the question is
not whether you're going to buy it or
not it's just how do you want to pay and
so for me this is a personal note and I
I'll probably say it at the end but like
the reason we've been don't move quickly
through life is that I will buy other
people's mistakes because it's just it's
the only way you can buy time in this
life is to buy the knowledge to take
less time from other people who have
taken their time and like if you think
about human civilization in general Edis
took however long to make a light bulb
and then we just bought the lesson from
him and now we have light bulbs right
and the next guy figures out the next
thing and then we just buy the lesson
from him and that's how we have to move
faster so you're going to spend the
money either way question is 12 months
from now is it going to be on [__] that
didn't get you anymore or stuff that is
going to get you somewhere and no matter
what you're buying you're buying the
program just going to pay time or you're
going to pay with
money and if you're being real you've
probably been paying for time the last
six years how's that working for you do
you want to do more of that this is also
this is a this is a classic one it's
very easy one to remember but like who
here knows the difference between a
self-made billionaire when they had
nothing and where you're at right now if
you have nothing zero they both you're
both broke they were broke you're broke
whatever it is if that's where you're at
right now the only difference is that
that proves that if they were successful
it wasn't about the resources they had
is about how resourceful they were so
I'll tell you a quick story about this
so anyone here read uh shoe
dog right story of Nike so in the story
he talks about how he was about to lose
everything multiple times it's a crazy
story and this time it was like it was
it was going to go down like it wasn't
going to happen and he needed a
tremendous amount of money and he just
didn't have it he' extended all his
credit lines the banks wouldn't do it
and the next lenders said they they
canceled on him and the company was
going to fold because it was growing too
fast at that point he could have just
given up and said there's nothing I can
do I maxed out all my cards I maxed out
all my Banks there's literally nothing I
can do and his people had already worked
for free they were like we can't do this
anymore he went to his vendors and said
you need need to pay my payroll for me
he went to his
vendors anybody use like landing page
software anyone or anyone use something
from a vendor right it's like going to
that guy like going to your videographer
and be like listen you got to pay
payroll for me this uh this month
because otherwise I'm not going to be
able to keep doing business with you
because I'll be out of business
resourceful not
resources and the reason this is so
important is because when you have
nothing it's the easiest excuse to give
yourself is you're like well I have
nothing that's why I can't it's like of
course but every self made millionaire
and every self-made millionaire was
self-made and they started with nothing
which puts them in the exact same seat
you are so the question is do you want
to have power or do you want to not have
power you want to have power you're
resourceful not resources right and so
if we want to make these decisions that
are going to help ourselves we need to
step into that and so when you're
talking to your prospects it's the same
thing right does that make sense okay
rocking I mean and you can drill deeper
into this as like do you think there's
anyone else who's been in your situ
situation who's achieved this or maybe
worse than your situation the answer is
yes and if they can why can't you right
so we're taking steps closer is are you
guys digging this okay
cool oh
thanks
thanks I wasn't sure if it was WRA
attention or sheer boredom so we're not
you feel you feel we're progress are
making like the person presents this say
I don't have time shit's busy blah blah
and you're like nope Noe we're going to
take one step Clos they like you know
what but I I don't have the money or
it's too expensive you're like well if
you don't have the money you're going to
be successful it's worth it right yes I
understand why it's worth it well you
don't need money to begin with right you
got to be resourceful and you can find
the money cuz I'll ask you this is a fun
one for business owners who here has had
an unexpected bill ever come
up
taxes right yeah and then all okay so
everyone here is still alive who raised
their hands
who here was able to magically pull
money out of their ass and figure out a
way to do it raise your
hand here's what's crazy you have the
ability to be resourceful when it's for
someone
else and not for
you it's because you choose to be
powerful when someone else needs it but
not for
yourself [__] up right so stop doing
that if you function like you you have
to make payroll tomorrow and like you
you're back on rent you're going to get
kicked out you think differently and if
instead of paying your landlord you're
paying you because that's what you want
to do it shifts internally because
everyone here just Prov the fact that
you can be resourceful when you choose
to
be so just choose to be so number three
is it's not not sure it's a fit for me
so be besides the obvious ones which is
like I don't want to work out broccoli
sucks I I can't do a program where
where I I can't do cardio whatever the
[__] right um like I said I don't want
to do DMs I don't want to post on
Instagram I don't want to have a
Facebook group whatever right whatever
the [__] is all right I'm not sure
if the vehicle is a fit for me so
usually you can overcome the easy ones
but if someone is just really sticking
hard these are the three that I use to
to shift perspective okay so this one is
new identity new priorities so it's good
to have cues for these things which is
like we vote with our dollars about the
things that we care about and if you
show me what someone is spending their
money and their time on I can tell you
what their future is and I'll tell you
an interesting story so um I had
somebody who was just like you who was
like you know what I don't want to do
this either and I told her this story
can I tell you it yes and this is what
you'd say to the prospect right so I was
with Lea and we went to Sephora which is
a makeup store
and and I show up like this um I feel
welcomed and so we're we're standing
there she's doing something and I
usually stand in the corner like this
um and I saw these two little girls it
might have been like I don't know girl
age so like 12 to 15 this like this this
and they were like giggly and so excited
and they had like the girl with the smok
came over was like helping her out
helping them out and she was like okay
this is like eyeliner and this is
lipstick and this is whatever blush um
I'm just like using words I've heard
uh this is how you paint your face and
the thing is the girls were like so
excited and then they were like right
before they left she was like girls
she's like you have to remember like now
that you're getting older and you're
becoming a woman you need to start
budging for this stuff all right so
you're going to start buying this every
month all right so like remember you got
to save some money for this so you can
have it and the girls were so excited
that they were like yes like we're
becoming women now and these are the
things that women do it's because when
you have new identity you have new
priorities and so you've had priorities
that are aligned with your old identity
right there's the you that goes out the
you that drinks the you that does the BL
blah blah blah blah spends money on [__]
you shouldn't do spends time on [__] you
shouldn't be spending time on and
there's the you that you want to be and
so right now we can draw the line in the
sand and be like do you want to keep
walking down the road that you have been
walking and if you don't then you have
to step into a new identity and with
that new identity comes new priorities
because people who want to be rich spend
money on themselves they spend money on
education they invest in their skill
sets because I want to align my identity
with the identity of those who came
before me who've done the things I want
to do right and just like those little
girls stepping into that identity we too
must step into the identity we want to
be does that make sense and so when
you're talking to somebody who's trying
to lose weight and they're like I can't
afford a gym membership and you're like
girl you're spending 200 bucks on your
nails and you've got a $1,000 outfit on
do you think another $1,000 outfit would
make you look better or your high school
weight
right do you think another ,000 outfit
would make you look better
or being rich as [__] and I say that for
those of you who are thinking about on
the money side right like who waste like
some of you guys have bigger shoe
collections than like it's like Fitness
like Fitness people and shoes it's like
the weird like and Lululemon and the you
know spandex it's like a hundreds piece
of SP anyways so it's like your whole
wardrobe could be Consolidated into a
skill that could buy you as many
wardrobes as you want if you chose to
right okay rocket I don't like this
certain aspect this is one of my
favorite easiest ones to hit which is
like you got to change the change right
what you have been doing it's been
getting what you've been getting and you
got to change the change cuz like I
remember I would go through meal plans
with people and they'd be like well can
we change this because this is what I
eat for breakfast can we tell can we
make that the breakfast and I'm like
that breakfast makes you look like
you that way you spend your first four
hours of the day makes your bank account
looks like what it does look
like
ooh right right taking steps right we're
getting closer to the truth and so the
thing is is that it's going to hurt to
change because change hurts and you've
heard this one probably from Tony
Robinson if you haven't the question is
whether the pain of staying the same is
greater than the pain of change and
that's we just ask someone and this is
in the help part if someone's like the
pain of staying the same is not worse
than this Chang it's like then
girlfriend like gain 50 more pounds and
come back you know what I mean like get
there you I mean hit rock bottom this
isn't it for you I'm being
real some people Rock Bottom is 12% body
fat some people it's 500 lb but
everyone's got one you just got to know
where yours is and all you really got to
do is just move what rock bottom is for
you which is kind of interesting because
you start making a change here which is
kind of Interest like interesting as a
thought but are you in enough pain is
the question you ask the person so for
those of you who are unwilling to make a
change because it feels contrary to like
I don't want to do I don't want to seem
salesy I don't want to I don't want to
help people like whatever right like is
your current situation more painful then
the change that you'll have to go
through or experience to get to where
you want to go and so the last one is
hypothetical I actually really love this
this is a great framework overall for
overcoming lots of different obstacles
um or objections that present themselves
but the hypothetical and there's lots of
ways of phrasing this which is like
you've probably heard the Unicorn
clothes you probably heard like if this
were perfect would you do it on want a
scare from 1 to 10 where would this
program be if 10 was amazing one was
terrible you know where is this they say
a number and you say cool what would
make it a 10 why isn't a one like you
guys heard this scripting before so you
guys are like no please talk slower um
the reason I said we have to learn the
principles behind it rather than
memorizing the script is that it all is
based on one thing which is hypothetical
which is if this were perfect would you
do it because you get a hypothetical
agreement and they say yes if it were
per the thing is that if you're like if
this were perfect would you do it if
someone says no then you're like girl
okay like let's take five steps back
this my breath
smell because the thing is they've
actually told you a lot there it's like
it has nothing to do with the stuff
you're talking about they don't trust
you and now we can talk about that right
so it's a great question to frame like
where are we and so it's like if this
were perfect would you do it sometimes
they'll laugh if you ever poor they'll
laugh they'll say yes right and so then
you get to flip it and say then what's
difference between Perfection and what
we've got and the thing is is that
people are very hard they don't actually
know how to generate making a program
cuz they're not going to like know all
the things you can deliver on the spot
right and and so they're like most of
the time they'll be like I don't know
you're like right well because it sounds
like it's nothing to do with the program
it's all about to do with you so let's
talk about that right and then all of a
sudden boom one step closer to the truth
does that make sense yeah all right and
that's why we do hypotheticals so if it
were perfect what's missing and then if
you can if it's if they do give you an
answer and they're like I just don't
want to do broccoli and you're like I do
green beans would you do it they're like
yeah you're like great green beans it is
sign here right
like some you would be [__] amazed
how many times [__] like that happens
it's like one crazy thing it's like well
if we didn't have that would you do it
like oh yeah
sure where were you 10 minutes ago right
and that's how you do hypothetical okay
we're making we're making progress you
still with me still digging okay
cool Authority all right this is one of
my favorite F and so this one instead of
having three I really just have like one
very good statement of reasoning that
you should understand okay this is real
[__] so this is more of a process than
it is anything else but the spouse or
decision maker is not there right now
note for you guys a lot of you guys have
had the opportunity to go talk to a
spouse but a lot of you guys don't have
that in your business right like spouse
ain't there and they leave they're not
coming back right or they are but very
small percentage don't wait for it okay
so what we have to do is try and
sidestep it by isolating the objection
and casting aside the partner because
the partner is not there so how could
they object anything they don't even
[__] know who you are right and so
the idea is and again this is assuming
if you have a really long-term thing
then you want the partner to be there
right like ideally that's what you have
but if you don't have the opportunity
then you got to go through the next step
all right which is what do you think
they wouldn't like and then they will
tell you and then you just overcome the
thing which has nothing to do with the
spouse because spouse isn't there right
very easy s side step does that make
sense this works really well
it's like why wouldn't they It's like
because they don't want me to fail o
they don't want you to
fail let's talk about you and so this is
the process that I walk
through do they approve of your current
struggle they happy that you're
struggling no okay then why would they
not approve of something that's going to
fix something they already don't approve
of right they're not happy with how
you're currently doing why would they be
against something that's already making
them
unhappy
right right
well let me ask you this and they pause
like if the rules were reversed and your
husband needed this to make what he
wants his dreams happen or your wife
needed this program to make her dreams
happen would you support
her then why wouldn't you support you
right right and I think the real problem
that we're dealing with here and this is
the kicker this for
everybody is that you're asking for
permission instead of support
because it is your life not theirs and
what happens is if you give that power
to them and then two years from now
you're still fat you're still poor
whatever it is who are you going to
blame them and so that's when you have a
resentful marriage because you didn't
own your [__] and so I'm not saying you
shouldn't like explain the decision to
them but the way you explain it to them
is what I just said which is if I don't
do this for me I'm going to end up
resenting you and I don't want that and
instead of me bitching to you every day
about how we don't have money or about
how I don't like my body I'm now doing
this and I'm joining a group of support
of community of people just like me and
crazy enough for some reason doctors go
to college right right that makes sense
they go to medical school lawyers go to
law school but where do entrepreneurs go
there's no entrepreneur school no one
teaches the stuff but it turns out there
are people who teach it just for this
specific industry and I can take
failures of a thousand people in pack
into a
year and it's one10 the price of a
4-year
degree right and so instead of whining
to you what I commit to is I'm going to
show up and be a better husband a better
wife a better partner I'm not going to
[__] to you about this the stuff
because I'm going to take this seriously
I'm going to go all and I'm not asking
your permission I'm just asking for your
support all right that's how you can
overcome it because I'm going be real
with you it is about them and you have
to believe that like you can't say this
unless you believe it because like you
will you save marriages by showing
people that they are the ones in control
because if they keep saying my husband's
not going to let me buy a weight loss
program what do you think she's secretly
saying can't believe you won't let me do
it right if that's real if she's using
it as a foil you sidestep you get
yourself right but that might be the
real thing and if that is the thing then
you have to let them step into that and
that's where you know having that's
where like having a three-day no sweat
guarantee or something like that is also
helpful it's like hey sign up and I use
I use a lot of aapor and humor in my
selling and so I'd be like hey Cindy if
you sign up and you tell your husband
and he's upset you have and and when he
sees you he's like girl I don't want you
to get in shape I want you to stay
overweight I want you to put those
sweatpants on I want you sit on that
couch reach your hand a bag of Cheetos
put the the Cheetos fingers on there I
want you to create generational unhealth
I want you to live 10 years less long I
want you to see our grandkids I don't
want that right I want to marry a
younger better you sooner because you're
going to have a heart attack if he says
that to you you have him call me and
then they're like cracking up and you're
like okay okay listen sign up three-day
no sweat like if he if he does tell you
that he just wants you to be out of
shape and never leave him because uh
because he doesn't want you to get you
hot cuz he's insecure if he says that um
yeah just let me know all right so like
the whole time you're just joking and
stuff but the 3day guarantee helps like
nudge a lot of these people over is that
cool you guys get that one
okay sweet
and so that goes for you right like it's
it's about support not permission that's
the bottom line right support not
permission because otherwise you're
going to blame them for your lack of
Dreams being realized rather than
blaming the person that should which is
you all right so this is avoidance now
we're getting to the core we've gotten
rid of time we know that you've got time
and the best time to do it is today
because you're going to be busy forever
right value we know that you can't
afford it if you can't afford it you'll
buy it if you can't afford it's a great
great reason to do it and if the value
is there then there's no reason not to
do it because it'll pay for itself right
what's money good for anyways you're
going to pay for the program regardless
you want to pay him less time or more
time value is not a problem fit you got
to step into new identity right you've
got to be willing to change and the
question is just whether the pain that
you're
experiencing is less than the pain of
the change that it takes to experience
the next thing right if they step into
that they're good because it's not about
resources it's about resourcefulness so
the fit's not an issue Authority they
have to own it it's about support not
permission we all here do you feel like
we've peeled the layers back on your
prospects and they're just laid bare
naked there just you've solicited the
sale now you got to close all right
avoidance so now they're like wait wait
I need to think about
it so now that we've exhausted I'm
putting this as emphasis we've exhausted
all outside reasons now we are finally
talking to someone in power and that is
what a good coach does we don't make
decisions for people we help them make
decisions so here's I have to think
about it not sure give me a hand who's
dealt with somebody who say thinks that
way all right at least one person here
no I'm kidding all you guys that you
guys are great so this is how I divide
this up past present future and so
hopefully this should already before I I
dive into these give you simple
Frameworks to work through time you've
got macro micro when then right you've
got you got value you're thinking about
it's not a lot of money even if if it
were a lot of money it's not a lot of
money you're going to pay for it either
way like you have the simple Frameworks
that you can walk through you might just
hit them with one and if they hit it
with again you hit them with the other
angle because they're logical Frameworks
they're not scripts that's why I made
them bubbles you don't have to memorize
it just got to understand it
past so like I need to think about it
and so the thing is is and this the
first bubble there is if someone's like
I feel like this is happening so fast
any we get that one like I just I just
got on the phone with you I don't really
know who you are and you're like hey
this is not a fast decision right you've
been making this decision for the last 6
years you continually make the decision
we're doing to say is deciding you're
actually going to do something about it
right how long you wanted to lose weight
a long time so this is not a fast
decision at all but the thing is is that
and this is where you go sunk cost so if
I were talking to you guys I would say
you you know you bought tickets cuz you
saw some ad you registered there you got
your flights you got a hotel you blocked
the time you flew here you listen to
this whole thing you're 6 in from gold
this isn't a fast decision at all you
did all these to get here because it's
important to you so don't let that
Distortion stop you from getting what
you want right it's fear right let's
face that what are you afraid of having
happen which by the way I took the slide
out but my two favorite questions to ask
in a in a sale that I feel like are the
fastest to cut through is what are you
most afraid of having happen if you buy
what are you most afraid of what's the
worst thing that you envision in your
mind and if they're not sure I just fill
in the blanks I'm like I take your
credit card I swipe over as as much as I
possibly can I go to Vegas I put it all
on black and then I go to Monaco where
they can't extradite me fair enough and
they're like I was not thinking that and
you're like
right so what's the worst you know like
what's what's the real thing they're
like and then they're like you know I
just hav bought so many programs before
you're like right let's talk about that
right and so I'm going to skip one
forward and then I'm going to go back to
it this is one of my favorite obstacle
or objection overcomes it's I call it
don't let it burn you twice and this you
can see the date it happened yesterday
this girl texted me or me April 6th she
said it's crazy to think that I had a
sales call with you 6 years ago and I'm
kicking myself in the butt for not
jumping on this is yesterday right like
I don't even own the company anymore and
I said you let a bad decision burn you
twice once when you made your poor
investment but a second time when you
let that bad investment stop you from a
good investment it would be like anybody
ever have a boyfriend or girlfriend in
middle school or high school that
they're not currently married
to anyone just like just come on help me
out here okay
it would be like having a bad eighth
grade boyfriend or girlfriend and being
like you know what men aren't for
me all coaches suck right there's good
coaches there's bad coaches there's
crazy ass [__] and there's crazy ass
dudes you know what I mean like there's
also good ones and so the things is if
you stop if you let the bad one prevent
you from the good one you get burned by
being with the bad one and because you
let the bad one control your next
decision right and so when someone has
had a bad experience with do doing keto
or whatever the [__] right or you had a
bad experience with some program that
you did or did not do or they didn't
fulfill whatever either way don't let
that burn you twice because no matter
what you're going to have to do you're
going to have to do these actions
whether you're part of the program or
not you're got to do these workouts
where you're part of the program or not
doesn't matter you're going to have to
do it so you might as well do it but
somebody's going get you there faster
right let me go back one real quick so
it's not a fast decision and this is
another one that I love which is do you
think that you're maybe in this position
because you have struggled to make a
decision in the past you have waffled
when it came time to make to make the
hard call have you been in this
conversation and said no before yeah do
you think that's why you're here yeah do
you think that might be the reason you
should change
that yeah okay let's change it one
decision change your life and the last
one is like are you tired of another
year of almost right tired another year
of almost hitting your goals of almost
getting to 10K a month of of almost you
know Hing the team that you wanted of
almost retiring your your wife or
husband or almost moving into the
neighborhood that you wanted to move
into or almost being able to pay for
your kids Recreational Sports rather
than not being able to because you can't
afford it you're tired of another year
of almost well if you're tired of
another year almost then we can't do
what we're doing to get here for another
year because we're going to get another
year almost and so the question isn't
what it cost you but how much has it
cost you to not decide up to this point
right the cost of
inaction and I think that when we think
about our lives in Reverse we never
never regret the things that we did we
regret the things we didn't do the
opportunities that we let pass by and I
think that if you can let that person
step into that power they will make the
decision to help themselves like this
person did not all right present so
depends on who you're talking to
someone's talking about past stuff then
you do with the past stuff the second
frame for avoidance is present which is
they just don't know how to make a
[__] decision right and so you have
to help them make a decision and so this
one the rocking chair is one that I just
for some reason have used a tremendous
amount of time especially when I was
selling weight loss
is to be like I just really really need
to think about it like totally
understand well let's walk through like
what that looks like you're not going to
like go home sit in the rocking chair
you know smoke a cigarette because of
course you're not healthy yet right
you'll quit when you're healthy right
you're smoking your cigarette and you're
like H am I going to do this weight loss
program right you're just sit there and
stare into the clouds like I wonder no
of course now you're get in your car and
you're going to realize you got to pick
up Timmy from soccer practice you got to
get groceries you got to cook you got to
clean you got to pick you know go do the
laundry got to do all these things right
and then 3 four 5 days from now you're
going to put on that pair of jeans and
it's not going to fit you be like
[__] and just there you'll have made the
decision you'll keep living your
life and so let's just make it now
because the reality is that it doesn't
take information to make decisions sorry
it doesn't take time to make decisions
takes information and I'm the only
source of information you got so let's
talk I'm here I'm here for you let's do
it right because that's the fallacy is
that people think they need more time to
make decisions because they assume they
will get more information in that time
but if you are the source of the
information then time does not help them
and so let's confront it now and let me
answer the questions you have to make
the decision one way or another does
that make sense yeah all right and so
then they're like well then [__] how do
I make a decision you're like glad you
asked so there's three things that we
got to understand do you believe that
this product or service is going to help
you achieve what you want yes or no
they're going to say yes right and if
they don't you can confront it note all
of these are confronting decisions so
we've moved all the way down the onion
right we're at truth now and all like
the theme of the of the last bullet is
confrontation we have to confront the
decision we got to peel it back and be
like are we going to do this or not
right because we already got out the
time we got out the fit we got out the
SP we got everything out of the way it's
just you do you think that this is going
to help you get closer to your goals yes
or no two do you trust me to fill to
fulfill my word that I said I'm going to
help you I'm going to do these calls I'm
going to do these workouts I'm going to
do whatever right three this is the mo
probably the most important one do you
think it'll work for you and if they say
no you say why not and then they have to
defend why not and then it's very easy
at that point it's a 6inch putt right
and once they say yes to all three which
is usually what'll happen be like cool
we'll make the decision together do you
know how to make the decision they'll
say no you go through the three and the
last question is they said yes yes yes
it's just do you have or have access to
the amount of money to get started do
you have the MX do you want me to help
you enroll in an MX cuz I want to I want
to help you I'm good either way but if
you believe that this is going to help
you get closer you believe that what I'm
saying is true and you believe that you
can be successful it's my moral
obligation to get you going and do
everything in my power to help you get
the money or get access to it because
the real R is if I was giving you a
Ferrari right now for $5,000 you'd find
the money if your landlord needed you to
come up with $10,000 because you had
background and payroll you'd find the
money so find the money let's do it
right
three who wants to make informed
decisions yes
how can you make an informed decision if
you haven't even tried it huh so this is
when you have some element of trial in
the program or some sort of guarantee
which is why I'm a big fan of guarantees
it's like well you can't make the
decision to buy that's informed until
you're on the inside so I'm not even
asking you to make a decision right now
I'm just asking you make an informed
decision which you can only do on the
inside and if after 30 days I'm not what
I said this product doesn't do what I
told you I didn't fulfill my promise and
you don't think it's going to work for
you you let me I'll give you the money
back low pressure you get someone to
decide by not
deciding even easier does that make
sense think that'll help you close yeah
all right and then uh this one is uh it
depends on who you're selling to but
sometimes if you a logical person it's
like do you know what deciding even
means like where the atmology of the
work comes from it's dcad which is Latin
which means to cut off to kill off and
so the question is which future are we
killing off today
are we killing off the future of the
dreams that you want are we killing off
the future sorry are we killing off the
future of of not doing anything and the
life that you've lived up to this point
because indecision is a decision
inaction is an active decision right and
so it's just which one are we killing
today we killing your dreams or we
killing your past second and last one
future so we talked about past so if
they're thinking about the past the
things that hurt them don't let it burn
you twice Etc right they don't know how
to make a decision rocking chair this is
how you make a decision three things you
have access to money great let's get
going you want to kill your past you
want to kill your future right awesome
we're talking about the future this is
actually magnifying pain which
is cool you got here it's been 5 years
you've been struggling how's another
five years sound what if we just keep
doing let's go with indecision let's
look at it what does five years of you
doing what you've been doing look like
and is that a place you want to be no
you got to change the change let's do it
right
and then you go right into let's
consider the options which is
like like this is logic right so let's
consider the
options option one you do the thing get
the result life is awesome option two
you don't do the thing you don't get the
result because you didn't do the thing
option three you do the thing but then
you don't get the result all these are
the options that can happen in front of
you because we have a guarantee they're
all risk-free except for one of them
only one of them has a true guarantee of
not getting you where you want which is
walking out the door so which risk-free
option do you want the one that's
risk-free that guarantees that you're
not going to get there or the one that's
risk-free and has the potential to get
you where you want to
go right that's not an emotional close
it's logic and if you have an offer
that's set up that way you should be
able to close most people as long as
they don't think you're an [__] right
okay this is one that's more around
urgency because again this is avoidance
if someone says I I'm still not sure I
want to think about it more whatever you
say well you're not going to struggle
forever right like you don't want to
struggle forever you're going to do
something about this whether it's weight
loss business whatever they're going to
say yes you're like well if you're going
to fix your business eventually you
might as well start fixing it now so you
can start enjoying the fruits of that
labor sooner would you prefer making
more money faster or slower what's your
preference great so if you're going to
do it eventually you might as well do it
now does that make sense it's a little
nudge this is a final one that I just
really like from a framing perspective
which is instead of a like this has to
be my savior this program has to get me
to an ifbb Pro bikini body and I'm 100
pounds overweight probably not realistic
right reframe the question is do you
think that making the decision is going
to be help you get closer or further
from your goal that's it because if we
keep making decisions that keep getting
us closer we will get there eventually
but if we make decisions that get us
further away we will not get there and
so do you think that this is going to
get you closer to your goal than what
you're currently doing yes what are we
waiting for we don't need to be snipers
we need to be directionally right we do
that long enough we'll get there does
that make sense that helps you too
because we have this fear of
perfectionism is this going to be the
one probably not but it will get you
[__] way closer right because I can
tell you there's no one program that
changed my life but the the decision to
buy education changed my life forever
does that make sense yeah all right boom
and so let me let me look at the top we
have no reasons left not to own the
power that you have it's just you all
right and here's bonus number six and
you can use this as one of like there's
some closes that you use all the time
you always go back to right the reason
you are telling yourself not to do this
is the reason you to do
it how long do you want I can't afford
this to be on your list of problems in
life the fact that you don't have time
is the very reason you need to do this
the fact that you're so dependent on
your spouse is the reason you need to
take this decision and own it right the
fact that you're not sure about the
person that you want to be is the very
reason that we're going to help you get
it in this program so whatever the
reason is is usually the biggest chain
that you're holding on to is the thing
that you're enslaving yourself to is the
thing that you're casting your power to
if you break that chain power comes back
to you and so the very reason that
you're holding yourself back is
typically the very reason that you need
to do it so hopefully this helps you
realize that you and your clients are
always in complete power did I
accomplish that
awesome thank
you and like I promised at the beginning
My Hope Is that you become more powerful
by making decisions rather than letting
life make them for you all right so
here's a few final
thoughts fortunes are created by taking
a lot of risk with a little bit of money
fortunes are maintained by taking a
little bit of risk with a lot of money
and every one of those people that was
self-made takes a lot of risk with a
little bit of money and sometimes you
need to take that step because it's the
only way to build the fortune all right
and if everything that I've ever made in
my life all right sorry everything that
I've made in my life is a result of
investing in my own education it has
gotten me far higher returns than any
stock any real estate any crypto right
any whatever buy a mile and people say
like it's all about investing yourself
like I just I think it sounds a morphus
it's like Buy experience and
skills because no government can take
that from you no divorce can take that
from you nothing can take that from you
and I come from a family where so we're
Persian and so my my parents had to flee
Iran During the Revolution and so they
had land and houses and other stuff
right and my uncle was uh the brother to
a guy who started the lottery in Iran he
owned the lottery because you can do
that there right very rich rich and so
my dad and him he went to London my dad
went to the
US he had no
skills and he was able to just forge
enough money to buy a print shop and he
lives above the print shop in London and
still to this day that's what he does
and went to visit him it was incredibly
sad seeing just like well once once
incred and his wife my dad gave her a
scarf and it was like a nice scarf
apparently and she just baled she's like
I used to have rooms of these and now I
have nothing and blah blah blah blah
right my dad came to the United States
with
$1,000 but because he had skills he
built it all from scratch and so I mean
he was a doctor as all Middle Eastern
and Indians are
um right doctor lawyer accountant
engineer anyways um the only four
approved
paths but when we say invest in that we
come from a place where like it was
literally all taken the government was
like that's our house now that's our
land now that bank account is our bank
account now
and so that was why it was so and like
that might be a benefit for me I had
somebody who was always like it's the
only thing no one can take from you and
so why would you not invest in the one
thing that can never be stolen can never
be taken and compounds with time and it
increases your capacity to make money
increases your capacity to
live and so I like to think of the
Investments that I've made in myself as
bricks on a bridge and so if I'm on the
bottom left here and where I want to be
is the top right is right looking like
The Nightmare Before Christmas now
um you're going like there are many
skills that it takes to cross the bridge
right and just like you have an
arithmetic teacher in high school once
you learn calculus you're not like that
guy was a load of [__] calculus is what
no you have to learn things in sequence
right and so the thing is is that when
we build this bridge it's one brick at a
time and I always come back to the same
question which is is this going to get
me closer to where I want to go I don't
need it to get me there I just need to
get closer and if I get better I'll get
there eventually right as long as I
don't stop moving and so that's why
that's that what I've dedicated my life
to education my mission is to document
and share the best practice building
world class
companies because when you realize that
you are the source you realize that
Superman is not coming it's just you and
every decision that you make is a vote
towards or against the person that we
want to be and so the question for you
is that are your decisions voting
towards the person that you want to
become or just more of what you already
have
and so people ask me all the time how do
you move so quickly and the answer is I
know how to buy time and the follow
question is how do you buy time you buy
Time by buying the time took other
people to make mistakes that taught them
the lessons that's how you do it right
that's that's the heck and so right now
the ignorance of not knowing how to
create a million dollars a year is
costing you a million dollars a year the
fact that you don't know how to make a
million dollar a year is costing you a
million dollars a year think about it
right and so therefore you should always
be willing to invest money to increase
the capacity for your income because
once you have it that capacity pays you
forever you're increasing your ability
does that make sense we're widening the
pipe and so when I thought about this I
just added zeros to it and I was like
it's [__] costing me a billion
dollars a year not knowing how to make a
billion dollars God right but it's true
because the thing the number one tax
that no one appreciates or no one
respects is not the tax of the
government it's not capital gains not
income tax it's the time tax of
ignorance someone asked Lela yesterday
what's the number one thing that people
from 0 to 10K are messing up you don't
know what the [__] you're doing that's
what's messing you up you're ignorant
you have no idea you're eating an orange
like an apple no clue
right and it's not because you don't
have the processing power it's not
because you don't have the ability to
reason it's because you just don't know
and so the goal is to pay down the time
tax of ignorance fast as humanly
possible and the only way you do that is
by educating and investing yourself
right specifically investing in
experiences that build skills so make
the decisions that to help yourself
Implement like crazy take ownership
because we just discover that all the
other [__] is not real is literally a
distortion of reality that anything that
you give your power to that's not you is
fake you're making it a false god in
your life and your prospects are too and
you now you know how to confront those
when your mind tries to play tricks on
you and realize that there are no silver
bullets no program is going to save your
life all right but some things can move
you close to your goals and when those
rare opportunities present themselves
take them all right because either you
win or you learn and both of those get
you closer to wherever you want to go
all right and so a wrap up with this 10
years ago I had to that was me a Swanky
uh you know when I was a consultant
looking cool was actually after I don't
even have a good picture when I was a
consultant but there's me in a suit
um and I I knew I hated the job that I
had um I made okay money but I just like
I just really wasn't happy um and I
emailed 40 gym owners and I was like hey
I think I want to get in Fitness can
somebody like help me out one guy was
like sure you can work for free I was
like awesome uh that guy was standing
back to y and anybody know who Sam backr
is raise hand jeez okay well seven
figure Sam is what he used to be known
as he actually died during Co um which
is really sad for me because I really
looked up to Sam and the thing is is
that when I got to his office I
literally drove across the country from
Baltimore to LA or Chino Hills which is
where he was and I showed up without
notice and he was like you're a
psychopath I just met you from the
internet and I was like I'm here I'm
ready to learn he was like I'm going to
lunch and um
but right after he came back from lunch
uh he was like all right so you should
join my my Mastermind and I was like I
don't have a gym he's like that's okay
it was a gym Mastermind
um and I didn't I mean like I was 22
like I did not have a lot of money um
and he was like well it's 10 grand and I
was like I I don't know and he's like
you need a [__] commit man he's like
you've been waffling back and forth I
had had multiple phone calls with him
before left um he's like I think you
need to draw a line in the sand and
thank you God you know thank God he did
cuz I did take a step over I had no idea
what the [__] I was doing but I was
trying to start paying down the time tax
of ignorance and I got around a whole
bunch of other Fitness professionals and
I learned way more from all of them than
I ever learned from Sam but because of
that my belief started to change the
ways I saw the world Chang the traits I
started to embody change and started
taking steps The Mastermind I got from
Sam is not what made me $100 million but
it got me on the right path towards
making it over the years of having
hundreds of salespeople work for me I've
seen these nine things that the best
sales people do differently than
everyone else and so if you boil it down
a salesperson has three jobs to do they
have to maximize the number of
opportunities they have they have to
convert the highest percentage of those
opportunities and and this is the
important part they have to do it
consistently for a very long period of
time and so the nine things they do
differently will fall elegantly into
each of these three buckets let's start
with the first one which is maximizing
lead needs or maximize the number of
opportunities that a salesman
has so right off the top I've never seen
a salesperson who does the most in a
company have the lowest amount of hours
worked I've yet to have it you know what
maybe there's a special snowflake out
there but every company that I've owned
and every company that I've looked at
the guy who works the most hours is the
one who sells the most deals and so
maximizing opportunities comes in a
number of different forms so number one
is that they have the total most hours
available per day because you should be
available when the prospect is available
and that means sometimes working long
hours it sometimes mean working weekends
and yes businesses also pay rent on
Sundays and so you can make sales on
Sundays so my software company Allen
scheduled 4,000 plus appointments per
day across a number of different
Industries and so we got to see all the
way from click to close which companies
were selling the most people and we
looked at all the different data so
times of day number of days per week you
know speed between text responses number
of characters and text response all
these different variables cuz I had two
data analysts that looked at this to
figure out how could he maximize
throughput for any business and
obviously sales a big component of that
and the single greatest lever on
throughput across all companies was the
number of total available time slots
which means availability was the
strongest predictor of total sales and
let me give you a tactical example of
this when Leila and I were traveling the
other day we went to a different city
and she wanted to get her nails done or
something and so she she just pulled up
Yelp and looked at the one that had the
top reviews called them up and they said
oh I'm sorry we don't do same day
appointments and they're like we can
book you in for 2 days from now and she
was like yep don't care called the next
one same thing called the third one and
then they were like yeah we can take you
right now and boom she went in and the
thing is is that both those other
business owners the first two business
owners that said no lost money and the
next time she comes to that place she'll
probably go back to the one that she
went to as long as they did a good job
and so trying to be egotistical about it
rather than accommodate customers it's
like well we're so
great you just lose money now if we
maximize the total number of time that's
available for the salesperson to sell
then the next part of maximizing their
opportunities is getting as much of
their day as humanly possible filled
with the best opportunities and so the
second subunit of this
is they will pull up calls and so the
first thing is if you see a call that
gets booked or you book a call that's on
Thursday and today's Monday if you have
a time slot that's open you grab your
Thursday appointment you drag it into
today because today appointments always
have higher show up rates and if you
pull it up then they're even more
interested and you can close even higher
and you can have two or three calls by
that same Thursday time so you increase
your sales velocity now a correlator to
that is if you look at your calendar and
you've reached out to a prospect and
that person has not responded back and
now it's the same day and they're coming
up in a few hours well what do you do
well the best salespeople pull that time
slot and say hey sorry I didn't see that
you confirmed why don't we do the same
thing for tomorrow you can push it out
one and then try and fill that time slot
with somebody who is responsive even if
they're later in the week and that
increases your total number of calls per
day and so fundamentally the perfect day
for a salesperson is that they have call
back to back to back to back to back
with the best possible leads that are
the hottest that day I learned that
little tactic about pulling up because
we had one of our companies uh was in
solar sales and they had one rep that
massively outperformed everyone else and
I was like what is this guy doing and so
what he was doing was he would whenever
a new appointment would book he would
immediately call the appointment to
qualify the lead cuz that checks two
boxes one is he says okay is this person
qualified to buy if the person was he
had two decision paths if they had the
time right then he would just go
straight into closing because he was in
offthe callop and then by getting in
contact with the lead became on the call
in terms of his sop and if they said
they had time right now he just went for
the sale that maximizes his time on call
if they said no then the reason for his
call was that he had an opening later
that day that he was trying to fill up
and so he either takes the moment now
that he's working the lead and turns it
into into a sales call or he fills
another slot later in the day and turns
that into a sales call both of those
things maximize the number of sales that
guy was having and this guy was selling
like four times more units than the
second best guy on the team and then
they obviously saw this and then adopted
it companywide and then of course I saw
it and adopted it across all my entire
portfolio and let me double down to why
that's so powerful because not only does
the salesman have two opportunities to
sell now or later that day he also opens
up the slot later in the week for
availability for another customer that
can't make it today to to book that time
then because what I have found and we
saw this with the software was if you
have fewer time slots people may still
book with you but they are not booking
at the most convenient time for them
you'll see schedule rates but then show
rates will drop because it's not the
time that works for them ideally and so
you want to make it the most
accommodating so it's not just are is it
convenient or inconvenient it's how
convenient is it if I have a a tight
deadline and a hard stop and I've got
something that I'm stressed about
afterwards I might be able to schedule a
call then but I might not be in a in the
mood to buy high but if I say you know
what Sunday afternoon I'm free I'll have
all the time in my world I'm going to
have zero urgency to get off the call
I'll listen to you and I'll be in a
completely different Zone and that might
be when I'm in receiving hands in terms
of prospect brain mode for
buying and so one of the things that the
best sales people have and this is
something that companies should provide
but often don't is that you have two
Sops meaning standard operating
procedures you have an on thee call sop
which is what you say when you're
talking to prospects and you have an
offthe call sop which is what do in
between the vast majority of companies
don't have an off-the call sop and
they're losing tons and tons of money
because they just say yeah just work the
leads in the meantime when the total
amount of output that a salesman has is
so correlated with the amount of
opportunities they have and they get
those opportunities by the time they
have when they're not on the call and so
they should have two separate checklists
if they don't have them in front of them
and this is what the best sales people
do is this is what I'm doing when I'm on
and this is what I'm doing when I'm off
and you can just switch hats as soon as
you're off you start at the top and
you're like I'm following with this
person I'm following with this person
I'm dragging this person forward I'm
canceling this appointment and they have
high
Activity one of the things that we do
across all our companies and I learned
This Acronym from my friend shiron
bamfam which is book a meeting from a
meeting which is that the best
salespeople never finish a call with a
prospect not knowing when the next time
they're going to talk to the prospect so
that Prospect should never fall into no
l they should never fall between the
cracks where they're like I don't know
and so if you get to the end of the call
and they're like yeah let's uh connect
offline we'll you know we'll Circle back
up and we'll find another time no you
have to address it at that time because
if for whatever reason like a Time
obstacle is still an obstacle and you
can resolve it right then you both have
your calendars up you can both make the
decision if someone's like well I'm not
sure then you actually address the
concern like isn't this a problem for
you how much you losing every day not
implementing this solution in your
business how much like how much of a
problem is this in your life and why
isn't it this something that we'd be
doing sooner right and so you want to
address those things because that is
these are obstacles and so if you just
get off the call Jolly then you actually
lose more sales so you always book a
meeting from the meeting here's three
more things that the best salese will do
number one is that they don't take
rejection personally because they're
going to reach out in more volume than
the mediocre salespeople and so you can
see on a CRM how many Outreach attempts
and how many follow-up attempts that A
salesperson is having between calls and
it correlates with the number of calls
that they take and so they work their
leads harder and that's because if
someone before they've scheduled a call
you know say has something mean they're
not like oh my gosh I can't believe this
or if someone no shows they're not like
well I'm not going to work the rest of
my leads no one really cares about me
like wo is me it's no they know it's a
numbers game and they just keep plowing
something that I've noticed the best
salespeople do is they have something
called a kill list and so those are
those prospects that you're like this is
a whale or this is a really good
Prospect and they they sure they have in
the CRM sure they have them in the place
that they're supposed to have them but
they also have it somewhere else that's
visible so they can always think about
it and like that's like an everyday list
it's like I got to get back to these two
guys I got to make sure that these ones
I'm going to put extra attention to
because they're high value deals now the
last element of what the best salese do
for increasing their number of leads is
that they create their own opportunities
so sure they're going to get the inbound
leads from marketing they're going to
get the people you know the leads that
are handed to them but the best salese
know the value of referrals and so the
way they do that is at the end of the
call or at the time that it makes sense
they say hey do you know anybody else or
my favorite way of asking is who do you
know because it forces the prospect to
answer the question with a not yes no
but with a name you say who do you know
who is as awesome as you now it's a
compliment who would also benefit from
this so now I'm giving them a compliment
by by by asking them for the referral so
I kind of like have a like a nice guy
sandwich there so like you're amazing
who else do you know who's like you who
would love to do this with you or with
us who could benefit from XYZ right now
sometimes if they say no one then
sometimes like this is where Rapport is
important but you could say say
something like why do you hate me so
much and they're like what do you mean
it's like well I only can assume that
you hate us because you don't want
anybody else to know about this amazing
thing and you probably hate your friends
because you want them to suffer as well
right and if it's because you don't
believe me then let's talk about that
but otherwise like why are we not
getting your friends in here because I
can promise you you'll be far more
successful if you have more people you
know who are in it so in the spirit of
bamfam book a meeting from a meeting if
we consider this to be a meeting if you
would like us to help you more with your
sales process acquisition. just started
a workshop division where my sales
director my team will talk to you
specifically about your sales your
process your scripting so we can
Implement some of the things that we
know work in our portfolio into your
business ASAP we do other stuff at the
workshop but we also talk about sales if
that's at all interesting you can book
your next meeting by going to acis.com
clicking the scale button and following
the steps and if you're qualified my
guys will reach
out when I had a team in a different
portfolio company we had one guy who was
outperforming everyone else by a huge
margin this one wasn't as big as the
pullup thing that was massive this was
was about 50% higher than the number
number two guy and we were like what is
this guy doing he was brand new and that
was what was interesting is like brand
new going to the top leaderboard is not
very common because that means that
they're doing a different process right
and so he was following the script and
we listened to the calls like this is
the same call and so when we called him
up we said what are you doing
differently and the thing is he was
multiplying his leads and so what he did
was at the end of the calls he was just
asking who they knew who would also
benefit from this thing and I think they
were they were selling um some sort of
uh tickets of some sort and so he was
saying who else wants to come with you
who else would you like to bring and
it's just a simple little thing that he
was doing but by doing that he was
increasing his sales by 50% because the
referrals even though only one out of
three or one out of four people would
refer the referral close ratees like 80
or 90% And so if you think okay I take
you know four calls and I close one and
I ask for referrals in all all four and
only one of them gives me referral but
then that referral then closes then I
take my one sale out of four and turn it
to two out of five if you're a business
owner thinking about how valuable just
implementing that is consistently is
that your cost to acquire a customer you
just you cut in half by taking one
customer and getting a referral from
that customer and if one out of three
customers refer someone then you cut
your cost to Aire customer by a third
and this is the type of stuff is
advertising becomes more expensive
because it always will become more
expensive that the businesses that do
this the salesmen that do this will be
the ones that win in the future so now
we have a Salesman who has the max
maximum number of hours the maximum
number of days they're pulling up
appointments so that their time on call
closing with the best people is
maximized they're following up before
they're following up after they're doing
personalized reach outs and saying like
hey voice memo hey video hey I've got
this thing for you that I've got set up
for the call um what size shirt do you
want I've set aside uh thing here was
one of the things we did at the gym hey
what color shirt do you want hey what
boxing gloves hey what you do a tiny
little thing hey I've got three gift
cards here I got one for Amazon one for
Starbucks and one for whatever which one
would you prefer right you ask a
preference question prior to the call
and more people show because the thing
is is you're like well shoot this guy's
doing this thing the least I can do is
show up and so they're maximizing the
number of scheduled appointments they're
maximizing the number of shows they're
maximizing the number of opportunities
they're getting from those opportunities
and now we get to the call so now we got
to close
them understand the value of preparation
you would be amazed at how much of a
genius you sound like if you just do 5
minutes of research before a call and so
my rule of thumb for research is that if
it's something that you do all the time
it's about 10% of the time that you're
going to be on a call or meeting that
you can do in prep so if you have a
2-hour call then you've got 12 minutes
of prep if you've got a 60-minute call
then you do six minutes of prep now this
is something that if you do it all the
time if this is like I'm doing a
quarterly meeting then it reverses it's
like 6 hours of prep for 1 hour of
presentation if it's something that you
don't do often and so sales people do
the same call over and over again but
the thing that's different the tiny bit
of difference is the prospect they're
speaking with and so like this applies
to everything like if you're picking a
girl up at her house if you do 5 Seconds
of research in the car before you go in
and you look at what her dad does and
look at the company of the of the father
and say hey so Mr so and so really nice
to meet you so I see you work at you
know whatever engineering like do you
like that stuff I see that they just had
a a press lease coming out do you have
any involvement in that this guy would
immediately see you no matter how you're
dressed what you look like as it's a
it's a check they're like whoo like I
will respect this person because he did
me the honor of actually taking some
time to look me up and figure out more
about my business he didn't show up like
everybody else does not knowing which
way is Sunday trying to figure things
out as they go I'm telling you the best
salespeople take those five minutes they
do that tiny bit of research and the
amount of Rapport that you build in that
first one minute from having those
Secrets the person is then like oh wow
they know about me think about what it
takes to close someone no like and Trust
well all of a sudden you feel known
because they did it you like people who
know more about you and what else do you
do you trust people who know more about
you because you approximate friendship
you approximate a relationship and you
do and you get to do a ton of that at
the first second of the call rather than
taking the five first minutes the call
to show that you don't know what you're
doing right as I started selling gym
owners rather than weight loss when I
was selling my turnaround business I
started getting leads but I didn't have
any like methodology so like I had a
webinar it didn't work and so I just
started finding people on Google using
their emails and so I'd find their
social profiles and I'd liter have to
piece together like a profile of who
this person was cuz the only thing I was
collecting was an email for this webinar
and so I'd find like three or four
social profiles and then I would connect
with them and I would do some research
so that I could make my reach out not
look sketchy as hell and so when I would
do my reach out that I would have all
this data that I put as almost like a
little profile together um about them
and so when I hopped on the phone they
were like whoa like you know a lot about
my gym and I was like well yeah and I
saw that because I look at the images
like so I saw your square footage layout
I think if you move this here this might
actually be able to allow you to double
the amount of usable square footage that
you have for the sessions and that would
help me sell more people into your gym
so I don't know if you're open to
something like that but now I'm coming
with like I see the problem I also have
the solution cuz I thought about it
before we got on the phone cuz I don't
want to waste your time trying to figure
things out now I want to figure them out
beforeand come with you with Solutions
and this is when I was starting out so I
didn't have a reputation yet so I had to
build the reputation by showing up and
providing more value than other people
were ahead of time and this is where
like if you're new and you're coming
into a space you win through prep like
the big guys have the reputation the
small guys went through
preparation the best sales people take
notes this is one of those things that
is just like prep but it preps you for
the next call
and so you do your public preparation
with what you can find and observe you
do your second call preparation with
what you find out on the phone and I'm
telling you if you hop on the phone and
say oh yeah so you've got your daughter
Sarah and Jessica and they're at you
know Colorado and they're finishing up
and you've got X Y and Z happening in
the business is that correct okay cool
just making sure just reading over some
of the past Nots got on the call they're
like oh wow I don't have to resay my
whole life story again this guy now when
this guy makes recommendations I assume
he does it within the cont context of my
business because one of the big things
when you are selling something is that
people want to make sure that it not
only that it works but it's going to
work for them and so you can address
that concern before it ever comes up by
proving that your recommendations are
contextual this is also what switches
you from being a Salesman to a
consultant this is what switches you
from somebody who's just trying to close
to somebody who's trying to
help the most brilliant salespeople
listen more than they talk and this is
one that people get wrong all the time
is that they see super talkative people
I mean moms in high school are like you
should get into sales cuz you don't shut
up uh no that's not not always the case
that's what that's what bad sales people
look like uh and unfortunately the thing
is is the best salespeople don't come
off as salespeople they just
close and so people don't feel sold they
feel like they bought and so everybody
buys stuff every day all the time and
they're buying from companies that have
salespeople and they don't know it so
when you go to a restaurant and they ask
you if you want dessert that's a sale
they get commissions on those things and
if they do it in a weird way you're like
uh I don't want to be sold if they do in
a great way you're like oh I'm so glad
that person made that recommendation and
so you never felt like you got sold you
felt like you bought and so the problem
is that the reputation of salese is
terrible because you only remember the
bad ones we actually did this big study
because we have a huge amount of sales
calls that we can look at across the
whole portfolio and we use software that
analyzes the calls with AI and all that
stuff we can see what's talk time versus
listen time and the best best
salespeople listen twice as much as they
talk and so the little isms that I have
for this is that the person who's
answering the questions is the one
getting interrogated you don't want to
be the one getting interrogated and
whenever you answer questions you give
the other person something to attack and
so you want them to be answering so that
you have things that you can pick apart
and move around if you're the one
answering questions then you're the one
who's getting picked apart and has
things that they can disagree with I
want to be like smoke right they can't
they can't catch anything that I say and
so if someone says you know hey well
tell me tell me what makes you better
than your competition I'd be like well
what things you're looking
for right back to them right it's like
it's like hot potato it's like right
back to you well I would want this this
and this and this I'm like why are those
things important to you right back to
you right like I I can do this all day
right like I I cannot answer because the
thing is is that they believe nothing
that you say they believe everything
that they say and so I need them to say
that it's a good idea not me when I
started selling weight loss I realized
really quickly that I had an agenda of
what I wanted to tell people they needed
to do and I realized that I didn't have
time in 15 minutes to re-educate someone
their last 10 years of life of all the
experiences good and bad that they had
prior to me what I needed to do in that
moment was get them to buy and then I
could spend the rest of my time trying
to do the real education stuff and so I
wanted to Simply align with where they
were coming from to get them to make the
sale and so that was why I started
asking what have you done before for
what did you like what did you not like
rather than picking apart the things
they did and then they like I actually
really like that about that other thing
lost the sale only takes a few times of
doing that to be like I'm going to shut
the [__] up and just let them tell me
what they liked and then I'll say we're
like that and not like that and so the
whole concept here is you want to
educate the prospect so that they can
come to their own conclusion and so the
only gaps that you're filling is is hard
information and I only give that
information after I already know it's
the right answer and so just like
lawyers don't ask questions when they're
on the stand that they don't already
know the answers to should never ask for
the sale unless you already know they're
going to buy and so there are times and
this is where pattern recognition is
helpful for salese this is what the
brilliant salese do is that if they're
like I don't think he's ready there I
don't think he's ready yet and it's like
you don't you don't go for the kill you
just ask more questions like I feel some
hesitation like what are your main
concerns right now like I'm feeling some
hesitation around price talk to me about
that there's two ways by the way if
you're weirded out about asking
questions is that you can both give
commands or ask questions and so you can
change the the Cadence up in the script
by saying so instead of saying for
example hey how's it going it's an easy
first thing a lot of people say on the
first thing of the call but if I say
tell me about your day it's a very
different thing because it it people
have automatic responses to questions
they hear all the time and so if you
want to break a pattern with somebody
and then get them more present you say
tell me about your
T and then like oh uh I mean it it was
good I had a couple calls before this
and you're like oh that's fantastic was
that related to this thing cuz I looked
looked you up online totally different
perspective on that salesperson the
first 30 seconds right so they listen
more than they talk they are like smoke
you only answer questions with questions
unless you already know that the
statement that you're going to say is in
alignment with what you know the person
wants and so if they're like tell me why
you're different then I'd be like well
what have you done in the past because
then it'll give me more context so I can
help explain it now they're going to say
all these things they be like what did
you like about that what did you not
like about that and so when I get to the
point where I actually have to say what
what are things about I'm going to
highlight all the things they liked
about the other stuff and I'm going to
not highlight the things they didn't
like about the other stuff and all of a
sudden they be like this is perfect i'
be like what do you know I just asked
you the question of the things you
wanted and as long as they are the
things that we can actually provide I
highlighted those features about our
thing because I already knew which piano
keys to play cuz you told
me they breathe the script and so the
reason I use that is because that is the
best description I can give is that they
can they can say it without thinking
just like you breathe without thinking
they can say the script without thinking
because you can't listen to a prospect
if you're waiting to talk because you're
trying to remember what you're going to
say next you need to know all of the
script like the Bible or like something
that you've memorized in the past so
that you can be 100% present with the
Prospect and listening and so my
favorite ISM around this is again and
the first time I learned this was I saw
an exceptional sales trainer training a
rep and he was just drilling them on the
opening 30 seconds of the script and so
they did the script and I heard and I
and I was watching him listen to them
while giving them visual cues and so
this is this was a huge advancement in
terms of my understanding of selling
happened because before this I knew how
a sell but I couldn't transfer the skill
but this guy was sitting there and he
was like yep yep yep pause harder on
this word do it again nice do it again
nice one more time nice keep going and
so he would get them to drill it three
times in a row the right way after
making the correction and then he would
keep going in the script and so the
point was is that if you're a
salesperson you need to be able to do it
again and again and again because the
word concision matters a lot you don't
want to be one of these salespeople that
takes a hundred words to say something
you could say in five it'll also make
your sales way longer so again the best
salesperson can take more calls because
they shorten the call required a medoc
salesperson will do the script in the
beginning and it'll close and they will
have coughed right before they asked for
the close and then the person closes and
so they get reinforcement for coughing
and so the next sales call they take
they add a cough in and whether that
person closes or not they're like well
it worked on that other one and so all
of a sudden they add coughing in right
before they close now the next time on
the time that they close let's say on
their fourth call after this they also
added a second question in before the
close so they add the second question in
and then you see where this happens is
that they cough and add a second
question to every single call that they
do and by doing this over time the
length of the script and the length of
the things that salespeople do continues
to expand because they get positive
reinforcement but the reality is that
that person might have just been willing
to buy no matter what and so the script
gets longer and longer even though it
might not have nothing to do with what
was required to close and so you want to
be as concise as humanly possible and
this is with the best sales people do in
order to close the most sales per day
per unit of time because the less time
you're on the phone after make the sale
the more time you have to fill your
calendar back up and close more deals
and so the three tactics this is the
sales managers is that you rehearse the
script every morning they do role plays
meaning let's pretend like I'm a
prospect like you got to you got to get
over whatever your weirdness is with
role playing like I don't know what it
is but so many managers like don't want
to role play like Get over yourself you
have to role play in order for them to
get good and when you do the role
playing you work on one specific part of
the script because if you're doing every
morning you're going to be able to work
through things pretty quickly but you're
like today we're just going to focus on
the intro today we're just going to
focus on the close today I just want you
to focus on how we're overcoming spouse
overcomes I want you to overcome I have
to think about it issues I want you to
give me two or three bangs in a row to
overcome that obstacle because you seem
to be struggling with it right and so by
and you just keep hitting it again and
again and again so that when it comes up
they just breathe it out rather than
thinking about it also because no one
can improve multiple things at the same
time so when you say hey there's nine
things you did wrong one it's a
incredibly discouraging second they
can't improve any of them and so if you
look at any good skills coach whether
it's a basketball coach or it's a
painting coach or a sales coach they
work they might see you have a hundred
things wrong with your game they're just
going to focus on one at a time until
they clean them all up and then all of a
sudden you become an exceptional sales
person so I said I had nine but I have
way more than nine so enjoy so here's
number
10 they kill zombies up front now that's
the term that we use internally you can
say diffuse the bomb which is one that I
did earlier in my career is what I used
to say but I'm Middle Eastern so you
know we had to change that the formal
definition that I use is you've got
obstacles and you've got objections an
obstacle occurs before you've mentioned
the price and so if someone says for
example um you know I have a special
snowflake thyroid issue right and you're
trying to say like you need to do this
thing to lose weight you know that
that's going to blow up on you in the
sale see we're doing bomb references so
you have to address it up front and it's
much easier to address things before you
ask for money than after if you do it
after it's called an objection all right
so I say obstacles are up front you want
to avoid them you want to move around
them right I mean you have to Crush
through them realistically but you get
through those and then objections you
have to handle but now the the time is
ticking on the bomb like now you have a
short period of time before it blows up
on you right uh or the zombie is about
to bite you whatever analogy you want
spouse for example or decision maker or
I'm not going to have time to do this
thing or there's elements of this you
know program or implementation that
aren't a fit for me you want to address
all that stuff up front so that you've
handled everything before the stakes get
lifted When you mention price and then
you go for for the close and the
obstacles and objections that you handle
are always the same and so they're going
to Bubble up to three main things one is
going to be circumstances so
circumstances is going to be time it's
going to be money it's going to be
things about this specific program or
implementation those are all
circumstances those are outside the next
is going to be other people it's going
to be my wife my employees my kid my
some my business partner somebody else
has decision-making Authority and the
third is going to be myself somebody who
themselves doubts that they can do it or
that they will be successful or that
it's the way they want it to be done the
good news is that most of the time when
you're diffusing these bombs they start
with the outside because time money fit
is what I like to call it are things
that are really easy to cast blame to
and it's and it's almost a it's a it's a
response right it's like they don't have
to think about like I don't have time I
don't have the money I don't have I
don't have the card I want like I don't
have the you know whatever if they talk
about an authority figure then it means
that like I would do it but this
person's in the way and so now you're
one step closer to the decision maker
once you handle that if you have
somebody who says I need to think about
it that's actually great cuz it means
you're already two layers of the onion
deeper to just like you're talking to
somebody who's in power who can make the
decision great now you just have to help
help them make the decision and so you
should know all of the key fundamentals
of how to overcome these now you can
memorize each of them which I highly
recommend but I think it's also good to
understand the fundamentals and so this
is what the best salespeople do is that
they have key
stories or metaphors to break the belief
that the person has around that obstacle
so for example if someone says hey um I
can't decide today because you know my
husband and I make all of our decisions
together right now this depends on the
nature of your sale if you're in a
transactional sale and I would say like
a consumer based sale that's under 1,000
bucks maybe 2,000 bucks usually you have
to do that right there if you have like
a B2B sale that's going to be a multi
you know multi call sale then you might
have to bring in stakeholders and so
this is one of the nuances that depends
on the thing you're selling in the price
point but the way that the best sales
people do this is that you play out
something in the past and you play it
out in the future okay so with a
decision maker you'd say hey so let me
tell you about this girl Susan she was
just like you and um she actually had
the same issue come up where she was
like I don't do anything without the
consent of my husband and you know what
happened she walked out her husband said
I don't want you to spend the money I
actually saw her a few years
later and when I talked to her I said
hey so how's how's things going with the
you know the fitness stuff she was like
oh they're they're not and I was like oh
why she was like well my husband never
lets me do anything and I was like oh
geez um that's got to be kind of rough
and she's like yeah it sucks and so the
thing is is that if you play it out into
the future like you're going to end up
resenting that person because they're
not letting you do what you want and so
I think what you're asking for is
permission when you really need support
that's how you how you like you go from
past to Future right and so then you can
play it out with this person so so let's
play it out five years so over the last
five years you've gained 5 pounds a year
so you're 25 pounds heavier so 5 years
from now if you're 25 pounds heavier
than you are right now they're like oh
my God if I'm 25 pounds heavier than I
am but that's just the track you're on
and so let's play it out it like what if
they say
no and so sometimes they're like well
then I would do it anyways then you're
like awesome let's sign you up now one
out of three times that's actually what
happened which is crazy I still am blown
away by that but then the two out of
three times then I go you want
permission not support now if you're
looking at time or money for example
then you say hey we need uh we need
resourcefulness not resources so it's
like you have your little isms that you
can remember if it's time then it's well
is it a seasonal thing because if it's a
seasonal thing means you're busy right
now uh and you might be you know less
busy later that assumes that you'll
never be busy again and so do you want
this thing to be long lasting this
implementation or do you want it to be
just like only for the time that you're
not busy and then you'll fall off again
when when you get busy well shoot I want
it to last forever it's like okay well
then you should probably start when
you're busy cuz that's what I'm going to
be giving you the most support is now so
that when you get to the the free time
it'll be easy coasting and when you get
busy again you know how to stick with it
because you had the support right and so
again it's like you have to be able to
dismantle these things because you
understand all of these there's a
fundamental underlying fallacy of giving
away power to something else because
people don't want to make mistakes they
don't want to fail and so they come up
with all of these excuses they come up
with time they say like that's the
seasonal thing you can have time in
terms of the money micro which is I
don't have time in my day I'm like well
you're here so when were you imagining
this is why you do this up front when
were you imagining how much time can you
dedicate to this implementation to this
SEO agency to this weight loss program
whatever it is right if you ask that up
front then if they say oh I don't have
time with it then you can say well what
changed between then and now just so I
have understanding did I ask the
question in a weird way that made you
like not understand it um and again this
is where tone matters a lot cuz now
you're in the red zone right now it's
like the bomb's way more sensitive cuz
the the the the time ticker is going and
so we want to be extra this is where
Rapport is so important in the beginning
because I I'll add this in this is a
bonus one I call it the ghetto tone okay
and I learned this from Sam back so he
had a personal training business and
that's why I I shadowed underneath when
I got into fitness he let me just work
for him for minimum wage uh and so I
learned how the gym business worked but
anyways I saw him have this you know
rich white lady doesn't put her weights
back right and he was still training at
the time like he was training sessions a
little bit um and so he was like girl
he's like I know you ain't about to
leave my gym without putting your
weights back and he's a Persian dude
right but he would get into this kind of
like ghetto like whatever you want to
call it way of talking and she'd be like
fine I'll go put him back and I thought
about that and I was like man if I had
just been like hey Susan can you put
your weights
back like she's like I pay for personal
training you can put my weights back
like that could get really bad really
fast but when you say it like that all
of a sudden it's like I'm communicating
the same thing and I get the desired
result and they think it's fun and
light-hearted and so in the same sense
when you're in the clothes I use a ton
of humor and that tonality to diffuse
hard conversations so I say like girl I
was like five minutes ago I was like you
had four hours a week I was like what
happened to my four hours if I say that
no one's going be upset with me they' be
like ah well I mean I didn't know that
it was going to be X Y and Z and then
I'll be
like fine I know like and then then then
tone switch and you're like what's
really going
on and then you get the real stuff
because guess
what closers ask hard questions right
and they're the questions it's the place
where you don't want to go versus where
you need to go which is you want them to
diffuse the bomb in front of you not
when they get home right and so you
don't want them to sit with the decision
you want them to confront it's like you
might be wondering this is a lot of
money let's talk about it right you
might be wondering if your husband's
going to be against it well let's talk
about some reasons that he might not be
against it let's talk about uh what your
business partner will say if you buy
this without their permission let's talk
about that right and so you want to
confront those ugly things you don't
want to cuz like you're not like if I if
you take anything from this the best
salespeople want to confront it because
they're better at selling them than they
are at selling themselves so you want
them to confront the obstacle in front
of you so that you can help them through
it so don't wait for like you're not
going to avoid it I promise you you
think you're avoiding the landmine but
like CU sometimes you hear that thing in
the beginning of the call and you're
like that's a bit I don't know if I want
to blow the call dude it's going to blow
up in the close if you can't even can't
even confront it before you've mentioned
price it's definitely coming up after
you mention price so like confront it
now so one of my favorite ways to get to
the hard question is asking what are you
afraid of
happening and then I follow that with
let's just play it out a lot of times
it's like people don't even want to look
at what's going to happen it's like no
let's play it out right like I remember
I had this this sale that happened where
I had a lady who was like I follow Dave
Ramsey and I have envelopes of cash and
if I give you this envelope that's my
grocery money for the week uh if I do
this program and I was like okay well
what are you afraid of and she like
paused and I was like is it that you
won't be able to afford food I was like
would you be afraid of that and she was
like well yeah CU she thought she was
going to win the sale day but it was a
trap um and I was like but you're trying
to lose weight I was like worst case
scenario don't afford food you lose some
weight I was like whenn win now I did
that with a good tone so she got a laugh
out of it right and I was like but let's
be real I was like have you ever bought
anything in the past that you weren't
sure you could afford I was like and
where are you now you still survived
you're not on the couch right I was like
we always make it work in the end right
and you have to you cut somewhere else I
was like this is something that's going
to last with you forever like you have
all these clothes I was like you want to
make all of them look better in 6 weeks
I was like just lose 20 lbs what are you
afraid of let's play it out best case
worst case when you do that you can
basically take away the emotion from the
decision and say okay worst case
scenario you're on your friend's couch
and you know what you were poor before
this and you were happy then too so
worst case scenario is you're in the
same position you've been in before and
it was fine best case scenario you
change your life
forever so does that feel like a bet
you're willing to
take right and so if you if you just you
want to confront it and then walk into
what they're afraid of and just say
let's play it out so this happens here
this happens here best case worst case
and I can tell you like I've probably
closed more sales on best case worst
case than any other close I
have ask for the sale again and so this
is a big one if you do not ask for the
sale you will not get it that is a
promise once you ask if you ask again
you'll increase the likelihood that they
buy now there's a right way to do this
and a wrong way to do this if you just
ask again when someone says no bad look
if someone says no and you ask why and
then you resolve the why then you ask
again and that makes sense says hey I
can't make Tuesdays and you say no
worries if we're able to do it on
Thursday would that work for you and
they say yes they say awesome so you
want to move forward you ask again right
so all you're doing is resolving the
concern there's terms in the industry
called looping or you know uh obstacle
overcomes whatever whatever wording you
want to use is that you resolve the
concern and you ask again and you can do
this literally unlimited times as long
as you resolve the concern and then you
ask again I mean Lila will tell you that
like if it was either a Sunday sale cuz
I usually had way less calls on Sundays
um or it was the last appointment of the
day for me she just knew that I would
always close that sale because I would
just have unlimited time because I was
like I will just keep going and so I ask
again and again and again and I had um I
had a partner back in the day I don't
know if I like the visual but he's like
he's like you're like a pit pull on
someone's ankle he's like you just will
not [__] let them leave and I was
like it's cuz I think I think that they
need it they came in cuz they're trying
to lose weight we sell weight loss
what's the problem like we just have to
figure it out and usually it's just like
it's mounds of stuff you have to UNP of
all these excuses of all the times that
they've been unsuccessful in their lives
it's like they came in because they want
to solve the problem and when then they
get confronted with the decision they
get freaked out again because they reli
this past traumas of the things they've
tried and then feeling like a failure
and then they associate that failure
with you in the moment you're like hey
Susan calm down we're just going to have
you eat some [__] chicken and walk a
little bit it's going to be okay and so
the best closers come from the frame of
helping the Prospect and so I will tell
you this right now the best salespeople
care more about the prospect than they
do so whoever cares the most about the
prospect wins the sale and so if they
care more about themselves then they
will win now you're like well of course
they're going to care more about
themselves ah if you have more context
than they do which you should because
you know more about the product than
they do you should be able to have the
best perspective to say no I'm not going
to let this guy's limiting beliefs get
in the way cuz I really want to help him
or really want to help her and I can see
that today it feels safe to retreat back
to not taking action on this huge pain
that they have but I can see how this is
going to play out cuz I've seen a
hundred other people just like them walk
out the door and I see them you know a
year later and they're the exact same
position or worse and I don't want that
for them and so if you keep the human at
the Forefront of your mind when you're
making the sale you'll never come across
pushy because you they can hear the
intention they can hear the tonality in
your voice about you actually just
trying to help them so when you ask for
the sale again having key stories and
metaphors that you can use to break
beliefs is what allows you to then ask
again and you can do that literally
unlimited times as long as they have
time and you have time and you address
the problem now if you don't address the
problem and ask in they go annoy so you
just want to make sure that you have an
answer and you should have an answer
because you've had this conversation
before there's nothing they should be
able to tell you that should surprise
you if we zoom out we have a salesperson
who has maximum hours maximum days they
have as many time slots per day filled
up with the best Prospect effect CU they
work them well they have a plan before
and after to come prepared to the call
and take notes and follow up with them
bam famam the whole thing and when
they're on the call they're completely
present they breathe the script they
know how to handle obstacles they have
they have analogies and stories and
metaphors memorized so they can help
people overcome their issues they stick
to the script they don't add to the
script they keep their word concision as
tight as humanly possible so they can
maximize the number of sales they have
per day and maximize the conversion rate
of those sales fundamentally sales by
the way I should have defined this
earlier is increasing the likely that
the prospect buys that's all it is so
everything that has to do with sales
like if you had the perfect sales
process it means you would account for
every single variable that could ever
happen to any human and you would get
100% of people who go through this
process to buy that's what a perfect
sales process would be and so it's a
percentage conversion that's all it is
and so with that we have maximum
opportunities maximum percentage
conversion we have an amazing sales rep
but what if they can only do it for a
day that gets into the third bucket
which is what I would consider meta
skills which is traits of the best
salespeople the things that most sales
people struggle with are trait issues
meaning they are on and then they're off
again they're on and they're off they
get motivated they get demotivated
motivated demotivated if you feel like
this then it's a skilled deficiency you
just don't know how to sustain
performance for a long period of time
and I promise you the difference between
Champions and everyone else is they can
sustain performance it's not like I
don't know if sales is for me um I don't
know if I'm growing enough in my dude
here's the cleared deficiencies you
can't stay consistent there's some
growth that you can tackle right now
being consistent another kind of meta
skill around this is enthusiasm like
they're enthusiastic one week they're
not enthusiastic the next week being
able to sustain and maintain a high
level of enthusiasm for with the role
and when you're on the call is a skill
it's a skill you whistle while you work
you got to learn how to do it you got to
learn to like the stuff you don't love
so you can do the thing you really love
which is
sales the best sales people kill for
sport so let me tell you this a little
analogy huh notice a little iies so I
heard this from uh Mike Ary and I just
love this he said there's three types of
sales people there's dogs horses and
tigers he like dogs you got to feed them
and if you don't feed them they starve
to death and you got to you got to give
them all this attention you got to rub
their belly every day and the moment you
stop they die horses they will Gallop as
long as you keep whipping them but the
moment you stop Galloping they just go
down to a trot he's like but Tigers he
said a tiger can eat a full meal but
then if a bunny walks across his line of
vision we'll kill the bunny for sport
he's like you want tigers and I love
that little analogy because the best
sales people that I've ever met in my
life they love sales they love the
thrill of the clothes of the hunt when I
was selling weight loss I would
sometimes have homeless people and
things like that that would come in who
would respond to my ads it would happen
right I had two ways to take it I could
try and not take it seriously try and
just like basically just get through the
sale so I could move on with my life or
I could see it as free practice and
what's crazy is the amount of times
where I judge someone as poor and turned
out that they just dress different I
don't know anything about
that was more times than I can count and
a lot of them were like hey I appreciate
you're just like you know Trea me well I
was like of course I was like this is a
business your money spends the same and
so you either practice the skill or you
close either way you win it's a lot like
lifting weights where if you have your
warm-up reps and they look different
than your heavy reps you're actually not
practicing at all so you're wasting all
these opportunities that you could be
practic practicing your skill sharpening
the sword which is what we call it in
the sales world you could be sharpening
your sword but you're actually making it
duller CU you're practicing the wrong
way you're learning bad habits by not
taking the sale seriously so the best
sales people kill for sport and so I had
uh I'll tell you a Jacob story which is
my my young my young you know started
with me at like 15 and now he's been
with me however many years seven he
started as a low man on the totem pole
and so when we would have lesser
qualified leads they handed all of them
to Jacob he's like I'll be the garbage
man he's like take anybody's leads he's
like I just want to get good I just want
to practice and so he's trying to take
as many reps as he possibly could and
guess what happened he started taking
more reps than everyone else did and
guess what happened after that he got
better than other people did cuz he took
more reps and he took every one of these
as a [__] gift which is what it is is
that someone's going to give you the
time to learn the skill of sales the
business paid for that lead maybe it's
less qualified they paid for it just the
same and you have the benefit of
learning the amount of people who want
to learn how to sell better and are
unwilling to take quote unqualified
leads is ridiculous to me it's free
practice with stakes and you still have
the possibility of winning and closing a
deal track data the best salespeople
track data and so they're meticulous
about the data they track and so let me
explain this so you can judge and I've
just seen this across my portfolio the
skill of any person in any Endeavor that
they practice by the quantity and
quality of the metrics they track and so
if someone says oh I'm good at sales i'
be like cool tell me about the metrics
you track now if if they're like ah just
you know close rate it's like well
there's so many other metrics that you
could track to understand how good you
are at sales because the close rate is
really just an outcome it gives you no
leading indicators it tells you nothing
else right I want to know what
percentage of leads you're booking I
want to know what percentage of of
scheduled things are showing I want to
know of show rate what percentage are
you offering of offer how many of you're
closing how many how many what's your
average call to close are you doing one
call two call 1.2 like what's your
what's your average number what's your
average number of cash collected like
there's so many other metrics that you
can track to know how well you're doing
as a salesperson and yes for everybody
like shout this from the rooftops if you
can get their schedule rate up by 20%
it's just as good as getting their close
rate up by 20% and so there's so many
other things in the funnel that the best
sales people know about closing about
how to increase the total number of
sales they get by controlling all of the
other variables that are under their
control now the bad guys the dogs are
like I only want these times and I want
them to be spoonfed to me and if I don't
get them fed there and you don't pat me
on the head I'm going to starve to death
and die right that's what the dogs do
and if you've got sales people like that
they're dogs I don't care how many how
much experience they have they're dogs
right tigers are like I want to be
available to kill whenever because I
just love the hunt I would do this for
free I'm just happy I get paid to do it
pro tip if you are somebody who's
running a sales team if you want to
increase the close rates across the
entire team even more give the best
closers the best leads and the way you
do that is that you have to start by
scoring your leads first which means you
actually have to track data so you can
say these people have the highest
likelihood of closing when they have
these three characteristics they close
at a way higher percentage and then you
give those leads to the best guys so
fundamentally you'd want the worst leads
to go to the worst guy the best leads to
go to the best guy and everyone in
between and so by doing that you
actually match the org and so I actually
had a Salesman that I knew who was the
top sales rep for a time share business
and it's exactly what you think it was
so it's a billion dollar plus company
this guy was making 3 million a year in
commission selling time shares and I had
with him and I was like what do you do
you know differently and he said well I
won the sales competition and so I got
one hour with the CEO and on that one
hour with the CEO which is the prize for
winning the sales competition it was
3,000 sales people it was number one he
said I just said if you give me the best
leads instead of wasting them on these
guys who are new he's like I will make
you so much money and so the guy
experimented with his little Division
and he 5x his income as the sales guy
and then they took it and they rolled it
out Nationwide and they 5X the business
and so there's a huge opportunity in
every business to give the best closers
the best leads because you make more
money and what happens is is that the
best guys will actually make more and
more and more money which then creates a
survivorship bias for new guys coming in
and so if you know that best guy used to
make 200,000 a year as the top closer
but now can make 800,000 a year the
amount of sales people that you will
attract your opportunity will 10x now
even though the entry level guys now
make less than they did before the
opportunity just like the lottery the
same reason people buy tickets is they
assume that they're going to get there
and so by having it this way you'll have
people come in willing to make less
because they know that if they if they
perform well they'll go to the big
leagues now the other benefit of this is
that you train your new guys on the
worst leads so you lose the least money
as a business but they also develop
their skills because they've got to
learn how to Big borrowed steel and
squeeze blood from the stones from the
least qualified customers and so when
they get to somebody who's got a 700
credit score and actually has intent to
buy they're like oh my God this is
amazing because they practiced on
somebody who's like missing an arm and
missing seven credit cards and they are
in bankruptcy and they're actually in
the middle of a divorce and the real
name isn't Al it's actually Larry and
you know it's complicated I'm a little
liquid right now I'm between thing you
know whatever right and they're closing
those people for lunch money uh and so
when you learn how to do that when you
get to like qualified prospects you're
like oh my God this amazing but at that
point the business doesn't bear the cost
the salesperson does so that they can
develop their skills cuz just being
real you're still paying them to learn
and I'd rather pay as little as I can so
I can allocate the resources the best
way possible in the
business my biggest pet peeve and the
reverse of that is my favorite thing
about the best salespeople is they never
blame circumstances so whenever I have a
salesperson is like the leads are bad or
you know uh these These people aren't a
good fit or just like whatever BS that
they can come up with or like I don't
like the commission structure we should
change
like just focus on the things you can
control right and the guys that I love
the most never complain they pick up the
extra shifts they call the leads the
most they work them the most they're
like these leads are amazing I'm so
grateful to have these and be able to
practice and get paid to do it and
there's a time and a place for giving
feedback on stuff group calls not one of
them if you are one of these salese you
give it oneone with the manager say hey
by the way I've noticed like some people
get on the phone just objectively like
their credit scores are just
consistently lower than they were a
couple months ago I don't know if we've
changed anything on the marketing side
I'm going to approach the leads the same
I love The Practice just thought might
be you know useful data for marketing
right that's very different than like
dude these leads are [__] I'm I'm not
taking these calls right that's just a
primadonna and I hate that and so again
the worse the leads the better you get
the flex your skill and the best sales
people take 100% of the control and the
best marketers take 100% of the control
too and so if everybody is taking
absolute blame for every outcome guess
what you win we doubled one of our
portfolio company sales by tweaking
several tiny things in the sales process
and you can use all the same tactics in
your business too enjoy three young
Founders who are all sad because they
were not making the amount of money that
they wanted to make so before I show you
the data let me explain what each of
these terms actually mean so show rate
is the percentage of people who have an
appointment who show up for their
appointment so in any business if if you
deal with people you will have sessions
or appointments you have a time slot
that someone says they're going to show
up right if it's a sales consult then
they are a prospect and they're going to
show up to get sold so if I have 100
people have an appointment and 70 show
up that would be a 70% show rate the
second one here is offer rate which we
forgot to put in the rate so let me just
put that in for you there you go offer
rate which is the percentage of people
that we actually make an offer to you
might be like well why would I not offer
everybody well not everyone's qualified
and so for example if I work with only
gym owners and somebody comes on it's
like Oh I'm a personal trainer well you
shouldn't be here we had all these other
things that said don't be here but you
still came why are you here that means
that you don't offer them anything and
that's it now if 100% of people who
showed up show right you are able to
offer to then that means that your offer
rate would be 100% And that is an
indicator of the quality of the lead
flow that you have the third is close
rate this depends on how you can track
this all right so you can either do it
based on percentage of people who show
or you can do it on percentage of people
who are offered what I normally do is
I'll just track both I'm going to guess
that this one is off of offer rate
because it's what we have here it's good
to have both stats here because let's
say a Sal man wants to artificially
increase his close rate well then he
will just say well I'm not going to
offer anyone unless I know they're going
to say yes and so then their close rate
is high and then they'll show that
there's a really low quality score but
if that salesman this is why having team
stats is so important and individually
is because if the team is all saying
that they're offer rate 70 and one guy
saying his offer rate's 30 but he has
100% close rate and they all have 30%
close rates we know where the data went
and this is why having high quality data
allows you to see what the problems are
if I didn't have this percentage then I
wouldn't know it's because we have low
quality leads or because my salesman
suck this data allows me to identify the
problem and then fix it so the fourth
set here is percentage of cash collected
up front meaning if we're selling $1,000
widgets and the average cash we collect
today is $500 because people do payment
plans then we would know our cash
collected percentage would be 50% if I
have a low close rate but High cash
collected percentage that would tell me
a different story than a really high
close rate and really low cash collected
percentage i' be like oh so they're just
getting anyone to say yes and taking $10
down if they can versus somebody saying
we have a hard line and so it's really
trying to find the magic between these
two and saying how can I get as many
people to say yes and get as much cash
collected up front the final one here is
just unit sold and this is really just
the output of these four well if we
multiply these things together how many
do we end up closing and that's the
result so beforehand damn we had a 49%
show rate so let's say we have 100
appointments now we have 49 who actually
show up for their appointment and then
of the 49 we're able to offer 83% of
them beforehand so 80% of that is 40 40
people now are getting offered out of
our original 100 appointments of the
people who get offered 27% of them which
is 10 people roughly are actually buying
in that closing percentage and then our
cash collected from those 10 people is
we're getting a little less than half of
the cash that we closed down now I gave
you 100 as a number but the actual
number of units sold for this business
in the prior month was 56 units all
right so this is current state if you
don't know these numbers in your
business you should so that you can
improve them let's say I invested in
your business today the first thing we
want to do is get the data so that so we
can see what Baseline is so we can see
where the discrepancies are and where we
think the biggest opportunities for
improvement are and you're going to have
to wait till the end of the video I'm
going to show you what happened after so
let's start with problem number one or
opportunity for improvement number one
we had a low show rate as in based on
our benchmarks of 70% for any kind of
appointment type business we think that
we should have at least 70 there Allen
which was a company that I had all we
did was show rates we were doing 4,000
appointments a day we experimented we
had a machine learning team to think
like what was the number of
communications that we had to have with
a prospect what was the delay between
responses that got the most people what
were the total number of exchanges how
far apart were the exchanges there is
lots of data that we were able to
collect so their number was 49% of
appointments were showing up what we
wanted them to be at was 70% this is our
Benchmark where we'd say okay this isn't
a problem anymore now do we want to
improve things absolutely but where are
we going to allocate our effort at the
constraint this was a constraint now to
give context here this Delta is a 40%
difference 40% is a lot think about the
S&P 500 they're like we trying grow 9% a
year it's like boom I unlock that I get
40% growth I don't have to do anything
else for like 4 years in the S&P big
wins that's what we look for lots of
things can affect show rate by the way
the number one one that affects show
rate is number of total time I sa
available take that to the bank but one
of the other ones is the targeting and
the offer itself so targeting is who's
actually seeing this promotion if I'm
targeting teeny boppers for example I
might get people to schedule but then
realize that they're not here for a
laser hair removal appointment so the
targeting there would be off and and so
that would affect our show rate and that
has nothing to do with our lead nurture
sequence or our salesman or anything
like that it's just the wrong people
were seeing it so that was issue number
one for context for us just imagine
that's underneath it was 25 to 35y olds
who were gainfully employed and love
their job and this when we came in to
look at it was actually targeting 18 to
24y olds the reason that this was far
off for us is that the ad objective now
I'm going to get a little bit tactical
with you ad acis.com at hold Co we have
media buyers we have Pros who do this
for a living and so when they zoomed in
on how their Med a buyer was optimizing
the traffic they were optimizing against
what a lot of people would initially
think they should do which is optimizing
for the lowest cost leads and the lowest
cost appointments what we had to do we
switch to optimize around cost per sale
if we can optimize around who we
actually sell to we will shift where the
sales come from and just to give you how
big of a problem this was they had to
cancel 75% of their appointments before
the 49% show rate the sales guys are
spending most of their time just looking
at their appointment looking up the
person cancelling to get their 49% show
rate and that's about the closest thing
to literally burning money so second big
problem was multitasking and this really
goes for any role but especially like
sales-driven roles they had a setting
team and a closing team and the Setters
were both trying to call leads to get
appointments and then also nurturing and
doing the follow-up to remind them of
the appointment and it's similar as that
may sound in your mind it's two
completely different activities you're
banging phones calling people up you're
in that flow and then you're like oh
wait Sarah has an appointment today let
me go REM mind Sarah does Sarah going to
interrup it and you're like wait I'm
calling and then you start like and it's
you go back and forth right so they had
three big issues number number one is
that they weren't double dialing right
which is one of the most common things
that you can do by the way if you're
doing phone calls because a lot of
initial screens will stop the first call
but if you dial twice you'll get through
number two is that the time to contact
was too slow so lead would come in and
they would just like sit there for 30
minutes 60 minutes an hour 2 hours 3
hours right and they weren't getting
contacted it's like what did this person
do they're like oh I'd like to find out
more information nothing and the third
thing is that they didn't have the right
times to set appointments and they
weren't nurturing correctly so we go
same day next day I'm just giving you
some secrets and they didn't have
morning of nurture meaning if you have
an appointment today and you booked this
appointment 3 days ago if I don't remind
you that day that you have an
appointment the likely that you show is
lower and so these are the problems that
they have no double dial slow speed to
contact and they didn't have any mning
of nurture but wait there's more the
second problem they had or opportunity
for improvement was that they had a low
close rate and this is based on our
Benchmark I would normally give you a
kpi but it has so many different
variables in terms of what percentage
Clos rate is cuz if you're selling in
person for example for a low ticket
thing you might be able to sell 80% plus
of people walking the door on the flip
side if you're selling an investment
opportunity over the phone on you know a
first or second contact you might sell
5% but for this particular type of sale
that they had which was a two call close
for like I would say a mid-priced
consumer service in my opinion they
should have been about 40% so 40% is
what I wanted them to be at and then
current was 27% so this is where they
were this is where we wanted them to be
and again for context here this is about
a 50% Improvement so problem number one
is that they had service level Discovery
if you're not familiar with that
terminology in a sales script there's
different kind of phases that you go
through in a conversation and the
opening part is often a little bit of
Rapport and then right after that you
get into Discovery and Discovery is
where you're discovering what the
problems that the person's going through
you're trying to understand why they are
where they are why they're on the phone
with you why they decided to take time
out of their day why this problem's
important to them what they've tried in
the past etc etc right this is the
Discovery this gives you all the
ammunition that you're going to use at
the end of the sale to close it so the
way that they were doing was simply
saying how much money do you want to
make just asking the one question which
is the big obvious question it's surface
level but the big thing that you always
want to ask when you're selling is
intention why do they want this like
what changes as a result of this how
will your life look different what can
you not do now that you would be able to
do as a result of this change who else
in that in your life would that affect
why does that matter to you right and so
these are all why questions and it's to
to dig up their intentions because if
you can understand why someone's there
it's much easier to get them to agree to
getting them there right but if you
don't know that someone's trying to
let's say replace their income versus
quit their job versus just have side
hustle money those are very different
intentions if I want to talk to side
hustle money I'm probably not going to
be like this is going to take a ton of
time on the flip side if someone's like
I hate my job I just want to do
something that's not this then I might
talk about what the day-to-day looks
like in this scenario and ask them if
that sounds better to them so if you
think about sales process
what they were doing is they were asking
questions that were here surface level
but this is where all the meat is and
that's where all the money is is the
questions that are below the surface is
understanding why someone's even doing
this to begin with look at that Iceberg
killer Iceberg and so the second issue
is that they had a lot of objections
coming up on the call I'll say
objections but I also mean obstacles for
those of you who are sales sales senses
objections happen after you talk about
the number obstacles happen before you
talk about the number if you come on the
phone and I say hey why are you here and
you're like I just want to find out more
information that's actually an obstacle
like you already have to confront that
cuz like no you're not hopping on phone
calls all day trying to find information
what problem you trying to solve and
then they're like well and then you get
into it right but if you don't address
that up front it'll blow up on you in
the cloes so objections and obstacles is
what they were encountering a lot of and
part of that is because they Discovery
was wrong right they were talking to
service levels so then lots of [__] was
blowing up on them in the close common
objections that happen after you present
price is uh this is too much I need to
think about it I have to talk to my
spouse I'm not sure if this is for me
I'd like to get more data can you send
me a brochure like these are all just
the make believe things that people will
say in order to not buy from you
interestingly a lot of times if you stay
in the surface level they'll even give
you what we call Smoke screens but
basically like they'll just come up with
uh a reason that they're not going to do
it and it's not even the reason they
just throw a smoke bomb up and they're
like I don't like English you know walk
away right has nothing to do with it
they just want to get off the phone so
those are the two issues that we had on
the sales and that was getting us to
this 27% close rate and what this looks
like is lots of argumentation and like
hard closing and it's because the S
isn't positioned properly and they were
basically talking at people and not
listening if the salesperson is talking
more than the prospect in your sales
like these are likely issues that are
coming up I'm going to give you two
examples real quick to show you how
important delivery of a messages so if I
say I have to think about it and I say
oh like what are your main concerns or
what are the main like what are the main
variables that you're considering you're
not thinking wow this guy's a douchebag
I sound like I just genuinely want to
know I call it childlike curiosity I
always cue it by tilted my head I'm like
huh what are the main things and I would
increase my voice at the end there an
improperly trained salesp person might
be like well what are the main concerns
you have and all of a sudden that sounds
like a very different thing so they're
saying the script but they're not but
the prospect isn't hearing the same
message and these are little details
that actually can make a huge difference
in ultimately how you close there's a
lot of things in tone but I'll just say
one is how you raise or lower your voice
and the second is where you choose to
emphasize if I say I didn't say he hit
his wife if I say like that I have
neutral Tone If I say I didn't say he
hit his wife then it's like I'm not
saying that I didn't say he hit his wife
is now saying that like those weren't my
words I didn't say he hit his wife he's
the one to question I didn't say he hit
his wife means like he might have done
something else but he did something to
his wife I didn't say he hit his wife it
could have been somebody else's I didn't
say he hit his wife it might have been
his kid right and so it's the same
sentence but simply emphasizing
different parts of it communicate
different things and so the tone and
emphasis create a altogether package of
how we communicate and for them their
tonality was way off as a team because
they were missing the first five minutes
of discovering and setting the frame
properly and so I'll give you the last
set of problems opportunities for
improvement and then we'll dive into
what we did to solve them and what
happened sales problem three opportunity
for improvement people in orc structure
issues so issue number one is that CEO
was the sales manager and that was
because he was the best closer he had a
significantly higher close rate than the
rest of the team but he wasn't a very
good sales manager even though he was a
good Closer by the way that's one of the
main issues that a lot of sales teams
have they promote their best closer as a
sales manager and often times those are
two very different skills and we could
see this because the churn on their
sales team was through the roof just to
be clear like they were a group of young
Founders it's not uncommon it's actually
probably very common because usually
when you start a business learning how
to promote and sell the product is
usually the job of the founders like how
do I get people to want to buy the thing
and so they end up getting the most reps
early on and also understanding the
prospect better than just about anyone
and so one of the big things you guys
were in a little mini sales last I is
that companies will over educate on the
product and under educate on the
prospect the person that you should be
educating your sales stuff on is who
we're talking to more than what we're
selling cuz for me if I know someone
deep in their core what their intentions
are I can tell them anything I know
someone inside and out and then someone
says sell this thing and I know nothing
about it I could probably get them to
buy on the flip side I know everything
about this thing and I don't know who
I'm talking to talking to a child a man
a woman old young different language and
so a lot of people talk like hey sell me
this pen when in reality what we want to
do is like talk to John the majority of
good sales trainers who try to do that
gimmick what they want the person to do
is ask them a question it actually has
nothing to do with the pen and so if
they say sell me this pen what you do is
you take the pen and you put it in your
pocket and you say how's it going what
brought you in today right cuz I got to
go from where they're at to wanting a
pen I'm not going to just be like hey
buy this pen give me money like it
doesn't work that way but bad salesmen
do so the second issue was the setting
team expectations one of the benefits of
working with someone who has more
experience is that we know what the
Benchmark should be and so a lot of
times we can reset some 's minimum
standard and they're like well they're
setting two a day and we're like they
should all be minimum setting three and
that sounds tiny but again 2 to three is
a 50% increase in sets and that's across
a whole team so that means a lot of
productivity but if you set the bar low
people just naturally shrink down to
that level all right so you understand
the problems and here is the data this
is before they had a low show rate issue
they had low close rate and multiple
issues around that and they had people
in organizational issues I want you to
pause real quick in the video in the
comments to be like what would you do
how would you attack these issue if this
was your business and then I'll tell you
what we
did now there's two elements of
solutions element one is what would you
do to attempt to solve the problem and
the second is which one do we do in what
order the third problem that was
actually the first thing we decided to
fix was so we hired a sales director the
reason for that was because the CEO was
overly involved he was micromanaging he
wasn't a good manager and he also wasn't
doing CEO stuff and so we had to hire an
experienced sales director who in this
instance had been a sales trainer for a
similar type of sale in a consumer good
this guy ended up being exceptional and
being able to implement the rest of the
changes that we outlined so this was in
terms of order of importance I think if
we hadn't done this and had tried to do
the rest of them it would have fallen
flat this is like one of the most common
errors that business owners and Founders
make is that they see the what and not
the who or they focus on the how and not
The Who and if you have the same problem
that has recurred multiple quarters in a
row in the same Department underneath of
the same who it might not be a what
issue it might be a who issue one of the
reasons having experience is he
is because you know what it looks like
when it's right some of the biggest
costs in the business are hiring
incorrectly you waste the time trying to
find them you waste the time onboarding
them and training them and then you
waste the time of all the time it takes
you to figure out that they're not the
right fit and all the loss growth that
you would have had to then start that
process over again that's tough but a
lot of businesses have to deal with that
which is why picking Personnel is so
important with this instance we looked
at culture fit which is like do we think
that this guy will fit in which we
usually the founders pick that part out
like hey does this guy fit in cool and
then we're going to hardcore drill on
usually experience and tactical
knowledge and so we have subject matter
experts at holdco media buying cro
experts sales experts Finance expert
whatever and we will then do tactical
interviews we talked about earlier you
can know that someone is good based on
the quality and quantity of the data
that they collect I would ask somebody
what data do you plan on collecting and
how would you plan on fixing those
things based on how vague they are and
how high level they go in terms of their
Solutions it'll tell you how nuan they
can be in their thinking and ultimately
executing Solutions sales directors
specifically in my experience when I
have guys who are like I just want to
build up people I want to give these
guys skills and they marry that with
like and these are the metrics that I
track to know X Y and Z that's a good
sales director the next thing we decided
to solve boom was fixing the ad
targeting and the reason we did the
sales director first was because we're
like well how do we know if anything
else is going to happen afterwards if we
fix this so what we ended up doing here
it turns out is that we also had another
Personnel issue the media buyer was
asleep at the wheel they were optimizing
around the wrong stuff they were trying
to split their attention and start their
own side hustle it was clear that they
were negligent they actually were doing
the right thing and then they stopped
doing the right thing and it was clear
that that type of behavior the founders
felt was not going to correct itself so
they let go of that person hired a new
person and boom fixed the ad targeting
problem we were back to 25 to 35y old
people who love their job what did we
fix next boom We reduced the sales team
what and we reset expectations for the
setting team what we looked at is sales
team utilization if we know that guys
can take 10 sales a day and they're
actually only taking four then we have
too many sales people in this instance
it gives you an opportunity to to cut
the fat for lack of better term and
reward the people who are actually doing
their jobs and closing well if you cut
the lowest percentage of the team and
you have utilization like you have space
you lose the lowest closing percentage
people and you gain more closes just by
Shifting the closing rate overall of the
team when you make those changes in my
experience sales people get into a
rhythm if you don't take enough sales
calls you're too desperate to close the
deal and then you start being too hard
and not listening enough cuz it's about
you not them when sales people have more
and more consults they sell from the
back of their heel they're open-minded
they're asking questions they're feeling
good and they get in a rhythm the
setting team we both downsized and
increased expectations how did all these
sales increase by having fewer people we
had better people that's how and that
also helps recreate the culture of the
team so that we can have a new standard
set of high performers because there's
nothing that demotivates a high
performer like a low performer who's
still on the team and so we went from
two to four in terms of our expectation
per day for the team in terms of sets
sales fix numero qu I'm messing all my
columns up now just going to have to
deal with it we promoted one Setter to
lead nurture specialist I was saying
earlier that they were multitasking
right so they're doing some setting and
they're doing some lead nurture and that
gets really hard for a team of six guys
to split those things we took one of the
Setters who was really good and made
that person the lead nurture specialist
who basically acted as the bridge for
both the setting team and the closing
team to basically coordinate and remind
the people of their appointments and we
equipped that lead nurture specialist
with one of our checklists for what that
role needs to do to get the most people
to show up and I'm not going to give you
all because of the long checklist I'll
give you two quick examples one of them
is doing a three-way intro once you have
the set appointment between the setter
and the closer and doing it via iPhone
if you can because now you have a known
person and an unknown person and a
person that Bridges the two they might
know show on Johnny over here but not on
the guy that they just spoke with and so
the idea is how can I bridge that Gap
and kind of make the association for
them add some trust the other thing is
that the closers mning of would remind
them with either a voice memo or a video
text personalized to them being like hey
John really excited for our apointment
today I saw your profile XYZ
personalized to you really pumped for
you I think we might help you out so
that's just a couple of the things that
we have on that list that we had them
Implement and all do consistently and
sales team fix number five boom is we
optimize the sales scripts I said
earlier that the discovery was to
surface level so we rescripted the
discovery made sure we were asking
deeper more meaningful questions and a
part of that is also bringing some of
the objections to the front it's much
easier and this is the this is the
terminology that our team uses which is
killing zombies right it's a lot easier
to kill a zombies when it's far away
than when it's on top of you if
somebody's trying to bring up a zombie
in the clothes another way of saying it
is like you want to diffuse the bomb
before it goes off in the clothes in
your face so we solve the problem before
we bring it up now this is actually
something that we added to this part of
the script which is prior to the
appointment we say hey is there anyone
else who'd be required to make a
decision about this thing if they say
yes then you say cool well let's push
back the appointment and let's get that
person on that way you have all the
decision makers present so these are
just little things but like little 1%
improvements over and over over again is
what yield these 50% boosts and the
third main change we did was that we
drilled the team on looping and looping
is just a sales terminology for
basically when you encounter an
objection handling the objection and
then asking again handle the objection
ask again right because a lot of sales
people are afraid to ask if someone says
no and they don't want to ask again
right and I can tell you this is that
the number of sales you make is direct
proportional to how many times you ask
there's ways to do it wrong and there's
ways to do it right the idea is that you
should be able to resolve the concern
right so if someone says I need to think
about it and you say well what are you
your main concerns and they say well it
seems really complicated you say oh what
part specifically feels more complicated
they're like it's the whole Tech thing
and we're like oh we also have a vendor
that can actually fill that in I think
it's a couple bucks extra but like we
can just handle that for you does that
solve the problem and they're like oh
okay so you guys you guys will just
handed that one part of it like yeah
we'll handed that part of it for you
cool now this is where the salesman says
great you want to move forward you have
your idea on you hey what C you like you
can just make the ask right after that
and so then at that point you might say
ready to move forward then and they
might say this feels like a fast
decision it's like oh well what makes it
fast how long you been thinking about
this they're like well I mean I just met
you and you say well how long have you
wanted to solve this problem and then
they would say well I mean a long time
it's like well that doesn't sound like a
fast decision at all it sounds like
you've already made the decision a long
time ago that you wanted to change now
we're just acting on it so now do you
want to move forward right keep looping
and continuing to resolve the concern
ask again resolve the concern ask again
drum roll
please what happened in the real world
so let's go to the data all right so in
our first column we had 49% show rates
after we implemented sales fix 2 fixing
the ad targeting sales Fix 4 promoted
one lead Setter to lead nurture
specialist and sales fix 3 reduced the
team size and reset expectations survey
says we had a 70% boost which is almost
exactly the kpi and that's because when
you do things that work they work so
that was a 40% Improvement in sales and
to be clear this was just over 2 months
all right so some of these changes going
to happen real quick if you know what
you're doing the second change we have
is our offer rate and so here's what
happened so survey
says 80% we actually offered just about
the same amount of people realistically
what they were doing is offering people
who weren't qualified cuz the sales team
wanted to eat I get that like there's a
human component here they were offering
people were not qualified the deal cuz
they needed commissions right which is
what we were trying to fix with the
targeting close rates we went from 27%
and 60 days later we were
at 41% so 1% above our Benchmark all
right this is a 50% Improvement in sales
so 40 and 50 Kazam next up we have
percentage of cash collected a really
good metric for knowing how strong the
sales team in is and this is especially
important for that early Discovery
portion and how good they are at looping
and closing because the deeper you get
the discovery the the more convicted the
buyer will be about the solution and the
more likely they are to pay up FR as a
measure of their conviction in the
solution the survey says we went from 47
to 82% so we almost doubled the amount
of cash that we were collecting up front
per sale in 60 days we had a 40%
Improvement and we had a 50% Improv and
we had a almost doubling of cash
collected so if we almost doubled the
amount of sales that happened and we
almost doubled the cash upfront
collected what did we do to the cash FL
the business Forex ah much more enticing
after we added all these four changes
together and we waited 60 days what
happened survey says we went from 56 to
93 sales a month and that was just from
a few of these fixes on one particular
part of the organization I taught 116
sales Prof professionals my closing
framework and after implementing it they
increased how much they closed enjoy um
Alex Becker who's the who's the founder
of that uh clued me in recently to
something he's like dude your your your
rowes is insane because he can see
everyone's revenue and their ad Spin and
I was like what do you mean he's like
you have the highest return on ad spend
of everyone in the entire platform by
like a mile and I didn't really ever
think about it but our lifetime return
on Advertising is 36
to1 so to do over you know hund now you
know five or 10 million whatever we're
at now um we've spent just under $3
million in advertising and so there's a
lot of other pieces to you know making
more but just for everyone on this call
we're talking specifically about sales
correct yeah so so Alex yeah yeah 99% of
these guys are are
closers and they're getting closing
positions a couple people are sorting
like a closer agency where they partner
up with a guy like you and they're like
hey let's do like a little JB deal I
slam your deals okay sweet well then why
don't I so what I'm going to do is
because I do have a presentation um
which is just how I think about sales um
and I have the the third part of the
presentation about scaling sales teams
does anyone here have multiple closers
who work for them or is is most people
just closing on your own right
now you guys got to talk with Alex he
don't bite I also can't see I can't see
the chat I can't see the chat
we're working towards that
Alex okay so how about this I'll give
you the things that so um Russell when I
first met him was like dude how did you
learn how to sell so well and it was
because I looked at my CRM and I'd done
4,000 sales one-on-one uh in Fitness and
so that's a lot of reps you know I was
taking 20 consults a day for like four
years and so that's in person face to
face my team would double or triple book
me every 30 minutes and I just sold the
same thing over and over again and
because I was really good at sales I
ended up not hiring a ton of salese and
I would actually have my manager set
appointments for me all at one location
so I had six gyms and so I would go
there they'd stack up an entire day I'd
mow down a whole day go to a different
gym and they'd been stacking all the
appointments and I'd mow down and so
usually I do 20 to 25 consults a day and
you just get you you know you just get
these reps in of reading people gauging
tonality and seeing where you need to
lean in and where you need to lean back
and so um you know over time I've then
started training sales people and sales
managers I had a remote sales team we F
we'd fly out and do turnarounds um like
in person so I had eight guys we'd fly
out to eight facilities every month and
we turn these facilities around because
I know Mike you were in the Fitness
World before this um that's right and
then I brought that sales team in-house
and they started doing phone sales for
high ticket so I've had um I've had
in-person phone High ticket low ticket
we've kind of done a lot of those things
I trained mortgage leads teams um so
kind of the whole Gambit and there's
definitely some things that I've seen
you know I've bought every sales product
on the market I bought Grant stuff
bought bord stuff um and I think there's
a lot of Merit and there's a lot of good
stuff out there but in my experience uh
Simplicity is what scales and so I'll
give you if you're okay with it I'll
give you the few things that I have
implemented consistently within my
companies that have generated outsize
returns is that cool all right awesome
what I'm Gonna Roll let get all right
full Jam so as I said Simplicity right
I'm a the world's best graphic designer
uh as you can see here so I'm trying to
uh show the the real Keys of the Kingdom
so everybody here everybody here selling
expensive stuff is that most people on
this call yes everything's High Alex
fantastic all right everyone still see
me and the screen yep all right Rock and
Roll All right so I'm guessing this guys
isn't your first rodeo um not your first
presentation with the sexy headliner big
promise and so if you have failed for
you guys to uh grow your thing in the
past I promise you it's not your fault
lots of information very confusing um
and you can sometimes be inundated with
lots of different sales people's
information you've got Mike here who's a
who's a gem and knows his [__] and you
guys are lucky to have him um but in
hopefully in this presentation I will
put some of those fears to rest of like
what if I'm never what if I never make
it what if I never turn this corner um
and become the salesp person I want what
if I never hit the 100 100 Grand a year
what if I never hit the 100 Grand a
month or whatever don't hit the million
a month goal that I have and then what
does that what does that mean about me
right if you've ever thought those
things um like I can tell you I did two
um right after the instance that I had
uh mic with that individual um and that
individual drained my entire bank
account and then sent it to their
girlfriend in Sweden and then filed
bankruptcy after that happened I had
$1,200 because I had sold all my gyms
and put my money into that account so I
started at zero which I'm very grateful
for because it gave me the experience
that I have now and so what I'm going to
show you is that you can have a simple
sales process that can yield outsid
returns a lot of people like to make
this fancy because it makes it easier to
sell stuff to people about selling but
these are the things that I have seen
that have unlocked the growth for us
because I don't think I'm the best
marketer out there I think we've simply
attached a phone to a funnel um and
we've been very efficient at it and so
as a result of that I've always been
able to make more per customer than
anyone else because of how efficient we
are at the conversion process all right
and so that's what we're here for so I
want to show you exactly step by step
our process for selling all right and so
there should be two types of people here
some of you guys who are under $100,000
a month and I'll show you how to never
compete on price again all right and if
you guys are over $100,000 a month I'll
show you exactly what we did to scale a
team to get to a million a month and
Beyond is that cool yes because if
you're under a 100 it's just you right
if you're over a 100 you need people all
right so it's GNA kind of be like the
actual sing itself and then the scaling
of the sales all right so that's kind of
the goal for the 60 minutes I'll
probably be able to get it done in 40ish
I'll talk fast so we can have some time
all right everyone can just listen fast
is that all right all right
I'm
it so I've been really fortunate um yeah
now we're at 105 or 110 or whatever it
is um in in selling stuff which has been
cool what's been coolers we've been able
to donate to causes you guys don't know
my story but um I had a I had a gym
teacher after school who stayed with me
he didn't have to he didn't know me from
anybody and he worked out with me for an
entire year and taught me how to work
out because I was like a really insecure
kid and as a result of that I got into
fitness and so I feel like it's all of
our opportunity because you guys are on
here like we're already in the top 1% in
the world you know what I mean like
we're bitching about not making a 100
Grand a month like [__] you you know
what I mean like really and so um it's
been a great privilege to be able to
give back you we've donated 1.4 million
just in the last three years actually
1.7 now I have to update that um but
anyways just the causes that we that we
care about and so for us it's it's kids
being able to have the opportunity that
we had all right and uh if you guys are
in the fitness industry Arnold was my
hero is the reason I quit my job um and
I've been able to you know grow a
friendship with him which is been
awesome um and we've had you know over a
thousand clients hit $100,000 a year
using the sales framework I'm going to
show you all right so like you can
imagine that these people are not maybe
as good as you are you can imagine that
somebody in that thousand is probably
not as naturally talented right so the
process works okay and we've got a lot
of people over seven figures now um but
it wasn't that way right so this is me
when I started my first gym I slept on
the floor I had $5,000 total my rent was
$5,000 um and so I had one month that I
had to learn how to make money
and uh I built a funnel because I
learned this from the internet and I was
actually I sent this picture to my dad
because I was so excited I was so proud
of this picture because I sold that many
people in the first in the first two
weeks uh for
free um and things started to grow right
I my that was my one of my gyms I had
nine employees I felt like a badass you
know my dad finally told me he thought I
you know wasn't a schmuck for you know
being an idiot and getting into fitness
so I thought I felt like I was figuring
things out and then all of a sudden
Facebook slap happened this is years ago
and there's been many slaps Facebook
just kind of kind of has its it its
[__] hand proverbially swinging back
and forth but um you know we got slapped
and overnight my my lead cost went up 5x
right and so my my money my moneymaking
rain turned into a desert and the thing
was my marketing was losing money every
day and all I could think about was
letting my dad down and more
realistically having my dad be right I'm
gonna I'm gonna all right cool um and so
the question that I asked myself was
like how can I afford to get more leads
right and so I called on my friends up
and he had a he was a brick and mortar
gym owner and he told me that things
were going great for him and I was like
what the hell dude what are you what are
you doing he was like dude we just we
just attached the phone to the funnel
and I was like no [__] he's like we're
selling expensive stuff on the front end
now instead of selling trials I was like
well that's cool I'll do that and so we
went from losing two and a half two to
one to making 10 to one return on the
front end right and what that meant for
my business is I went from being able to
break even at $10 a lead to being able
to spend up A1 $100 a lead and still
make money which is crazy right and so
then things started to grow again for me
and then we you know open location after
location and things grow and I met this
guy and uh I was I was I met I joined
his Mastermind I was trying to I told
him I wanted to create a nationwide gym
gym chain and he said uh you should
teach other people how you do what you
do and not grow that chain and I was
like well you make more money than me so
okay I'll listen and so then I started
making uh our doing our Marketing System
Mike this is by the way at that guy's
gym um did 191 signups in 19 days and
that was the stack of contracts um some
of you guys may have seen this it was
like the most run ad for like a year and
a half
um but we did I know $100,000 in in 19
days in sales like in the ghetto all
right so these are the three Frameworks
sorry I sped through that because we
already covered a little bit of my story
early so I wanted to get through it um
and these are the free Frameworks that I
kind of discovered um to scale High
ticket all right and it'll take if you
if you're if you're partnering some with
someone then it'll help take their
losing funnels and turn them into into
cash machines and I mean that genuinely
all right so the free three Frameworks
that I do is one is the closure
framework all right these are the
questions that get prospects to say yes
all right and so adding this to any kind
of any funnel process is going to
instantly make it more profitable all
right and I'm going to walk through the
questions that we ask and specifically
what only three things that you can say
on a sales call period it's the number
one mistake that all the sales guys that
even my guys make and I have to remind
them up all right the second thing is
the conviction framework so anyone who
believes can outperform a seasoned sales
rep by simply learning control their
tone all right so some of you guys right
now can I get a hand um I'm gonna
unshare my screen real quick can I get
hands on the screen of who here is newer
to this newer to high ticket sales okay
great great perfect then this is for you
I'm going to show you how you can beat
the best sales reps all right and this
is how I never ever hire seasoned
closers just FYI no no mik we're goodna
TR trading salese I
don't um but I'm gonna show you how you
can beat seasoned prep seasoned Pros all
right which if I can find my
presentation there we go um by learning
control your tone and the last one is
scaling so for all you guys who are over
$100,000 a month and need to scale a
team I'm going to show you how to
duplicate the skill in other people all
right because it's one level of the
skill is learning to sell another level
of the skill is teaching to sell and
it's a more valuable skill so if you can
duplicate your skill in someone else
that is how you can make 10 times 100
times more money because it's no longer
you're no longer constrained by your
time all right so let's rock and roll
close your framework so after pouring
over like hundreds of scripts like I
mean it hundreds of scripts um I
realized that there was always like
these minor in wording but if I hit
these kind of main Milestones along the
way I ended up closing the sale right
and the nice thing is that this process
works for B Toc and B2B so I don't know
what stuff you're selling but it works
for both and it worked for $500 tickets
as much as $100,000 tickets the process
is the same right and the way I teach my
sales teams and now thousands of clients
is This Acronym right and like even when
I'm thinking through sales calls we use
we like closer C right l so the C is
clarify why the person is on the phone
with you right that's the the objective
why are you here why' you take the time
to take the call what's the problem
right what are we trying to solve here
after that then we're like got it so
what I'm hearing is you're struggling
with this does that sound about right
I'm going to label you with a problem
after that we overview their past pain
it's like okay so you have this problem
I can't be the first person you've
talked to about this tell me a little
bit about what you've done so far to try
to try and get past this right tell me
more about that how'd that work out for
you okay understood after that it's like
okay so hearing all these things this is
why you're here this is what you're
trying to get this is what you've tried
and hasn't worked okay well can I tell
you about how I think we might be able
to solve your problem this is where we
sell the vacation right and then finally
or step before finally we explain away
their concerned so this is where we tell
them about the program and then we're
like do you want to do it they say yes
or no if they say no then we explain
away their concerns so they say yes and
then once they say yes we reinforce the
decision and this last R here is a point
that I added years later because we
realize that
the sale the sale just continues
throughout the entire customer
relationship right and so for you guys
if you're dealing with clients uh who
you're selling for you have to also sell
them on continuously selling right you
might have closed the card or closed the
first payment but they're onboarding
experience they got to close them again
and then after that when they have their
first week check-in call they got to get
closed again because we have to
consistently sell them on why they
should do anything why should they not
just watch Netflix why should they why
should they take action why should they
have the discomfort of getting you know
smacked on the phone by a stranger right
why should they why should they feel the
The Sting of failure we have to sell
them consistently to help them overcome
their pains right and so I'll show you
each some of these more closely so
clarifying why they're there right it's
like what made you come in today what
made you reach out what's your goal
right now why is that important to you
right okay helping me understand what
what you what are we doing here right
this is one where someone in the
beginning like you have to hit this
because if someone says like you I just
wanted to find out more information
you're like cool but why like what did
you want the information to solve what
was the like I'm sure you don't just go
around collecting information all day
right like there's something you're
trying to get out of this what's the
problem and then and then you get what
you need you're like got it okay so just
so I'm hearing you right it sounds like
this is your goal correct then they
acknowledge they have a problem this is
important because they have to say it
they have to own it I can't cure cancer
until you admit that you have it right
we got to give it to you before we can
cure it after that we overview the past
right so it's like what have you tried
so far to accomplish this how long did
you do it for how long long ago how did
that work for you what else have you
tried we call this the pain cycle right
we consistently do this over and over
again until we've exhausted all options
right at that point we have tons of ammo
that we can use later in the clo which
I'm sure you're aware of right and the
big piece here is we explain how it's
not their fault because if they had this
missing piece or two of the equation
they were halfway there they were three4
the way there they were just missing
this one piece which we're going to
provide for them right and the nice
thing is is for most of you hopefully
you're selling a a holistic solution
right so for example I'm G to use a
fitness example because Mike's from from
that background too if someone came in
and said they tried workouts in the past
I'm be like I'm not telling you don't
that you don't need to workout it's
great but you also need the nutrition
and the accountability right you need
nutrition to make sure they stop eating
[__] because if you just start working
out eating Donuts it's not going to work
right of course now if I make you the
best plan in the world but you don't
follow it's not going to work either
that's why you need the accountability
and that's what I'm here for and so from
that point that's kind of how you can
naturally transition so it's like I'm
hearing these things this is what you're
missing well do you want to hear how the
program works because I think we might
be able to solve that for you they'll
say yes all so what we've seen is that
there's three things that make clients
successful right and at this point this
is my belief is that three things has
been you know unequivocal and most
pitches is that I think it's human brain
is that you can't take more than three
but typically it's like three pillars to
the to the stool or three you know
finish and accountability if I was
selling leads I'd want them to be you
know timely uh you know qualified and
you know uh exclusive right there'll be
three elements to make what makes a good
lead right there's there's always three
that you can usually find when you're
selling a solution and most times not
most times every time if you're on the
phone with the prospect you always have
the upper hand because they have
admitted at the beginning of this phone
call that they have a problem they have
not solved it and so inherently they're
going to be missing one of the keys they
cannot have them all or they would not
be on the phone so you have a you you
you are in in an unlosable situation
unless you choose to lose it right
unless you choose to lose the frame and
so in this instance it has been my
experience that we use stories short
short anecdotal stories to to to break
the belief of the prospect around a
topic what's important here is that we
don't get into uh jargon right we don't
get into technobabble and talking about
the program and the modules and the the
things they're going to do because all
of that sounds like work and that's not
what they're there for they're there for
a result right and so instead I would
say something like with the Fitness
Nutrition accountability like I said
earlier so if I was trying to explain
accountability be like listen you don't
have accountability when you were a kid
you ever like have your parents tell you
to brush your teeth they were like yeah
like you know how you're like I don't
want to I don't want to and they would
tell you oh no you got to go brush your
teeth and and you go and you brush your
teeth and you Sul back to bed and next
night you do the same thing they tell
you brush your teeth you go brush your
teeth go back to bed but you're an adult
now right you brush your teeth they're
like yeah and that's because you had
external accountability that turned into
an internal habit right and that's what
we're going to do for you here right so
I didn't tell them about [__] the
coaching call that they're going to have
and the post that they're going to have
and the blah blah blah we told them as
the result of that we gave them an
anecdotal story that made sense to them
for that's probably a really key point I
just want to drive home ear out when you
have your pitch part it shouldn't be
longer than three minutes like tops
because no one really gives a [__] and
at the end of the day the reason they're
going to buy is going to be because of
how understood they
feel so how much when you went through
that overview of the pain you were able
to restate back to them accurately
exactly how they felt felt and the
struggles they are experiencing which is
why you need to shut the [__] up when
they're talking right and so there's
only three things that are ever said on
a sales call do you guys know what they
are there's only three things that ever
come out of your
mouth
questions
restatements and anecdotal stories which
is the story that I just referenced the
three stories that you will use to break
a belief that's it so this so that's how
you sell them the vacation you have
these little sound bites right I'll give
you another example so if I was doing um
if I was doing food right I'm like
listen uh three parts of the program
Fitness accountability so nutrition wise
you've got to eat stuff that's going to
make you lose weight can we agree on
that yes okay cool but the problem is
you don't want to do that right that's
where we're here right right okay so let
me ask you a question when uh do you
feel like what's your favorite TV show
they're going to be like
uh whatever Game of Thrones you're like
okay Game of Thrones do you feel like
you need to get like motivated to watch
came through like man I was trying to
watch it tonight but I just couldn't you
know I just I just I got really busy and
I just couldn't sit down on the couch
and turn the TV on I couldn't do it
right of course not because you look
forward to it because you wanted to do
it and the key that we're going to do
here is we're going to get you to look
forward to the foods that you're eating
because if you look forward to it you
don't need to be motivated because you
do it on your own because you like it
does that make sense right so what I
didn't talk about the macros and the
carb cycling and the intermittent
fasting and the calorie counting and the
blah blah blah blah blah because the end
of the day that does not matter what
they want is for them to solve the
problem and have it be painfree right
and that's what we're explaining to them
so that's selling the vacation right and
this is a saying that I've used for a
long time which is sell the vacation not
the plane fright right and so this is
what everyone else talks about they're
like sir for us to get you these results
you're going to have to take your pants
off you're goingon to have to jump
through this Loop you're gonna have to
go through the TSA the airport lines
pack your suitcases take your shoes off
do the layovers connect your flights uh
have a person farting next to you don't
worry they don't have covid you'll have
turbulence probably on the plane then as
soon as you're out you think you're done
you still have to wait a baggage CLA
they probably lost your bag right and in
our world it's your modules your MPL
your Macros your workouts your support
team your URLs your domains your funnels
your targeting your ads and the other
[__] that doesn't matter right but
instead what they want is you sell Maui
Final Destination and you always sell
the same thing because the difference is
only the level of service and how they
want to get there right if you have
multiple levels of service so do they
want to swim to Maui to where they're
trying to go there's sharks and you
could drown or get robbed right this
chick crazy uh do they want to take a
boat to Maui it'll take a little longer
but there's no shark attacks but there's
still no Wi-Fi and you're kind of you
know in the sun uh do you want to take a
normal flight to Maui get there a little
faster still smells bad has security bad
food but you're going to get there or do
you want to take a private jet to Maui
right direct non-stop champagne on the
plane suitcase is packed when you arrive
right and so that's the selling piece e
is explaining way they concerns and so
these are the questions that sound like
um so there's I'm sure Mike has already
taught you a lot of the uh the obstacle
overcome Concepts right so fundamentally
there's there's three big ones right
price and rather than teach you like the
uh the the the drilling of the obstacles
I told you there's two things you need
to memorize one of them are the stories
the second are the obstacle overcomes
all right because those are the things
that you're in the Red Zone like that's
not where you start thinking about what
you're going to say all right so the two
things that you need to memorize as a
salesperson are the stories about what
you
sell and the obstacles that you're going
to encounter when you're in the red zone
the questions on the front end you need
to know the Milestones you need to hit
in order to move forward and this is one
of the big mistakes I'm sure Mike talks
about a lot which is you need to sit in
the pain if someone does not clarify why
they need a solution you do not ask for
the sale if they're if we just say hey
you know what what brought you to here
today I just want to find out more
information Okay cool so you know let me
tell you about the program like that's
not we didn't get the [__] like we
don't know why they're there we don't
know what their goals are like one of
the things drives me nuts about my team
sometimes is I'm like dude we're eight
minutes in the conversation I was like I
don't know how many clients they have I
don't know what their revenue is I don't
know what their profit is I don't know
what their biggest pain and struggle was
right now I'm like what are you doing
I'm like you just told them they're like
oh Jim is $100 million doll company I'm
like they don't give a [__] but they do
my sales guys because they get their OS
puffed up right but it has nothing to do
with the prospect they do not care right
they only care about them so right
that's right yeah that's the issue right
everyone talks way too much about the
product and so when you're training
sales people you don't train them on the
product you train them on the
prospect the product doesn't matter I
mean it matters obviously from like how
you're going to make money because you
have to do a good job because I'm going
to get that in the second point but in
terms of when you are selling and
training someone if you guys know
someone or know a specific Niche really
well then you will know their pains and
if you have a new salesperson you hear
them say [__] and you're like that's not
what he thinks what is's he doing he
might know the product perfectly but he
just said that the guy's problem was not
the problem and so then it doesn't
matter what the product is because he
doesn't feel like it's for him even
though it's totally for him but you just
misarticulated the problem that's where
the clarity has to happen if you nail
that the rest of the pitch is easy all
right and so the key here is relying on
past agreements that have already been
made so this person with their partner
with their spouse with their B you know
whatever has that person knows that
there's a problem and they also don't
approve of that problem and so why would
they be in any way against remedying a
problem that they already don't approve
of right and then finally we always tack
on sometimes it's better ask for
forgiveness than permission right ha
depends on the ticket sale right but you
can get those in right and then
obviously last last case here is you
just do a delayed close and say let's
get your car down we can put it down
payment we can pay the rest on Friday
and if between now and then you know
your partner comes back and says no man
I want to be poor I want to keep
struggling and like I want to never make
money and like continue to do this for
the rest of our lives then I'll
absolutely tear up the contract don't
worry about it
right finally you've got stalls right I
need to think about it so these are
because people don't people are afraid
of making mistakes right people are
afraid of making mistakes and because of
that they don't like making decisions
because it's easier to let life make the
decision for you and so they like doing
it that way because then they feel like
it's not their fault right and so I mean
a great obstacle over for this is what's
your main concern which is usually my
number one thing I go to when someone's
like I need to think about it it's like
totally what's your main concern right
let's think about it together right and
so fundamentally these are the things
that they need to know do you feel like
what we're doing can meet your needs and
solve the problem yes or no yes do you
want to work with us as a company do you
like our values do you like what we
stand for do you believe what we believe
about the world yes do you have access
to funds or know someone who does yes
well then let's rock and roll because
those are the only things we know to me
the B decision right do you like the
product do you like us and do you have
the money to do it that's it simple as
that right and so when we walk through
those if you encounter these situations
obviously there's you know if you're
going to do it now sooner or later you
might as well like there's plenty of
things to say but I think it's more
important to understand the theory
behind why someone has this objection
right they have an objection around
price because they don't see the value
because you didn't articulate it they
have an objection around decision maker
usually because you [__] something up
earlier in the sale but at this point
you're in the red zone so you got to
deal with it so you rely on pasted
agreements if they come with a stall
then you help them confront a decision
and make a logical choice and teach them
how to make a decision that in that
moment you say what are you most afraid
of happening I'm afraid of you just
you're afraid of me taking the money
right just taking your money and you
getting nothing right again well let me
tell you how that's not going to happen
right you can bring their concerns all
right and then finally they say yes and
you're like awesome and this is where if
you're selling for someone else get them
to send a personalized video like hey
Johnny saw you just signed up with us
today super pumped to have you uh you're
going to be meeting with Heather
tomorrow she's going to get you kicked
off um you should in the mail get a
special gift so keep lookout for that
and then uh you know send a handwritten
card if someone just bought a really
expensive thing people are making their
decision about whether they believe in
you as a company within the first 48
hours after the sale they make a
decision of whether or not they're going
to be with you in the long term and how
they are treated in the first 48 hours
after they give you money so it's
critical and it's usually in that point
that people [__] up and just ignore them
framework two and you know Mike I can
stop I'll just do framework two and then
we can do the Q&A because if I don't
have time to scale the sales teams I can
hit on the points later um so this is a
big one for everyone who is who's newer
to sales all right if you
believe you can outperform to season
sales rep by learning control your tone
all right and so I reworked all of our
scripts into the closer framework and
the thing is is immediately some people
were crushing it right While others were
still not selling [__] and I was like
what the [__] right and so I talked to
my friends and they were like dude you
should read this book by Jordan buffer
and the big biggest thing that I got
from the book was just he was very
specific about tonality and that was a
big shift for me in just learning to
teach how to ask the question not just
asking the question right and
so in the book he talks about having the
same issue that I had with scaling sales
it's like I give the script to two guys
some guy crushes some guy doesn't I'm
like what the [__] right and the thing
is there's a hidden dialogue that the
sales team does not know that they are
talking in right and so the words are
not going to be enough all right they're
just literally 10% so the words that you
have it might be the most tested script
in the world it's still only 10% 90% is
how you say the words right because how
you say what you say is tonality like
right now I could give everyone here you
know Jerry Seinfeld standup script you
could read it it wouldn't be funny right
because it's not just that you had the
script it's how you deliver it right and
that takes time to develop right and
that's kind of unconscious Mastery and
so there's two ways to do this all right
that I have found you can either trick
yourself into it or you can train
yourself to do it all right and since we
don't have enough time to uh to train on
the influence of tonalities here's the
trick that I teach all right conviction
will correct your
tone conviction made real so um let me
tell you this story so I was I was
brought in to do a day of Consulting for
this mortgage leads company to train
their sales team and the first half of
the day I reworked the whole script I
put the closure framework made it a
question based um sale and then I came
in and they were expecting me to like
rain you know fire and brimstone on
these guys and so I sat down I was like
who's the guy having the most trouble it
was this guy John so I was like John and
they were still on the leads I was like
John how good are the leads he was like
well you know and I was like we're good
thanks and I was like let me show you
how you would answer it if you actually
believed that the leads were good I was
like you say like dude these leads are
[__] unbelievable right now I'm
studying for my real estate exam so I
can get in on these leads my aunt is
real her and she has more business she
can handle and I'm sending her traffic
I'm trying to get my my my brother to do
it with me I'm not sure how long I'm in
a worker because these leads are killing
it for us
right if you believe in the product you
don't need to have all the sales skills
you'll do it the right way because
you'll actually want to help the person
so that's why the most important part of
the sale is the product Because unless
you're a malicious
person like most people here was
everyone here have some level of ethics
on some level like no near just wants to
like take someone's last dollar right so
then the only way to sell hard because
if you're going to close you got to sell
hard the only way to sell hard is to
believe through and through balls to
bones when you look at yourself in the
mirror at night this is what I talked
about when Mike said at the very
beginning like what happens when people
start hating on you the only way that
I've been able to stay where we're at in
the gym industry Mike knows the amount
of hate that I get right the only way
we've been able to do that is that I
read the
testimonials the thousand of them that I
have of Jim who have gone to six figures
of the hundred gyms we've taken to seven
figures right like I know beyond a
shadow of a doubt that our product works
I also know that if you sign up for a
gym not everyone loses weight and I'm
willing to deal with that I I'm willing
to give everyone the opportunity to
change their life so here's the tactics
around this reread testimonials out loud
daily in front of your sales team all
right and if the business that you're
working for doesn't have testimonials
find another business all right I'm
serious you're not going to be able to
close unless you're like literally
unless you're unethical you're not going
to be able to close so go find something
that is a good product because there's
plenty of them out there all right find
a good product that you believe in you
just see tons of testimonials and then
read those every day in front of the
team all right second well this is for
the business owners but fix everything
you possibly can about the product all
right and never blame a customer for
lack of success so as much as there are
people who have not been successful
who've used gym launch I still take the
fact that they were not successful and I
think what could I have done that would
have made the next person like them
successful and you plug the hole right
if you do that over and over and over
and over again you know truly at the end
of the day when you look at yourself in
the mirror when no one else is watching
whether or not you truly put the effort
forth that merits the price that you are
charging right and only you can know
that and the thing is is like the reason
salese get beat up is because they don't
put the work in and then it grates on
their soul and then eventually they burn
out they burn out not because they can't
handle no but because they can't handle
how they feel about
themselves right and so you have to put
the work in to have the conviction
because that's what's going to get you
through it if you've ever met someone
who's a born again Christian all right
they are convicted they do not care how
many people tell them to shove it
because they are trying to save people's
Souls it's real like if you let that hit
you it's real you know what I mean and
if you can be a disciple of whatever the
product you have an evangelist in the
truest terms then all the scripting
stuff it won't matter why are some of
the best sales people clients who had
success because they believe in it
that's it and the most convicted person
will always win the fight right they'll
always lead the dance because they have
conviction in their skepticism you have
conviction in your product and one of
you is going to win out right and it's
the question is whose belief is stronger
because belief isn't binary it's not do
I believe or do I not believe it's how
much do I believe to what extent do I
believe would I bet $1,000 on this
product would I bet $10,000 on this
product would I sell my mother this
product think about it if you would sell
your mother this product how convicted
are
you probably very and you will have no
problem closing deals and notice that I
have a lower tone right now so that you
listen to the words that I'm saying so
you think that they're
important in terms of uh the training
schedule 60 minutes a day 5 days a week
my guys do world class sales training
they text me in the morning before they
wake up they text me once they're done
uh they do the first 25 minutes they
read the script out loud five minutes
they drill obstacles I need to think
about it I need to talk to my partner um
this is expensive and then they talk
they they drill the second half right as
a closer you got to talk you got to
listen you got to train both skills
right the talking is the tone and saying
the words the right way in the right
sequence without having to think about
it the listening is going over recording
and figure out what went right what went
wrong and what we're going to do next
time and saying it drilling it as a team
marking it and moving to the next one
that's the short answer we 10x the
recurring Revenue in one of my portfolio
companies by using what we call the
diagnostic sale there are seven steps
that you can use to follow the script
and apply it to your business enjoy I
cross $100 million in net worth by age
32 I sold my first big company for 46.2
million and the reason we're able to do
that is because we know how to grow
companies and so now I buy companies at
a lower price I grow them and then we
sell them and so I want to talk to you
about one of the companies we just
bought uh we bought them a year and a
half ago I think or a year ago uh they
had 14 locations so it was a chain of
brick and mortar and since then we've
gone from 14 to 32 locations and the
reason we're able to do that is because
we focused on the sales process and
through a process that I want to walk
you through something that I call the
diagnostic sale we're able to 10x the
recurring revenue of the business across
all the locations so before we get into
the nitty-gritty of the story let me
just walk you through the steps in the
diagnostic process first is we like to
have some sort of pre-sale questionnaire
which the purpose of that is to get get
more information that arms the
salesperson so they know who they're
talking to what their pains are but from
the sales perspective for them they also
increase their awareness of the problem
second is we get their information in
their credit card which is key and I'll
explain why it later uh third is we want
to understand what their current
situation is where are you at today then
we have your desired state so where
would you like to be at and then what's
the obstacle why aren't you there and
then finally once we have these big
three we present the desired State and
our vehicle to overcome the obstacle and
we tie our price to the way we're going
to get them there and then finally we
give them an incentive to prepay so
here's the five steps that we follow to
actually get this done so number one is
that we secret
shopped the business so we actually
looked into it we went there by the way
you should secret shop your own business
highly recommend doing it you'll be
horrified by what you hear your sales
guys say you're like I thought we had a
script what are you even doing number
two is from there this is basically
information gathering we figure out what
the constraint is okay where do we think
there's big opportunities in the
business now you should think about
yourself as your own business consultant
if you could buy your business today and
look at your business what would be the
no duh thing that you would do now for
this particular business we thought that
they had an offer constraint which
really came down to packaging we had
offer slash packaging because
fundamentally we're not going to change
the core of the business we're not going
to all of a sudden start selling soap
when you sell HVAC like that's not going
to happen right so the core of the
business can remain unchanged it's how
we're going to package the services we
deliver or that the services we sell to
a customer how are we're goingon to get
them to perceive what we're selling we
gathered the data we figured out the
constraint was that they should get way
more re-bookings which I thought was an
offer and packaging issue which is we
need to sell the solutions sell the goal
and so number four is okay if we assume
that we're going to make this new
transition to this new new offer new
packaging we have to anticipate so you
we call it killing zombies uh which is
one way of putting it you anticipate the
obstacles or objections that people are
going to throw at you ahead of time
write this in neon marker above your
sales team which is it's way harder to
get someone to buy buy after you
presented the price because now they're
like he's trying to sell me so we have
to counter that before we become
salespeople in their mind we are a
trusted expert ideally if we're
positioned well and you should be that
way if you know what you're talking
about and I like to use the frame of
childlike curiosity I always tilt my
head I probably even did it
subconsciously just now you tilt your
head when you ask the question because
it's non-threatening you're like huh
that's weird what changed between then
and now just so I understand then they
can tell you rather than be like you
said that your husband said supports you
you can't say that now you have to buy
doesn't work that way if you win the
argument in a sale you lose the sale the
only way that you win the sale is being
willing to lose being right and so the
fifth step and this is the ongoing step
is that you implement the diagnostic
sales process so it's implementation so
now that I just outlined the five steps
let me deep dive into the implementation
into the actual business and how it did
this with this particular business when
we bought them I spent 4 hours with our
director of sales and we outlined the
new sales process we wanted to implement
and as soon as we implemented that sales
process we 4X LTV progression meaning
how much people paid us it went from 200
to 800 so really big jump and we the
crazy thing about this is that we didn't
change what we delivered we only changed
how we presented it and so this is the
key of how we create value how we scale
companies how we grow companies and many
companies keep these things as Secrets
uh as their special sauce and I just
fundamentally believe that that the more
we put out the more we get back and so
that's why I operate this way all right
so I will hold nothing back and this is
something I call the diagnostic sales
process now to be very clear the
diagnostic sales process is one of two
different sales or maybe three different
sales processes big picture that you can
have in a business one is a
transactional sale all the way on this
extreme so on one side you've got
transactional
sales and on this side you've got
Enterprise sales which is like
uh relational sales like if you think
about like you're selling some big
Fortune 500 company you have to get
stakeholders involved get budget
approval there's all that stuff and on
transactional side you've got like High
Velocity sales we're talking 20 30
minute sales a guy who stands in of the
car wash sells Car Wash somebody sells
gym memberships transactional and then
you've kind of got like this Middle
where you might sell something that's a
little bit higher ticket but it's a
little bit more custom all right now
what we did was I took their sale from
here a purely transactional sale and
moved it towards custom
all right now in a transactional sale
you typically fit the customer to the
product and so let's say that I sell
pens all right so I sell pens if
somebody comes in I'm going to basically
spend all my effort listening to what
they say they want and then telling them
how this pen fits their needs or I have
to basically say your needs are wrong
let me educate you more and this
actually solves all your problems right
and so those are pretty much the only
two approaches you can take in a
transactional sale now the advantages of
having this type of sale is that it's
really fast uh they tend to be lower
ticket in general uh and from an
operational perspective in the business
you don't need to personalize anything
and so you get the sales team and the
sales process to basically Orient
everyone like a funnel down to one
solution and then you just make a ton of
these Solutions and you get lots of
efficiencies because you only have to
produce one thing this the custom sale
is a harder sale sry easier sale to do
but harder on the operational side and
so the magic happens when you can
actually Bridge the product component of
transactional which you say okay we only
sell these types of widgets this is the
only thing we deliver
but I can do it in a way that feels
custom feels personalized all right so
I'm going to give you two examples and
I'll explain this one in a second this
chart that I have here which if you
could take your recurring revenue from
that to that just by changing how you
sell if you'd want to do that hang tight
we're going to break that the process so
if I had cuz I did this in the gym in
the gym world too which is part of why
our gyms make more money so a
traditional sale look something like
this someone comes in so this is
traditional and you say we have a
membership that's you know whatever $99
per month all right that's your
membership and you say our membership
has this this this and this and you want
that right because it's going to help
you accomplish all your dreams okay
sometimes you get people sometimes you
don't what I do
we do something called a
diagnostic and so the first thing is
that when the person walks in the door
we get them to fill out a pre-sale
questionnaire and so that's like an
application in a digital process but an
inperson process it follows the same
logic which by the way internet
businesses follow local businesses local
businesses can also model internet
businesses when you find out something
works in one place which I think has
been one of the big advantage of I've
had in business is I try and put it in a
completely different place and it often
works too if you understand the concept
and so we fill out a pre-sale
questionnaire now the pre-sale
questionnaire simply walks them through
all the reasons they walked in today and
it ask them the same question in
multiple different ways so it's like hey
like what brought you in today what's
the current problem you're dealing with
how long you've been dealing with it if
you had to quantify how much this has
cost you financially what would it be uh
if it continued for 5 years how much
worse would the situation be and so the
whole point is we're trying to agitate
tame we're trying to bring attention to
this problem and Elevate its importance
so that's what the pre-sale
questionnaire does now
the second thing is we get info and this
is very key so when someone comes in
after that we say hey I want to I want
to set up your account profile and so
when you do that you collect their
information and this is the key part you
get their credit card now you're like
wait a second I'm getting a credit card
but I haven't sold anything exactly and
you do that so that when you do sell
something later you don't have to ask
for it now you get the pre-sale they're
like wow I really do need this thing you
say hey let me complete your customer
profile just standard procedure no big
deal all right then you get their info
now if they're like well I don't want to
give you my credit card you're just like
it's just how the system works it's how
we complete
profiles and then they'll give it to you
all right so from there this is the this
is where the special the special magic
that's unique to each individual
business happens so in the weight loss
business I want to understand where
their goal at so we say what's
current and then four what's
desired where are you now where would
you like to be and then this one you ask
them say what's the
obstacle what's in between these two
things is the obstacle right current
I've got an obstacle getting in the way
of my desired that's all we're asking in
the process now in weight loss and in
most businesses the thing the person
thinks is in the way is often not the
real thing in the way and that's because
they've never had this conversation
before they clearly haven't solved the
solution and that's why they're coming
to you and so you want to just get their
word words more so so that you can
explain it back to them using the
language they gave you all right and so
in the weight loss world for example
instead of selling a membership I would
say okay well it sounds like you need
these three things Fitness distri
accountability Fitness wise you need to
work out X days a week nutrition-wise
you need to eat this food at this time
and we can help you meal prep the stuff
so you got when you go to restaurants
you can still stick on it and you need
accountability because if you don't if
you do if if I give you the best fitness
plan and the best nutrition plan but you
don't show up doesn't matter right
account is what makes the whole thing
work great finished nutrition
accountability easy three-step framework
fantastic now this is where it becomes
diagnostic now most
customers and this is why this is where
the magic happens is
that even if you still deliver the same
thing so fundamentally when I switch the
sales process the gyms remain the same
they still have workouts they still have
nutrition help they still have
accountability nothing changed but how
we presented changes and so rather than
saying hey I'm going to sell a four-week
thing or a six week thing I say hey
you're
currently 200 lb Okay now what's your
high school weight she says I want to I
want to get to 140 you say okay cool you
want to get to 140 this is your desired
okay so you have a 60 pound difference
now what we found is that we don't want
people to lose more than pound and a
half to two pounds a week all right so
let's just be conservative and call it
one and a half so then I take out my
calculator and I say what's one and a
half time 60 which would be other way
around it' be 60 divid by 1 and a half
which is 45 okay so 45 weeks is how
long it's going to take us to take you
from 200 to 140 so you lose a pound and
a half a week it's going to take 45
weeks and so
six present
price in
relation to
goal so you say awesome so we currently
charge 99 bucks a week we can get you
there in 45 weeks which means it's
$500 and that means and for us I added a
a guarantee on the back end which which
said hey if you show up to the workouts
for the next 45 weeks and you log your
food and you don't lose the weight I'll
keep working with you for free until you
do so that means this is the translation
this is the key part in the script so
that means when you pay this $4,500 it
means that you can count that weight for
good you can put it out of your mind you
pay me this money we're going to get
there one way or another As Long as You
Follow the steps you're going to follow
the steps right great and so here you're
trying to sell 99 bucks a month or or
whatever this would be 99 bucks a week
if if I was doing equivalent pricing all
right so this would be like a
semi-private
program but by positioning it this way
I'm not selling a membership anymore I'm
selling exactly what they want and
putting a price tag on it and saying you
want to get to 140 it's going to take
this long and I'll guarantee that you
that you'll get there provided you
follow these
steps and then they say wow that's
awesome you say well if you
want I can can save you a little bit of
money you want to save a little bit of
money and they're like yeah I want to
save a little bit of money well if you
prepay you can save 10% a
day so I can save you 450 bucks you want
to do that that's what most people do
great you want to you want to use the
card you have in
file done so that's that's the process
now I took this process and applied it
to a completely different service
business that we own that's a chain that
this is a little bit more Medical but
the concept still applied which is and
this is the key part is you have to
figure out for whatever it is that you
sell what the current is versus what the
desired is so if I were uh a painter all
right and I was painting houses sounds
crazy right say hey so you currently
have this thing you want a completely
painted house and so the like now for
them this is like more us do it for you
rather than uh self-service like I'm
going to have to like they you're not
painting your house and them helping you
so they're actually going to paint the
house so then we just try and think how
can we how can we how can we sell to
goal and break it into a price that we
tie to that and so it' be like okay so
we're going to need four coats of paint
and inste to take this period of time
and then at that point your your whole
house is going to be weatherproofed and
so that means that when you pay this
price that's what you're going to get by
this state and if we don't get it done
by that date I'm going to give you
this and that way we can relieve their
risk that it's not going to happen
happen and we tie the purchase to the
outcome so this particular business when
I bought it or bought into it
um it was a business that they had
really good lead gen and they have a
good product but they didn't have good
packaging and I saw the opportunity
because I knew that if I installed my
sales process into their business I
could make it make a lot more money and
so if you have the opportunity to like
4X a business without opening new
locations you do that and so that's more
or less what we did so I actually wrote
down the new sales process took me four
hours so I wrote down the new sales
process and then I presented to the
management team and they were like wow
this is the most valuable thing we've
ever had happen to our business and I
said great so let me know when you do it
across all the locations and let's keep
buying and opening new ones and so 18
months later we have 32 locations and
the recurring Revenue in that time
period has gone up and the average
revenue per customer went from
$200 to $800
from this one process and that was
because before this they were selling
one-off transactions they were saying
hey we'll do this service for you so
think of it like botox or we're going to
do filler or we're going to do something
this one time and so rather than just
say sure give us a call when you want it
again which is pretty much what the
process was before this I say hey you
want to look a certain way you're not
here because you want filler you're here
because you want to look a certain way
so if I show this chart to you of faces
and filler densities
where where do you see yourself on here
currently now you let them self-identify
you can't be like look vix you're ugly
can't say that so you got to say where
are you on this chart and then they say
this now in the weight loss sale I got
them to step on the scale the scale
called you fat not me all right so maybe
just point to the third party not me so
so so you get them to pick how ugly they
are all right and then you say how
pretty do you want to be now everyone's
going to say I want to be super pretty
but here's the beautiful thing when they
pick how pretty they want to be they're
the one who set the goal and that means
The price came from them and you know
where I picked this up was yogurt stores
so one of the things I thought was
genius about like Yogurt Land and things
like that was if if you go to a store
and then they fill up your stuff behind
the counter and then they say hey it's
eight bucks you're like man what the
hell this place is so expensive but if
they give you the cup and you fill it up
and you put it on the scale you're like
man I'm a fat ass same pricing but
because I had control over what I picked
I'm the one who's responsible for the
decision and so by saying where are you
on this chart and again this is where
the magic happens I say current desired
that's where the thinking behind how I'm
going to structure a sale is where like
that's where the that's where the
experience that's where the expertise
that's where it comes in this is the
process and hopefully you guys can take
this for your business and think like
okay what's current what do they really
want they're not buying lip filler
they're not buying a painted house
they're buying an image in their mind of
what they want that house to signify or
what it means to them and this lady is
not buying filler she's trying to buy a
certain look she wants people to think
about her a certain way that she want
when people walk when she walks in the
room she wants guys to turn their heads
though cuz she's probably getting a
little older they're not turning their
heads as much and she still misses that
and she pay anything to get that so say
you're ugly now how pretty do you want
to be we say cool so for us to get you
from here to here it's going to take us
45 weeks it's going to take us Botox
filler and you know plastic surgery
whatever we're going to have to hit you
with a pretty shovel and bring you back
to life all right we're going to have to
do this and it's going to take this many
weeks for us to reverse this level of
Aging or at least take these cow feed
out or whatever it is and so we tie
where you're at to where you want to go
and then our solution is only the
vehicle that delivers this outcome and
so that is the moment that you present
the price because they picked where they
were where they want to go and then you
as the expert explain the path to
getting there so they pick the before
and after and you just use your
expertise of this is what we found best
to get people to hear Who start where
you're at and so we found out that this
opportunity existed within this
particular business because I had my
sales director your secret shop them so
mind you this is Brick and mor chain we
have a lot of locations so we could
sneak our way in it's harder if you have
like a you know four sales guys who do
all the sales they'll just tell the
owner right so we wanted a secret shop
before we actually completed the
investment and so uh when he went in he
was I asked him so I went through this
checklist I was like okay so did they
give you some sort of pre-sale question
he was like no I was like okay great I
like did you did they ask you for your
credit card or did they ask you for your
information or anything before you got
the service and he was like No And I was
like fantastic what else what else El
did they do it's like did they have you
set you know pick uh where you're at and
where what your goal is he said yeah
they did have me uh pick where I was at
but not where I wanted to go so they
just had him pick okay how ugly are you
and he's like okay now again not
completely flawed I want to be really
clear here like this is a at 14
locations they're not they're not idiots
they had the pain we agitated the pain
they said listen this is how ugly you
are on this scale that we invented and
you're here you're a seven ugly great so
he checked this but he didn't get to say
where he wanted to be so then from there
he just went right into the service and
then when he came out he just gave them
the card to pay for the service and that
was it and he just walked out the door
and I was like wait so they didn't they
didn't actually like ask you to buy a
package or get into some membership or
anything and he's like well they tried
to upsell me this one product at one
point but this was the price point and
the price point was like 20 bucks or
something and I knew what the average
customer's worth which was like 200 at
the time I was like that's like by the
way if you're going to do upsell you
want the price point to usually be
usually be five times more than the
current price because if you get 20% of
people so customers are fractal so we're
going to go into a little side quest
here but it'll be worth it for you since
we're talking about
sales so you've heard of 8020 right so
You' got a 100 people right the top 20%
you've got the 80 underneath
right these are the people 8020 have
five times the spending power of these
people and so because of that if you get
20% of people to buy something that's
five times as expensive so let's say my
current thing is
$11,000 if I'm going to have an upsell I
want my upsell to be
$5,000 because if 20% take it then it's
20% time 5,000 which means I add $1,000
to my average ticket so I go from $2,000
or sry $1,000 per customer to
$2,000 per
customer and so when I heard that their
upso was 10% it'd be like having a up be
like my upsell is 100 bucks okay fine
maybe 20% take that so I I go from a
th000 to
1,020 who cares like what's like why
bother right and fundamentally again
smart business owners and they were
upselling product which means there's no
real delivery in a brick and mor service
business so they could just hand the
product make the money and I think they
were using it more for commissions for
their staff to increase the average pay
which a different objective entirely and
totally fine but I was only looking at
this from how do I take customers who
are worth $200 and make them my goal is
to get them worth a th000 currently it's
$800 I'm going to keep getting there
until we get to 1,000 but I think that
we can get it to a th and
so we secret shop them number
one which by the way if you have a team
of people who are currently selling your
stuff secret shop them and then be
horrified by what you listen to on the
phone or what you see in person because
you have this beautiful idea of what you
think your sales process is and it's a
night nightmare it's an absolute
nightmare if they remember half of it
you'll be stoked and so if you run in an
environment especially in a in a lower
wage environment so if you're brick and
mortar you have a chain of of locations
and you have to take low skill labor and
teach them a sales process you've like
the the expertise in sales comes down to
how easy and simple you can make the
process and so that comes down to like
can I automate parts of the p uh the
point of sale so that they can't move
forward without doing this checkbox
right and by doing this checkbox they
have to ask the question so it forces
script adherence now training sales not
into this video but you want to
basically repeat the process over and
over and over until they're sick of it
until they say like yes Mom would you
like to have do you have your credit you
want to use the credit card on on file
like until they're saying it like they
could they can breathe it they can think
they can say without thinking about it
that's when you've maybe just started to
have a a team that's that's well trained
now that we finished these seven uh
pieces of the diagnostic I want to add
one more bonus because you're like wait
a second so where's the where's the
recurring Revenue great observation
Andrew okay so so number eight is
transition to recurring all right I
remember this I'll give you two separate
stories that'll drive this home so A
friend of mine has a a recurring
membership that he sells and he sells it
at uh I think he was sell at 300 bucks a
month and he couldn't get people stick
past three months and so he tried all
these different gimmicks and things and
he just couldn't crack three months of
LTV now that could have been a pricing
issue whatever so this is what he did he
stops selling it at $300 a month month
to month and started selling as a
$10,000 program with 36 Monon of
Interest
refinancing and so when people bought
they were buying a $10,000 price point
but they got an amazing payment plan and
so he didn't change anything about what
he sold but that took his average
customer from 3 months to eight months
so we're talking about a $900 so three
times 300 to 8 * 300 2,400 that kind of
change in a business life-changing in
terms of how much money you can make the
second one was I had a different friend
who had a continuity program uh he was
an uh agency and what he did was he
realized he had churn in his business
and so he said you know people are way
less likely to turn out of a payment
plan same as the other one than they are
out of a monthly recurring Revenue
strain and so what you call it to the
customer can affect the likelihood that
they pay but as far as the business is
concerned you just want payments that
are regular and all you do to take a
program and take it from from a payment
plan to to recurring in terms of what
how it actually looks and feels is you
just put an automatic recurring at the
end of the program and so when someone
buys this big thing and you make a
payment plan and then it recurs into the
exact same price as the payment plan you
just move the pieces around but the
likely they stick is way higher and so
that's exactly what we did as the last
step in the diagnostic sales process and
I wanted to highlight this point for you
because I've done it in every business
and so we give someone the option to
prepay you can give if you want a little
bit more aggressive you get 20% off if
they prepaid today if you want to have
one step down below that which is what I
like to do you give them 10% off if they
do half down and then make the rest his
payments and if they still can't do that
then I take the whole thing and I spread
it over let's say our 45 weeks and so
I'd say okay it's 99 bucks a week 99 a
week and there you go now they go from
99 a week to 80 bucks a week if they
prepay the whole thing and they go from
99 bucks a week to 90 a week if they
prepay half and here's the key part is
that when we present the price you
present it at the highest rate so you
present it at the payment plan let me
walk I'll walk you through this CU I
think it's important well I'm going to
put it here and so I don't have to flip
screens for you all right so you have
your full boat I'll say full interest
price so for us in our example is 4500
bucks all right 45 weeks time 99 roughly
all right so this is our full boat price
we have our prepayment
discount in full which is-
% all right so for us it's going to be
minus what is that 900 yeah 900 from
there so that's 5600 sorry other way uh
3600 if they do half
down you say I'll let you save uh 450
bucks so 10% so 40 five Z all right so
this is
10% minus 10% that's- 20% now the reason
this is so important is think about the
alternative think about and this is what
most people do so listen to me Andrew
most people do this they present the
price is
$3,600 and then they say oh well we have
payment plans that we have interest on
and so we do we do have 10% interest if
you can put half down and we have 20%
interest if you put uh nothing down and
you just go onto a straight payment plan
well which one would you rather buy if
on one hand you have a $4,500 price tank
which anchors you high and you say or
you can get a benefit for prepaying
today rather than you think about 3600
you're considering it and then they say
oh it's even more even though you're
just considering this Peg guess what you
have to pay way more now be because you
can't afford it you have to pay
more Banks do it all the time and guess
what everyone hates Banks so if banks
want to fix their process Mr Bank maybe
this will work who knows anyway point is
is that this is how you present the
price because you get the benefit of a
price anchor and you get to be the good
guy for getting them to pay upfront
rather than the bad guy for them not
being able to so we're going to we're
going to go through step eight in uh in
the more
transition uh process for the sale and
so I want to just walk you through step
downs and so this is super important to
understand from a sales perspective so
we'll call this
sales step downs and uh this is by the
way a preview for my next book coming
out $100
million yeah anyways so so sales step
Downs is one of the things that we have
so obviously the first thing we're going
to present is a prepayment all right
which is painful today prepay yay by the
way you've probably noticed from any of
my content I don't say paidon fools and
that's because that's a that's a
Salesman term not a customer benefit if
you prepaid you get a benefit whereas
paidon full is like I got all the cash
to front good for me and so I have
trained myself because I used to say
paidon fools pipis P you know whatevers
pifs like all of that stuff I used to do
as a sales team sales leader and then I
also heard my team saying that to
customers like hey if you want to pay in
full today like it's just like kind of
gross and so I prefer to say like hey we
have a prepayment discount and so
training that just little Pro tip for
you so number one is prepay number two
is we do
discount uh with
partial so this is the half down
oops half
down here you can also do in-house well
this is whatever sorry this is credit
card or third
party so if you have like most most
businesses that sell legitimate Services
have third-party financing solution that
already exist and so I promise you there
is a banker somewhere who started a
business to service this Emerging Market
of whatever it is that you do who says
I'll bet you I can help Finance
transactions now the prices they charge
for that financing will differ based on
how risky your businesses and so like
there's financing for casinos like if
you want to get if you want to get a
loan to go gamble more like there's
financing for that but they will charge
you a lot of money right and so like
that being the extreme on the other hand
if you want to finance a house there's
obviously huge mortgage industry and so
from every step in between there are
Partners who will step in as third party
and take on that risk for you for a
price and so I prefer can I get the
prepayment because it's easiest and
fastest if not I usually have a third
party that I set up so that my customers
can get financing if we don't move past
either of these two things then I try to
go with a partial with some level of
discount not as much as here but a
little bit and if they still say
no then I go for continuity
which is why don't we just make a
payment plan on the thing and in this
particular business because what they
were doing before was simply rebooking
people for another session of
service we just had this be the
automatic like everyone gets rebooked
and that would became that became an
internal saying like I like having
montras uh within sales teams which is
like everyone buys something like
everyone buys something there's no
reason someone should not buy something
and so sure we'll get them a prepay
maybe a partial okay fine we'll do a
payment plan that's whatever call it you
know 250 uh times four great that's our
th000 that's our th000 plan that we're
getting people to buy and you pay 250
today and then three more times and you
can do it every other month if it's a
more uh intermittent service whatever
just match the payments to when they get
delivery and then finally if they're
like well I can't do any of those things
and like cool let's just let's just book
the next time you want to come in that's
it and so this is the final of the
process in terms of in terms of the step
Downs that we might offer someone we
just walk through this whole process and
you're like wow maybe that's l lot of
work I have to use my brain power but
welcome to business but let me tell you
why it's worth it so these are the
actual stats and I put the numbers
without the names to keep it nice open
loop for you so number one is that they
had 9% of Revenue uh that was recurring
within this product line all right so
they 9% that was occurring after we
implemented this
process
60% they took this 9% to 60% of this
product line within the company so
awesome number two they had basically no
membership at all because they just
weren't it wasn't even an option not
really and we were to push that to 30
that's a 30
30% into memberships this included
payment plans this is just
memberships and then we went from
getting one additional extra visit on
average per person meaning two to
getting 4 to
six visits per customer by introducing
this sales process from a money
perspective we went from $20,000 when we
uh bought the business so mind you this
business made a lot more money than this
single product line or this service line
but this is where I wanted to invest my
time because I thought there was a huge
opportunity here because I saw from the
secret shopper from the constraints I
thought this was a big area of attack
and so they only do 20,000 a month which
business de sizes not a lot and then
however many have been dots this later
over
250,000 per month in and
added and it continues to grow and this
compounds and that's the that's the
beauty of this type of sales process and
repackaging of what someone already
sells and so we went from 9 to 60 0 to
30% on memberships from one visit to
four to six visits and from 20 to
250,000 so we more than 10x the
recurring revenue of this business by
following a diagnostic process rather
than just selling some traditional
one-off thing the first thing you have
to learn how to do is how to sell the
second thing you have to learn how to do
is get someone else to sell for you and
so in this video I break down how he
scaled a new sales department from 0 to
40 sales reps doing 5 million plus per
month in sales within 90 days but before
I explain the $21.6 million increase let
me kind of give you some context on this
business and where it was in the life
cycle we brought in Mercenaries so when
I say mercenaries I mean an outsourced
sales team the founder of the business
had never been in sales at all he'd
never got on the phone he' never done
door Todo he never done anything related
to getting a stranger to give him money
one-on-one I thought it was too risky to
try and have somebody's completely new
to it try and start from scratch and so
I called somebody in my network and I
said hey do you want to make a bunch of
money and he said yes can you round up
some of your guys and start taking
college for this company that I have and
so they started taking sales and we
started making more money we have a w
money up W fantastic and in a second
I'll walk you through all the statistics
of what the mercenaries and the ouse
team did which then led us to a fully
in-house team now as you can imagine
imagine going from zero sales guys to 40
sales guys in a fresh company is hard
but let me explain some of the problems
with the mercenaries and then I'll walk
you through the actual stats so there
were three main problems with the
mercenaries all right problem number one
is that we were giving them 20% of the
revenue all right now this is something
that I was vehemently against to be very
honest with you in this particular
company I was in a minority position I
said it's ultimately your call I was
like but I would not do it at this
percentage they decided to move forward
with it anyways and hey we made money
there was a w there but it was a problem
20% of Revenue coming in is a big
[__] check the sales team company was
arguing we can't get the top guys to
sell unless we give them a really big
rip that's sales slang big commission so
we had to give them 20% of the revenue
that they collected as commission to The
Mercenaries team the ouse sales team the
second problem that came
up is related to Performance they were
getting less than 30% of people to
ascend meaning people who buy the first
thing to buy the next thing and we
wanted it to be higher than that or I
believe that it should be higher than
that we're paying a lot and we're not
getting as much out as we want the third
problem with the ouse sales team and
this is one that I think more long-term
about because I'm investor in the
business
is is the sellability and Enterprise
value of the business meaning in the
future we'd like to sell the company at
some point probably and even if you
don't want to sell a business creating a
sellable business still makes the
business more valuable and so if you can
make a business more Val Val to a
stranger it also becomes more valuable
to you if you have a outsourced sales
team something that exists outside of
the business that's responsible for 203
40% of the revenue in the business then
that could be a material issue that's
why we decided to look at these three
things and say all right let's see if we
can move this in house I'm going to walk
you through first the funnel kind of
before and after and then I'll walk you
through the process that we did to fix
it or swap it over that resulted in the
$21.6 million increase in profit not
Revenue profit the way that this process
was structured is we had a two call set
up we've got a percentage of people who
schedule a call a percentage of people
who show to the call and then schedule
the next thing then they have to show to
the next thing and they go to the next
call and then do they buy so let me walk
you through the stats here because
everyone who bought the product had a
first call that they wanted to attend
100% of people were scheduled to show up
for this call with the Outsource sales
team we had
74% of people are actually showing for
the call once they got on the call we're
able to get
53% to schedule the follow-up call and
so some people call this a qualification
call which is if you're going to sell
something else you want to make sure the
person actually fits for the thing you
sell makes sense right you want to make
sure they have the problem to solve and
the money to spend with the 53% the
Outsource team wanted to only give their
closers because he's trying to optimize
for his dollars per hour for his team
only the easiest closes so they weren't
willing to take call they weren't
already sure were going to close all
right so because of that they're only
passing 53% or almost half to the next
call now again this is just scheduling
now from here we had 63% showing up to
call two so this is call one this is
call two now this is the close call this
is the set call this is the close so
I'll just put set this is close so the
last box we got to fill in here is how
many people were they actually selling
all right and they were getting 80% of
people who show go to the second call
the closed call to buy all right and so
that is where money came out the other
side hooray so let's walk through the
math as if a 100 people bought the
product so if 100 people bought the
product then it means that we'd have 74
74% of 100 74 people who would show up
to this first call now of the 74 people
53% so about 37 of them would then
schedule for the second call of the 37
people who scheduled for the second call
we're going to have 22 so 63% 22 of them
are actually going to show up to this
close call now 80% of these 22 are going
to close which means we'd have about 20
sales or
20% of that front end that ascends now
remember I said at the very beginning
one of the
problems is that we wanted it to be
closer to 30 this is the issue and so I
want to be very clear a big part of this
was was the price point we were selling
at and the fact that we were selling
people who are already customers we're
not selling cold traffic here we're
selling people who already bought this
already demonstrated an interest and
we're saying do you want more help with
that thing so we thought it should be
much higher so there's five steps that
we broke down that we had to do to go
from out ofh housee team mercenaries to
in-house sales team and the first one
started with hiring a director now right
off the BET let me explain our thinking
process before I explain who we were
looking for and how we found them cuz
listen you don't want to hire 40 people
people right you were thinking okay I
want to hire one person who can then
hire 40
people times a lot more circles right
it's even long to write it out all right
it's an old investor saying which is
hire one to hire 10 we're going to hire
the one person not the 40 that's the
main decision after that what we're
looking for is who who are we looking
for what do they look like and then how
are we going to find them okay now from
a who perspective we wanted someone who
had been there done that
which means specifically somebody who
sold this type of product in this type
of industry and ideally scaled a big
team and knows how to coach up new
salespeople so that's what been there
means for us for this particular role
the next thing is you want the person to
be metric driven so one of the easiest
ways that you can measure someone's
Proficiency in any skills this little
Pro tip the quality and quantity of
metrics that someone explains about how
they do their job is directly correlated
with how good they are at the job and so
if someone's like hey I'm an amazing HR
person and I say cool what metrics do
you track and they're like well the
happiness of the team and I'd be like
what else do you track how many
complaints I get on payroll I'd be like
okay what else do you track the order
that they tell me the metrics they're
looking at and what they track is going
to tell me what they care about what
they pay attention to and their level of
expertise now on the flip side if
someone says hey I like to take
companies from on average a 45-day time
to fill to 20-day time to fill because
we know that every day that company
doesn't have something they need they're
losing money there's opportunity cost of
Revenue they should be making by not
having them this is really interesting
because they're connecting their metrics
to the company's revenue and so how
people talk about the metrics and which
metc they track and how they connect
those with how it makes the company more
money will show you how good they are
what they do the third one is just kind
of the I would say
demeanor now I've hired a lot of sales
people and sales directors in my life
and the personality of a sales leader is
usually not the same as the personality
of a sales killer now there are some
superstars who can do both but it's
rarer often times the demeanor of sales
directors is a little bit more even
killed usually more humble very servant
oriented they have to be people people
they have to be the type of person who
wants to pour into the team and loves
watching someone improve their skill set
and can repeat the same directions over
and over and over again without losing
enthusiasm that's who you want you want
somebody who's like a Energizer Bunny of
of Positive Vibes because for the most
part sales director is just Performance
Management they manage the culture of
the team like the output of the entire
team is the direct function of the sales
director and so if you think about this
like on a on a football team or
something you can switch the coaches and
all of a sudden the whole team does way
better it's because the coach drives the
culture in the team that drives the
performance and the output and so that
is what they are responsible for and so
if they don't have values everything
else that comes from the team is going
to be a diluted version of them now we
go to the how you're like okay well that
sounds like an amazing unicorn Alex how
do you find that person who's going to
replace this well I personally have a
relatively large network of salespeople
and so one of the big things here is
that you can either this is the core 4
by the way you can do
Outreach which means you reach out to
strangers who you think might fit the
role you can run ads so you run ads to
go get more people content you can also
do recruiter I've used all of these all
right so there there's pros and cons to
each of them but what I will do is I'm
going to cross out two of these early
for most of you most people think that
you can run ads for these types of roles
the reality is usually no the higher the
role is the better the person is the
less likely they're going to respond to
an ad cuz think about it an amazing
sales director is always going to have a
job and always going to be making good
money now they might not like their job
as much as they they they could but
they're going to keep making money and
sales directors tend to be money
oriented in general and so they're going
to keep making money so ads is probably
not the way to get them content unless
you have a salesperson audience probably
not going to be the way you can always
try it it's free give it a shot but I
wouldn't say I'm going to bet the farm
on this so it's probably not going to be
content and so usually you're going to
do one of these two which is you're
going to get a recruiter to do it or you
do it yourself but guess what a
recruiter
does they do Outreach too I know this is
going to sound crazy you message them
and you say hey I've got this role and
it looks like you're perfect for it
could I tell you about it or if you want
to be a little less direct you can say
you're an amazing person who' be a fit
for this role do you do you know anybody
else like you they're going to be like
screw everybody else talk to me Alex how
many people do I reach out to five five
no one's even going to read it if you
message five people 10 no one's going to
read it if you message 10
people reach out to 100 to 1,000 people
and if you get to that 1% on the 100 and
you haven't found it then you might have
to go 1% on th000 and that's okay cuz
remember would you rather have a top 1%
sales director I sure this [__] would so
it's okay to turn down the first you
talk to just cuz he has a pulse and has
one of these things it's like okay this
guy talked about metrics but he was a
dick and he actually doesn't have the
experience that I'm looking for well
then don't hire him the thing is is it's
tough to do that when you're an
entrepreneur because you're like I'm
bleeding every day the house is on fire
I need this roll but I promise you it's
way more painful to hire the person on
board them spend 2 months run getting
them up then they start hiring [__]
because they're a [__] and then all
of a sudden you're like oh my my God I
HTE this whole team and so even if you
do get rid of the top you then have all
the stuff they brought in underneath and
so you have to clean house and it's
really really painful and so as much as
you hire one to hire 10 if you fire one
sometimes you have to fire 10 and that
sucks and so getting this higher right
is super important but it's also why we
spend more time on it so now that we
hired our in-house sales director we
want to rebuild the compensation
structure right because remember the 20%
wasn't going to fly because if we just
flipped it to 20 we might as well just
save the effort right so we had to
rebuild the incentive structure the
problem that we had right now if you
remember was that we had the pro I think
it was problem one or problem two
whatever problem one problem two
whatever it was 20% of Revenue was going
to the Outsource sales team so we wanted
to make sure we were less than that our
Target was sub 10% and that's usually
around what I like to be in now I want
to be very clear here there are things
that this depends on so if you're in a
business where the salesman does self
gen meaning they generate their own lead
so if you're if you're going out Bend
and you're cold calling or you're door
knocking
then these percentages will be shifted
because you technically are a cost of
acquisition you're both marketing and
sales you're getting the leads and
closing the leads if you're handing
salese leads if you're running ads you
have a media team that then generates
leads or prospects for a sales team then
you basically have to split that cost
between the marketing team and the sales
guys and so given that let me explain
how I actually think about this what
skills do I need how rare are those
skills so if I'm feeding softballs to
somebody then I don't need need Ken
griffy to hit it out of the park all
right for jiny uh mookie bets all right
I don't need mookie bets to knock it out
of the park uh because I'm soft tossing
right anybody can probably rock it out
of the park that's double AER up because
at that level because it's so much
easier if you have crazy expectations
it's rarer and they have more skills so
you got to pay more if it's something
that's not a lot of skills and more
common you can pay less and so I just
think how much would I need to pay to
attract the level of salesperson I need
our goal is to take from 20% to around
10% or less and rebuild the complaint
you can think about
compensation in two columns all right
you've got money and not
money all right this very complicated
system I don't want to get into the
specific a lot of physics behind this
all right so you've got the money you
give them for closing deals and then
you've got other [__] and so that's
recognition praise attention approval
perk
status if you publicly recognize them if
you have a leaderboard if you give them
more attention you get you actually
train them more you give them more
skills you say hey out a boy awesome job
great day today you say hey the guy who
closes the most gets to park in the nice
parking lot and then status like maybe
when they close a 100 sales they get a
hat with a stripe on it when they close
a th sales they get two stripes and so
forth so when you guys come on the team
they're like [__] I want one of those
hats right sales team six let's go
there's all these things that you can do
to increase the value of of the job
outside of money and as much as people
sales guys include will be like that
doesn't motivate me sure as [__] does
all right it totally does cuz it makes
your life better on the money side
there's a couple ways to do this all
right and so I'm going to explain how we
did it i' we've we've made a lot of
different compensation structures a lot
of it depends on again the business
that's involved now one of the big
decisions we made up front was that we
were going to comp
Setters and
closers now why is that so important the
funnel is through if I can increase my
show up rate by 20% it's just as good as
increasing my closure by 20% it makes no
difference the business they were just
as equally weighted in terms of their
value but again how rare are the skills
and what skills are required it's easier
to set than it is to close just as
important but easier Setters and closers
equally important but rarer to find a
skill from closers so they got paid a
little bit more but Setter still got
commissions as well to incentivize the
fact that they would get people to sh
cool so the way that I prefer to set up
compensation structures the idea that I
like to have is that I like ww at the
top which means winners win all right
which also means losers lose that's fine
there's more fewer winners than there
are losers what that means is you can
have ratchets for compensation meaning
if you close
50% of the people I'm just using
arbitrary number you get to keep your
job if you close
60% you get adab boys
if you close
70% your commission goes from 10% to 15%
ah 50% increase not bad if you close
above
80% you get
25% whoa right and so it ramps and so it
allows the people who are absolute
Killers to crush and then the people who
are not guess what happens down
here turn but this is structural turn
this is expected turn this is part of
the game with this type of role like if
you require work ethic you require
practice require people show up early
work late work weekends take calls it
requires a certain type of person and a
lot of people aren't cut out for it
which is also why most people don't make
multiple six figures a year selling we
fixed the compensation structure we
comped Setters and closers we ramped it
so that the best guys would get more
than 10% but we knew that as a team we
averaged around if you want to know the
actual number was we got the overall
everything Allin fully baked in
including the sales director for 9% we
are feeding them qualified prospects
they're not even prospects they're
customers we already have their [__]
credit card like we just had to say want
more of the thing you just bought want
more help with that thing so you can get
the outcome you just said you wanted
like these are not hard sales and by
doing this we got to move on to step
three now that we rebuilt the incentive
and comp to get the types of sales guys
that we want on the team then we had to
rebuild the process so I'm going to walk
through what we do to improve each of
these numbers one by one because as
you're thinking about your business
there is no Silver Bullet there's no one
thing you're going to do that change
this entire process it's 100 golden BBS
and this is how we approach everything
in business and business is a pipeline
like this and so I'm going to show you
what we did and we did improve every one
of these numbers except for one but it
was okay and I'll show you why but
remember 100% of people are
automatically booked for this next
appointment all right and so we wanted
to improve this show up rate and so we
improved it to
91% woo ooh 74 9991 more money good
that's a 211% increase meaning if we did
nothing else we did nothing else in this
entire process everything willse stay
the same we would have a 20% increase in
sales and most of that would
disproportionately drop to the bottom
line cuz we already acquired the
customer so all this additional sales
money goes to profit big deal so we did
three things the first is that the
mercenary team is way too aggressive in
their copy false urgency false scarcity
people kind of see through it um so that
was number one that they did that we
fixed number two is they were giving
people way too much time time to book
out I'd say hey when do you want to show
up for your next call people would be
like oh how's 2 weeks from now and they
were like sure our big rule of thumb
despite the fact them trying to push out
five plus days for appointments is we
try to go for same day next day and
that's because in our history more
people show up the same to next day
appointments than 5 days plus from now
and so by just simply making the
messaging less aggressive shortening the
time when they can book their next call
and number three setting reminders that
were actually personalized so rather
than just Robo texts they're the green
ones that everyone [__] hates right
we'd have the sales guy do a three-way
connection with the setter and say hey
my name's John it's nice to meet you
Sarah looks like you've got X Y andz
that I can reach from your account
really excited to talk to you tomorrow I
think I can help you with X Y and Z very
simple but it's a video or a voice memo
and they see it from a real person all
right and they can take a picture
whatever and those three things together
91% which is a 21% improvement so now
that we got people to show for that
first call how many of them did we get
to schedule the next call which is
basically the close of the set call
you're going to see some magic happen
right here we had a major Improvement
I'm not going to tell you what I'll tell
you how much we improved this one in a
second but we did two things to improve
the percentage of people who showed up
to set calls who decided to schedule
close calls all right so the number one
mistake that they were making in this
particular business is that again this
was an outsourc closing team and so they
were trying to minimize how much
unqualified work their closers would get
because they so carefully wanted to make
sure their closes were happy because
they were all mercenaries they all had
to pay them a ton just to show up to
work every day point being one the
incentives were misaligned and so
Setters remember we added our Setters
had a compensation to get people to set
they didn't have that we did add that
and so what do you know our Setters got
more people to schedule wild I know the
second thing was that they were deqing
people on the set call uh in my opinion
too early and so they wouldn't really go
through a sale they would just say hey
here's the price are you down to pay
that if yes I'll book you a call with
John but by doing that they were
basically not selling they were just
taking orders which if I just tell you
the price and you buy I don't need you
you're not selling at all you're just a
checkout page that's inefficient that
takes 20% we corrected number one we we
we align the incentives of the Setters
with the overall business not the closer
we align the setting incentive with the
business throughput which got rid of the
dqs that were overly deqing people and
we made sure that when they were talking
about the product we were just more
trying to qualify the prospect to make
sure they had the problem to solve and
the money to spend not telling them the
price of what they would ultimately buy
cuz we haven't sold them yet we just
want to make sure that this is a big
enough problem for them and that they
seem reasonably able to pay if we
present it to them our schedule
percentage went from survey says 53%
to 94% % for those keeping track at home
that's a 77% increase so forgetting this
one if we kept everything else the same
and we only did this we would have
increased sales by
77% assuming everything else stayed the
same but everything else didn't stay the
same so let me show you the next thing
we did which is we had people show up
for the first call we got 94% to
schedule the next call and now we have
what perc of these 94 actually showing
cuz hey maybe you just get everyone to
say yes so they get off the phone but
are they actually showing believe it or
not this is going to sound crazy the
show rate that we had here was actually
the same process that we had here
because believe it or not if people have
good experience and it's personalized to
them they're more likely to show and so
rather than explain literally repeat
myself I'm going to say how we actually
got the team to do it so we did four
things number one is we started
implementing daily training which means
that every day the team would get
together and they would roleplay the
scripting to make sure their tone was
right that they were coming off the
right way that they're hitting the main
points Mak sure that they were framing
things properly adding curiosity hitting
the main pain points that the prospect
was going to have so they could set up
the next call number two is that we do
gam tape reviews which is uh very simple
but you just watch gam tape with the
team and you have the person who is in
the call critique themselves so rather
than have everybody jump on them cuz no
one likes that it's horrible you just
have them say what are all the things
you could have done differently and then
the team says all the things they did
well cuz remember there's always
something someone did well you play the
tape they say all the things they would
have done differently and most people do
know when they watch it which is one of
the best ways to learn and then everyone
else says hey I think you did a great
job here I think you did a great job
here Bravo next one up the third thing
is this is why the sales director was so
key and why they were the first hir was
is doing one on ones and 101's you role
play like I you role play till you're
sick in the face you have to learn how
to train people how to speak like that's
what the job of the sales manager is
besides managing the culture of the team
is if John's Rapport building sucks
guess what sales manager does every time
they have a one with John they practice
Rapport building all right which means
you follow the script no say it again y
say it again try like this huh like
there you go change your tongue there it
is like we're talking 10 20 30 reps on
one or two phrases in the script so they
get it down if your salesman is not
talking back to you in the script on
your one-on ones you were literally
wasting time the fourth thing was just
end of day reports which is you just
want to make sure that they know you're
tracking what matters and if there's no
tracking throughout the week no one
feels held accountable it also doesn't
give you the opportunity to praise and
give out of boys all right and so every
day the stats are get tracked in real
time and daily leaders daily winners all
right so those are the four things we
did from here to drive our show rate
to woo 87% that's a 40% increase so if
we did nothing else but we just had this
one Improvement in this process and
everything else stayed the same we would
have increased sales by
40% not too shabby if you're following
at home which you should be we should at
this point have a ton more volume that
is coming to these closers massive
improvements cuz remember these are
customers this is why we felt like we
could do a lot better now hitting the
close call so in order to improve this
number to the best degree possible
because we never we're going to have
more disqualified people here remember
we we told the Setters send anybody you
can because we wanted to get more at
bats okay so one we also added in a vssl
so video sales letter between call one
and call two so people got to have some
social proof they got to see some
results they got to have a better
understanding because in my personal
opinion I don't like sales people
repeating a pitch I'd rather have
someone understand the benefits and then
have salesmen resolve concerns and
personalize solutions to customers
rather than have them say the same
15minute pitch because it then it sounds
robotic and they zone out and so does
the prospect so I like to say here's all
the info watch that and then we'll talk
about it okay so number one is we added
that piece in number two we role played
a lot on the common objections and we
like to do that before the call the
video sales letter covered some of these
common concerns in the video so that the
sales guys had a little bit more of
Advantage going into the call and then
also in the scripting we front-loaded
the obstacles before you mention the
price you overcome obstacles after it's
objections all right so if I say hey do
you think your husband supports you in
doing this new thing before I say the
price then I've overcome an obstacle if
I say the price and I didn't overcome it
it becomes an objection which is way
harder to close we call it killing
zombies right you want to kill the
Zombies you want to defuse the bombs
before you talk about money and so we
front loaded the script to accom at
those issues that people were losing in
the sales and we focused the script far
more on what they were going to
experience afterwards rather than the
features within the service because at
the end of the day they don't care about
the features of service they care about
where they're going to go what life's
going to be like afterwards so sell the
vacation not the plane flight so we made
those changes and
we got the close rate if you're like
wait 42 is lower than 80 sure as hell is
great math if we're doing the
percentages here and we have a 21%
increase here and a 77% increase here
and we have a 40% increase here so
that's 1.2 + 1.77 +
1.4 we have far more than a double in
terms of how much volume was going there
in fact we had three and 1 half times
more volume but we cut the Clos rate in
half but 3 1/2 * .5 is more than 1
meaning we increased the total
throughput of this system and so the end
result of this entire process
is we went from closing 20% of that 100
people that buy the product to 32 for a
net
Savings of going from 20% of Revenue to
9% so we paid less than half to get 60%
more sales and as you recall all
additional sales dropped to the bottom
line because we'd already acquired the
customers so now that we had ear in
house director we rebuilt the incentive
and comp plant and we rebuilt the sales
process now we wanted to scale so we had
to go from zero to 40 reps and we had to
do it in record time all right so number
one is that to go get all those people
we went everywhere all right so we
actually did all the things that
outlined but we also hired five to six
recruiters right off the bat we did a
ton of up on ourselves we hit our whole
email list up we did everything cuz we
had to hire 40 guys we had to do it in
12 weeks all right so number one is we
did everywhere so plus ads well actually
didn't do ads there's more uh
content and outbound all right so
recruiters content and outbound is what
we did to get all the people in the door
now once we had people in the door we
didn't have the sales director interview
all these candidates because he just
wouldn't literally have the time he did
a final check off once the team planned
on hiring them and so we had the manager
for the Setters do do several of the
talks with the leads and we also had the
recruiters do a lot of the screening as
well so that the sales director could
save his time and still keep managing
the actual team and training the people
who are on the floor making money for
the company all right so
saved
directors time the next thing is okay
great so we got a lot of people we got
them hired but how do we make sure that
they're actually good so we automated
the sales
training to the greatest degree possible
now what does that really mean it means
we made a course that was an internal
course on how to sell this thing and so
the nice thing with internal courses if
you don't have them high recommend it
because the most expensive thing a
business can do is train salespeople
reason why is because when you take a
salesperson and you train them on live
prospects all of the money they don't
close is money you lose and you lose all
like you lose the money that you could
have made and you lose the money that
you spent to get them there very
expensive all right especially when and
this happens a lot too you do all of
that only to have them get fired or
leave or burn out or whatever all right
and so we want them to take as many reps
ass soonly possible in a fashion where
there's no risk to the company which is
why we have them watch tons of gam tape
footage they tend all the meetings they
listen to tons of live calls they go
through the course and then they
roleplay there's one takeaway from this
[__] video it's that you roleplay
with your team and that you get really
really narrow on the things you want
them to improve and you keep nailing
that thing until it's perfect and then
you move to the next thing there's no
point in trying to tell someone to
improve six things doesn't work I
promise you it doesn't work I spent too
long doing this doesn't work you say
let's work on the first sentence of the
[__] script keep doing it again try
it again try it again try it again one
more time say it lighter say it faster
Loop to this one got it second question
right that's how you work through a
script until they will they will be able
to breathe it in their sleep then they
can actually be present for the sales
call cuz they don't have to think about
the scripting cuz they already know it
so we recruited the people we saved the
director's time we automated the
internal onboarding I'm going to give
you a pro tip from
me which is that if someone seems like a
dad within 14 days let them go
some people think I'm heartless how
could I be so heartless because I have
other families I have to look out for
too and if we don't keep the sales team
profitable the whole business doesn't
work we give people a shot we get to all
this stuff we give them a ton of free
training all right they actually
technically get paid to get trained and
if they don't if they're not up to chops
we got to let them go but we set that
expectation up front and one more thing
and this is a a little Pro tip for me I
don't know how to spell that but no
padas all right so no special snowflakes
because the thing is is even if you have
one killer on the team and they don't
follow the process they undermine the
entirety of the process and they also
kill the culture and so if one guy does
double the sales of everybody else or
triple the sales of everyone else I can
almost guarantee nine times out of 10 in
my experience they actually take those
sales out of the organization overall so
one guy does triple and everyone's like
oh we should be like him but the you if
you have like a 20 person team and
everyone goes down by 10% because of
this guy because the cancer spreads not
worth it just cut it out keep the system
and now that we had the in-house
director we rebuilt the incentive and
comp plan we rebuilt the sales process
we scaled the sales team and we
stabilized it so that we were
consistently beating the other team and
doing it for less then we're able to
move on to step five which is get rid of
outsourced
team so with the ouse team we did $7
million in cash collected in q1 the
commission on that was 1. $4 million
remember 20% so the company got to
profit 5.6 I'm saying profit Loosely 5.6
the company got to keep after paying the
sale the out Outsource sales team this
7% with the in-house sales team
became $12 million the next quarter the
commission because instead of
20% we went to 9% so the commission went
from 1.4 million on 7 to
1.08 million for 12 net change here was
12us 1
10.92 million which created the
difference between these two was
5.4
million and that was just in that
quarter times four for the year and you
get 21.6 million this is one of my
favorite sales presentations I've ever
given and it covers three things one how
to ask the right questions two how to
ask them the right way and three how to
duplicate those words in that tone
across a team of people if you're
building your first sales script if
you're scaling a sales team and you want
to make sure that you can onboard new
people and get them selling at the same
percentage or better than you are right
now which for many people is biggest
bottleneck especially when you're coming
to for your first million or first 3
million per year scaling the sales team
is one of the most difficult tasks and
so I've broken this down into three
Frameworks that I've used very
successfully to scale lots of different
sales teams I say that the the company
I'm referencing in this video has 14
that one company already now has almost
30 sales guys so this process continued
to work past when I made this
presentation so if you're trying to
scale sales you want to close a higher
percentage you want to get more guys
closing at that same percentage or
better than yours and if you don't know
who I am my name is alosi I acquisition.
comom with a portfolio at this moment of
six companies to do $85 million a year
keep being awesome love you and enjoy
the video
what I'm going to be breaking down today
is the scripting process that we've
applied for calls right and so as the
world's worst marketer I set my first
email this year I was very excited about
it we've been in business for 10 years
uh pretty big stuff and it was because I
couldn't get webinars I couldn't get
vsls I couldn't get all the fancy stuff
that you guys get to work um and so I
went back in time and just was like if I
can just get him to give my phone number
I'll be able to get him to you like buy
[__] from me and so I went and called
back all these webinar leads that never
showed up or never bought or whatever
and then doing like 100,000 in sales in
a day and I was like wow this is so much
easier and so over time I've consulted
with sales teams I've uh trained and
owned four high ticket uh performance
teams uh I think we have 12 or 14 sales
guys now it kind of rotates and so what
I want to do is kind of show you what
we've done to consistently replicate the
skill of sales another human being would
that be cool all right so if I can add
like 10% to your conversion rate in
terms of how you attract better closers
how you script the process out and how
you should close more deals and scale
them to incentivize them would that be
valuable for you guys all right sweet so
these are the three Frameworks that
transform losing funnels in cash
machines that was my real life that was
a picture of my actual first funnel and
that's what it became and so these are
the three fail uh the Frameworks number
one closure framework how to ask
questions that prospects to say yes
adding this to a funnel instantly can
make it profitable right this is my
personal experience number two is
conviction framework all right how
anyone who believes can outperform a
seasoned sales rep by simply learning
control control their tone really
important this is one of the biggest
things that most sales people Miss
number three the scaling framework how
to easily duplicate this process across
sales people in any niche in seven days
or less so seven days from now we can do
this would that be cool all right let's
rock so number one the closure framework
after going through hundreds of scripts
I've bought Grant stuff I bought the
Wolf of Wall Street stuff I bought all
that stuff and going through my own
sales processes I learned that the the
scripting process even was simpler I
think than it's portrayed and it's not
that it's something to be sold against
but um every sales script that has been
absolute Gang Busters has been a
question-based framework that is based
on this process all right and this works
for B Toc sales it works for B Tob uh
B2B sales it works for $500 tickets it
works for $100,000 tickets the process
is the same and so this is the acronym
closure framework as I said world's
dumbest marketer so I made it nice and
easy to remember all right so C clarify
why they are there when I look at
creating a script the first thing we ask
is like why the hell are you here what
mean you reach out to us today what was
the thing what is the goal you're trying
to accomplish right two label them with
a problem we can't cure cancer unless
they admit that they have it right has
anyone had a situation where like I just
want to find out more information you
ever had that right well it's like well
I'm assuming you're not hopping on sales
calls all day just trying to find
information is there a problem you're
trying to solve oh you're fat got it all
right boom so that's a problem we can
solve it after that I'm I'm assuming I'm
not the first guy you've ever dated
right so is there anything else that
you've had happen in the past that got
you here that didn't work I'd love to
know more about it s once we've gone
through the pain we sell on the vacation
right there's a process that I'll walk
through e we explain away their concerns
cuz obviously samean people don't make
decisions on the first call unless
you're a closer in which case they do
which I'll talk about and then finally
and this is something that we actually
added in my original flamework for my
first couple years was close and then we
added the r uh because when you do this
it actually transitions into the
onboarding process that will get higher
LTV per customer lower churn lower
refunds lower charge backs which sales
guys and you will be happy about cool
all right let's rock so we'll examine
each one more closely clarify why
they're there these are the questions
that sounds like what made you come in
today what made you reach out what's
your goal right now why is that
important to you why that number
specifically what does it what does it
resonate for you right why why is that
real L the questions that we're looking
is like okay so what I'm hearing is XYZ
us your goal does that sound about right
right really simple but very important
it's a milestone that has to be hit in
the process all right then we overview
all right this is where we're Gathering
all the inel and for some of you guys my
goal is that you can take this to your
sales team your sales director and run
your script through this framework and
then see where you can plug in you
probably have some of it but if you're
missing one or two of these questions
and Milestones you're losing conversions
on the call like you're closing people
who already had those obstacles covered
but everyone who didn't have two of
these questions covered you lose them
and you don't know why you watch the
sales call you're like what the hell
happened here right so what have you
tried so far to accomplish that how this
is what we call the pain cycle it's a
four-step process what have you tried so
far to accomplish this how long did you
do that for how long ago how did that
work for you what else have you tried
right so we just do that cycle until
they're like well yeah that's it now
that you think about it I've tried
everything under the sun like I can't
imagine what that's felt like wow right
it's not your fault you're so close
you're 6 Ines away right and I think you
you said this one thing which I'm about
to show you in a second we could be able
to help you want to hear about the
program fantastic that's when we
transition to the sale right right so
sell them a vacation the number one
thing that people mess up our sales
pitch on the call is under 3
minutes 3 minutes 180 seconds when we
talk about um I think someone was asking
about what are the bullets on the page
we don't say anything about that because
what we're trying to do is get them to
understand what they're going to
experience not how they're going to
experience it right and so when we have
a sales pitch just about every time we
sell three things right and it doesn't
matter what industry you're in I was
training mortgage leads team and they
were selling leads right and it was like
uh the leads are exclusive they're
timely and they're qualified right and
so we talked about hey you've had leads
in the past ah well the Zillow leads my
real estate people right the Zillow
leads are not they are timely but
they're definitely not exclusive and
these are people just window shopping
right our leads are different three
things you can always find them your s
fitness your own Fitness Nutrition
accountability right and so what we do
is when we say the three bullets get
them to understand yes that takes 5
Seconds cool fitness-wise we get the
commitment this is what I need you to do
fair enough be like I need you to work
out three days a week can you do that
awesome if we see any hesitation you
have a 30second story that's memorized
most of this script and this is what
makes it scalable is a question-based
framework which means if you get lost
you can find your way back again if
anybody here have scripts that are like
paragraphs and stuff
anyone okay like no no one has a script
that's paragraphs and Pages please we
all
know um but if you have those things
it'll totally mess it up because then
the the sales guy gets lost and then
he's just freeballing and he has no idea
where he is hot doging a hallway no idea
what's going on right and so the point
is here little visual anyways is that
when we're telling the story like with
the fitness example I would say hey when
you failed in the past like right now do
you have a do you have a favorite TV
show Game of Thrones that's awesome do
you feel like like you got to get
motivated to watch Game of Thrones
you're like oh man I've been wanting to
watch it but I just can't get up the
motivation to watch TV they're like well
no I don't have that it's like right and
so that's exactly how we're going to
make your fitness program so if you look
forward to you don't need the motivation
The Willpower because that's why you
fail in the past they're like oh I
didn't talk about the workouts the heart
rate and the calories they're going to
burn and they're going to sweat cuz all
that [__] sounds like work right but
what they do get is exactly what they
want which is wait so you're telling me
that if I actually like something I'm
not going to even have to try and it's
going to feel like watching TV cuz I
look forward to it it's exactly what I'm
saying and if you can deliver you make
tons of money and that's the point so
each of those points your sales guy
should know what that anecdotal story is
right if I was selling accountability
anyone have kids anyone here tell their
kids to brush their teeth and we have
their kids to brush their teeth say they
don't want to brush their teeth anyone
tell their kids even though they want to
brush their teeth to brush their teeth
anyways and now you're an adult did your
parents did that to you do you brush
your teeth that's an example of external
accountability turning into an internal
habit it's exactly what the
accountability we're going to do in this
program indust does that make sense
great done next bullet that's how you
transition in the pitch right so if you
think about this process why are you
here I have cancer I think we might be
able to help you out but I don't want to
get into that because I don't know about
you like I don't know what your
situation is tell me what you've done ah
that sounds that sounds great that makes
sense okay I think we might be able to
help see a little bit about that all I
did is I tell three stories that make
complete sense to everything you just
told me
and then we transition and so um I
pretty much just covered this um but we
we call it sell on the vacation not the
plane flight right and so we're not
selling TSA we're not selling your
modules your me plant your macr workout
your sport team your URLs your whatever
right we're selling Maui we're selling
the Final Destination and it doesn't
matter what level of service you are
selling you're always selling the same
thing it's always Maui it's just how do
you want to get there you want to swim
to Maui right do you want to take a boat
to Maui do you want to take a normal
flight or do you want to take a private
jet to Maui
right it's your call you're getting to
Mau either way because we're a man of
our word and I'm not going to sell you
something that's not going to deliver
right but it's going to be a little
different it's a little bit rock here
but we're going to get you there all
right so everyone gets the Maui the
variables are the the speed and the
quality of the journey all right the
likelihood of arrival is assumed so
since it's always the same thing you
probably have multiple levels of
business um but it's always the same
process right and so once we have that
they're like got it then we just make
the ask all right from this point going
forward it's explaining way their
concerns like any human being would
normally do I could drill price over
comes with you but I think it's more
valuable to explain the thought process
behind price stall and decision maker um
objections all right so the first and
obvious one is I can't afford it anyone
to get this one right couple people two
people of God in the you guys have the
best leads give me your leads um and so
the easy question that I use to explain
to our sales team because it's really
about breaking their Le beliefs is if we
were giving away Ferraris right now for
five grand do you think they'd find a
way to get the
money yes so that simply they do not
understand the value we're trying to
provide and if you can get your team to
believe that then they understand that
it is always their fault if someone
cannot afford the program does that make
sense fantastic second decisionmaker
clothes one of the hardest things to
overcome right I got to have my business
partner I got to have my husband my
spouse my whatever right so we have a
specific process that we go about this
and so what we do is in the very
beginning we just say we circumvent then
we go over past agreements and then we
ask for forgiveness all right this is
the best way that I've seen to overcome
this so the first thing we say is well
what if they say no one out of three
times they'll be like I'd probably do it
anyways and we're like let's get started
boom it's done you'd be amazed how many
times that actually works it's hilarious
if they say well then I wouldn't do it
then we divert we say well what do you
think their biggest objection would be
about it because now they're just using
a foil even the person's not there and
has no idea what the program is cuz
they're not involved with call right
they're like well I think this and at
this point we can attack the actual
obstacle even though the decision maker
isn't there now if they still if we
still can't overcome it then we go to P
agreements we say well does your
business partner know you guys are
struggling on sales well yeah does he
approve of that well no then why would
he be against something that he already
doesn't approve of that doesn't make any
sense why would he be against a business
partner solving a problem is know what
you do well that's great you're being a
great partner let's go right and so we
try and rely on past agreements that are
obvious and use those to Pro into the
present right and then finally you know
sometimes it's better ask for uh
forgiveness and permission right and so
we'll tack that on to the end you can
put that at the end of any of the closes
and so when we're dealing with this with
price it's value with decision maker we
go on past agreements and with stalls we
just teach people to make decisions
people are just so afraid of making the
wrong decision they're petrified and so
what we do is we literally teach them on
the call here's how we make a decision
these are the the variables you should
be considering X Y and Z right can the
product meet your needs do you think
that if you work with us you have a
greater or lower likelihood of losing
weight greater fantastic I think we're
halfway there do you want to work with
us do you think it'd be fun to hang out
and see me every day because believe me
this stash I had to I had to work 12
months to get my wife to say yes to that
so I understand if you're hesitant does
that make sense would you be willing to
do that all right let's rock right and
then do you have access to funds or know
someone who does right because it's not
just about you because if it's something
that's amazing we can find other ways to
finance this so do you have access or
know someone who does yes well then
great let's get started and if for some
reason we haven't closed them at this
point we say how about this let's take a
card down we'll delay the payment to
Friday you go to your husband you go to
your business partner right you go to
your I love this one you go to your
husband right and he says baby I want
you to live a shorter life I want you to
I want you to be a terrible example to
our kids I want you to not have
generational Health in our family to be
down I want you to sit in that corner I
want you to pull those sweatpants up
take up a bag of Cheetos rub your
fingers on there right and just get
comfortable with the fact that you're
never going to look better than you are
right now I like if your husband says
that to you you call me back and I will
tear this contract up fair enough right
you close them all right so we explain
where their concerns and then finally we
get the yes we reinforce the decision
this is stuff that we started doing and
it helped a lot so personalized video
from the CEO hey welcome aboard so happy
to have you thank you for trusting us
with your business hey we're so happy to
have you you thank you for trust me with
your your weight loss Journey know
personalized this is we want to do
everything in our power to absolutely
Amaze you right little things like that
because the customer is usually deciding
whether or not they like your business
in the first 48 hours after the sale I
learned this later so how you hand off
from sale to customer experience and
activation is where this all happens
does that make sense is that cool was
that nice love framework to work through
okay so that's the disclosure framework
that is the first thing that's what you
can run your script through all right
how to ask the questions to get the
prospects to say yes
check one down two to go you with me you
still good all right let's rock so
conviction framework number two how
anyone who believes can outperform a
season sales rep by simply learning to
control their tone all right so um after
I reworked all of our scripts using the
closure framework um some of my guys
were really successful but other ones
still blew and I was like well this
sucks right I was really excited I had a
little acronym and everything I was like
that took me a long time to come with
the acronym right and I was like what
gives and so I talked to some my friends
um and they recommended this book which
was awesome and the biggest takeaway
from this book is the is the concept of
tone and this was something that really
helped take us and give an extra Edge
for our sales training ourselves process
and the coaching that we give people
right and so in the book he talked about
the hidden dialogue um which I just love
and I just I just never want to take
credit for an idea because I got it from
him um but there's two dialogues that
are happening right um because the words
or the logic right what you're actually
saying is talking to The Logical brain
how you say it is talking to the
emotional brain right that's the one's
making decision that's the one running
the shop all right and so how you say
what you
say is what you
say so here's an example that's my wife
she's going to be here with me soon but
if she were here if she
said Alex right or Alex right or Alex
very different meanings very different
afternoon for me in each of these
scenarios
right based on how she said it because
there's so much communicated and that's
just one word imagine a 30 minute
dialogue where each word can be chosen
to have packed with the meaning that you
need them to feel does that make sense
okay so we need the words for The
Logical influence we need the tone for
the emotional influence we need both
okay and so once you become a more
seasoned like sales crap you can learn
to control your tone on purpose right
you can raise your voice at the end of
the statement to make it into a
question right it's a
question this is
John right I didn't need to ask him I'm
saying you know to answer that as a
question I didn't ask you that but you
know that based on the tone right or I
could lower my voice right now you know
that what I'm saying extremely
important right tone matters and so it
takes time to develop this level of
unconscious Mastery so there's two ways
to develop this and I believe that you
can either trick yourself into it or you
can train yourself into it and since I
don't have enough time in 30 minutes to
train on the influence of tonalities
here's the trick is that all right I'll
just give you the hack conviction will
correct your
tone if you believe in what you sell you
will say it the right way and that's why
some of you guys have a sales rep it
comes on crushes it and then tanks
because they did believe and then they
saw your reviews or they got customer
support feedback someone called them up
after buying it was like [__] you I
can't believe you did that and they're
done and then all their tones off
because they feel like out of Ethics
right and so I'm lowering my tone right
now so you know that this is really
important right and so I'll go upbeat
kiss the boooo bring us back up all
right and so real estate sales team
Consulting this is a great story so I
was flown out paid way more money than I
should have been paid um to fly out and
consult with the sales team all right
they were selling mortgage leads example
I was giving earlier and they were
really excited and they wanted me to
give this ABC always be closing chat
like this huge PumpUp chat and so I
spent the first half of the day on the
script and the second half of the day
we're supposed to be drilling the sales
team right so I get on the sales team
they got I think had a nine person sales
floor and uh they're like we're having
some problems with this guy John I was
like all cool so I was like John how
good are the
leads he was
like well you know there's kind of and I
was like I'm good thank you and I was
like because if you [__] thought the
leads were were good you would say dude
they're unreal I can't believe it right
now I'm getting my mom to pass her real
estate certification so I can start
sending her leads I'm studying for mine
I'm a couple months behind but I'm
telling you as soon as I [__] get
this thing pass I'm out of here I'm G to
start buying these leads myself because
I make more than I make right now as a
sales
guy that's what you'd say if you
believed right the way you say and what
you'd say would be entirely different
and so one of the hacks on this by the
way has anyone ever gotten hot or has a
sales guy who got hot starts just
closing closing closing closing
anyone that becomes a sales training for
that
person because the way they asked the
question at what point how they
closed that's how it's perfect and so
they should study the best game footage
when they're on a streak and that's when
you can replicate it much more easily
because it's like in the wild you'll
witness it and that's when they're
Masters right in those moments all right
and so these are the actions that we do
so I'm transitioning into tactic for you
guys who have teams all right reread the
testimonials out loud daily in front of
your sales team if you got fresh ones
which you should read them makes their
day makes them feel like they're making
an impact right they're getting the [__]
kicked out of them every single day
getting hung up on getting cussed at
getting told a [__] off every day right
and like the best thing you can do is
give them a cup of coffee and says hey
man you're [__] doing good in the
world right that's what they need so do
it every day number two fix everything
you can about the product this is
obvious but I want to say it directly
like don't blame the customer for a lack
of success because it doesn't help
anyone right doesn't help them doesn't
help us if we can take ownership then we
can fix the product right three never
stop improving it so you always know
it's up to date and this is a good one
for the sales team if you're sales dip
take your head of customer support bring
them to the sales meeting and say Erica
tell these guys what you do for our
customers they're like oh well the first
day what we do is we send them this text
and we send them this letter and then we
give them swag and then we follow up
with them and then we like write them a
handwritten card and we give them a back
massage and a foot massage and then we
find a wife for them it's unbelievable
you know what I mean and then the sales
guys are like God this is [__]
awesome I'm like I know let's go sell it
right and so these are the actions that
you can do on a daily basis
to get your team to be excellent all
right and so that's how you can hack
conviction and get your team's tone
unconsciously correct by just truly
believing in the product is that cool
you think you'd sell more if you did
that hell yeah sweet thank you all right
conviction framework number two check
all right number three scaling framework
how to easily duplicate this process
across sales people in any niche in
seven days or less all right so we've
talked about closure framework we talked
about conviction framework and this is
the oops I think I going to skip one oh
no where you are back great so when I
showed my sales team this stuff they
didn't do it every time all right
because you're probably going to come
back from here all gung-ho you might
show them this video and they're like
yeah and they go raw ra for two to three
days and then it's like back to normal
right no one wants that so piece by
piece we implemented processes to get
the same outcome over and over and over
again because of the $10 million we've
sold which is crazy it's been 100% over
the phone no one over the age of 20 no
we got one guy who's 40 but Bey besides
him everyone's younger than $27 $27 27
years old all right like these aren't
like crazy you know what I mean like
crazy veterans right they just do this
process over again you get the right
thing as a total
aside find people and educate them about
your prospect not your
product that's a big [__] up because
like they shouldn't even be talking that
much about the product they should be
knowing everything about the Prospect
and so right now if your sales training
is focused on your product Doing It
Wrong these are the six C's that I use
to scale teams from little guy to lots
of guys all right so this still a you
know we Ed this to build a 3,000 person
affiliate base in our physical Products
Company it added 35 million in sales
which is cool which is awesome and so I
will show you how this works all right
and so um we've used these sales teams
and this is how we've kind of these were
all multi-figure teams and I'll show you
what we did all right so closure
sequence is the first C which we went
over earlier the second C is consistent
daily training and conviction and I'll
show you how to do each of these call
recordings you got to record them
communication Cycles cuts and
competition those are the six C's all
right so number one make sure you have a
question based framework that follows
those steps in the script it should just
be questions it's so much easier to just
follow questions because if someone's
out and you know out in left field you
know wandering on like onto the highway
you're like whoa hey come back over here
this is the next question in this
process so thank you so much for sharing
that that must have been so hard for you
so what do you think that brought right
you go right into the next question the
sale all right
number two uh consistent daily training
this is the number one thing if you take
one thing away from this besides
conviction because that'll do more for
yourselves than anything this is the
second biggest thing all right is that
daily training our team trains 60
minutes a day five days a week we
actually do twice a day stuff but that's
okay anyways for right now if you just
do this you'll already be way better
than everyone else in your in your
Market all right so we do talking and
listening because a salesperson needs to
know how to speak the right tone you
know how to listen right and so we drill
both scales we're talking we have them
read the script out loud and the
questions with the correct tonality for
25 minutes and if they [__] up they
start again simple five minutes we drill
obstacle overcomes I need to think about
it I'm not sure I don't have the money
can't afford that right now I got to
talk to my partner right I know what's
going to work in my market or whatever
your specific obstacles are because
those when they're in the Red Zone they
shouldn't have to think about those so
the only two things that someone will
ever truly memorize will be those 30
second anecdotal stories I mentioned
earlier and your obstacle overcomes it
makes it much easier to get new people
on the
team listening so every day we listen to
a 30 minute recording and we'll go with
what went right in this call what went
wrong what are you going to do next time
very simple right you play the call
everyone watches it's game tape review
we're like man you got kicked in the
balls on this one right but you had
great report in the first 5
minutes right um you're like what went
wrong and that was about it
um and what you going to do next time
I'm going to transition from the report
of the question asking without sounding
like a douchebag fantastic all right
next day and you continue to improve I
know this sounds crazy simple but it's
so simple no one will do it so number
three C's is call recordings if you
don't call like record your calls one
you're not compliant but two like how
are you going to study game film you
know what I mean everybody's got all
their data and you've got your mouse
tracking on all the pages I'm like how
where's the mouse tracking on the calls
right that's where that's where you're
going to train your team this is like
every NBA team they play game and they
watch the game footage right why are we
not doing that with the sales team and
so you have to record it if you use zoom
gong is absolutely the best highly
recommend it it's been awesome we us
this for two years they'll tell you
exactly how many minutes people are
talking versus someone else they'll tell
you who's talking the most where how
many questions were asked if the AI they
have there is unbelievable um it's
expensive but it's worth it four com
cycles and feedback um I don't know if
you guys have heard the story but if I
were trying to uh fix your golf swing
right and I said okay so I take a swing
looking like I do like a like an idiot
right he's like all right man well first
off lose 40 lbs so you can rotate all
right after you do that uh change your
wrist by two degrees turn your other
hand over put your thumb underneath I
need you to take your first foot put it
forward and then point it the other way
and then put this foot back and try
again I'm [__] no chance of swinging
right but if he just said hey take
another 20 swins and just put one thumb
under the other one I'd have one thing
to work on I could probably get better
and so when you're training and this is
for the sales directors if you're
helping them out with that call what
went right what went wrong the what am I
going to do about it is the one thing do
that makees sense and so in terms of
communication Cycles we do weekly with
the team we've got daily training we've
got daily wrap-up at the end which is
really just to pump up and kiss them on
the forehead good night to make sure
they feel okay right because they do get
punched in the face all day so it's it's
worth being like hey you see Derrick's
overcome this morning it's [__]
awesome he killed it let's watch that as
like highlight footage like watch him
say he's going to have to talk to wife
Bo overcome right and then and then
they're like dude you killed it and then
it just makes them feel like they're
part of the team right and so that's
where we do the feedback and the
communication cycles and then we do once
a once a week if they're new we'll do
one of ones if they're a little bit
older we'll do once every other week
does that make sense can you use this
right now what I'm giving you for your
sales teams okay
sweet number five cut the fat cut it
fast um Randy probably knows this better
than
anyone when you hire sales people at
least in my experience like it's Sinker
swim like if a guys if guys can't close
in the first week to two weeks unless
it's some sort of crazy complex thing
they ain't closing right and then I've
got somebody who now came in neutral now
they feel like they suck right they're
actually worse than someone who's new
because now I got to overcome all your
beliefs and then bring you back up and
so in my experience it's been much
easier to take a six and get him to a
nine than try and take than try and take
a two and get him to a five it's more
work and it's not good for me or him
right does that make sense so in most
cases does anyone have a salesperson
that you've been waiting for them to
turn the corner for the last like six
months they're not going to turn the
corner unless they have like a come to
Jesus moment which does happen but it
doesn't need to happen on my team you
can do that and come back right all
right number six competition and career
path all right A big one so salespeople
are competitive right as they should be
right they are hunters and they should
go hunt and so having competition on a
regular basis what we have found is that
six we Cycles tends to work best it is
long enough that believe they can
accomplish something but short enough
they believe it's going to happen soon
and so we run our competitions on six we
Cycles um for us I think what you said
uh whatever Ryan said about the
percentages 10 to 15% actually works
pretty well as like a group goal um when
we have those as like top salesperson we
like we did like weekend to Vegas so
we'll split all the guys up we like four
teams of four you know what I mean and
they're all comp so it's like you get
the the competitiveness but you still
get the camaraderie CU if it's just one
you know one versus everyone sometimes
they can get um a little bit too you
know teethy uh so having like little
mini teams helps too because then you
can you can kind of like make it an
adjusted draft you can put the best guy
with the worst guy and then he helps him
out and he speeds him up does that make
sense and then career path this is one
that I probably learned later but it's
really good is that you can have minor
Minor Road uh Milestones like 50 deals
closed 100 deals closed 150 deals closed
right and they just get a little just a
little you know they go from 500 a deal
to 525 a deal right they go from 525 a
deal to 550 a deal just the fact fact
that there's this this road map of where
they're going and there's actual
progress because sales is one of the
most repetitive positions in the
world just the fact that they're doing
this and they something is changing on
the outside I think just helps relieve
anxiety and help the guys Focus so that
is one of the things that I would
recommend doing um with the career path
and then obviously if you have roles
like depending how big your team is
manager Etc and you can move up um
something that I don't have on here that
I will add is that um this seems to be
common practice but remember dumbest
marketer on Earth um outbound and
inbound uh keep them separated we also
have Setters and closers for both of
those teams so outbound sets are
different than inbound sets which go to
different in closers on either side
right because the prospects are a little
bit different right and so if you if you
have lots of different types of leads
going to the same person you're probably
losing a lot of efficiency and if you
don't have that much lead flow that's
another issue but it's it's as soon as
you can separating them out will get you
a lot a lot higher conversion rates all
right so I'll recap this this six for
scale in our closure sequence make sure
it's in a question based framework daily
trainings and conviction so you're
reading the testimonies every day you're
training them every morning on talking
listing the most valuable skills that a
Salesman can have call recordings to
make sure that they're actually doing
you have game tap footage to actually
look at communication Cycles to actually
improve on their skills based on the
game footage that we just had you cut
the bottom people who are just dragging
the team down that probably just don't
have the makeup for this and then you
keep it competitive and you give them a
career past so they have something to
look forward to in the future all right
and so uh now you can understand how
anyone can sell expensive FX paper Pro
even if you don't think you're any good
which is completely normal yeah that's
sales